Ich will ein Schwimmbad bauen und dann da drin so reinspringen und da drin so schwimmen. Und mir dann so rundherum so Pferde kaufen, die mir die dabei so zugucken. Und dann, wenn ich rausgehe aus dem Geldschwimmbad, dann will ich auf so ein Pferd gehen und damit so wegreiten. Ich bin eher so der Leckertyp, ich leck die so nach hinten, aber keine Ahnung, so jetzt mittlerweile ist es klassisch, ich steh immer so locker luftig. Ich glaub, gefällt es ein paar Leuten, die mich mögen besser.
Wer kennt diesen Mann? Tim vielleicht vom Millern-Ton, denn vielleicht spielt er bald bei St. Pauli. Na, Tim, freust du dich? Hallo?
Unfassbar, auf die Gespräche in der Mixed Zone hab ich richtig Bock. Allein deswegen muss das passieren.
Ja gut, wir sollten ja Menschen nicht anhand eines YouTube-Videos beurteilen, aber dieser Ton von Donis Avdicay ist einfach in positiver Erinnerung geblieben oder zumindest in Erinnerung geblieben. Und es war ehrlicherweise auch nur Zufall, dass ich den ausgewählt hab. Und dann hast du mir erst von diesen Transfergerüchten erzählt.
Ich befasse mich überhaupt gar nicht, nie mit Transfergerüchen. Ich weiß gar nicht, ich lese das immer erst, wenn es vermeldet wird.
Ja, du hast das auch nicht noch gecheckt kurz vor der Sendung. Na ja, also erst mal Hallo und herzlich willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, lieber Tim. Dich habe ich jetzt gleich schon vorgestellt. Ich bin der Max. Das solltet ihr wahrscheinlich wissen, wenn ihr den Rasenfunk hört. Ich habe hier aber neben Tim noch zwei weitere Gäste, und zwar Matthias Kneifl, unseren alten Darmstadt-Experten, der jetzt dann wieder in der ersten Liga auch mitsprechen darf. Hallo Matthias, schön, dass du hier bist.
Ja, servus, hallo zusammen. Kaum zu fassen. 2017 dachte ich, es wäre ein Abschied für immer schon fast, aber was soll ich sagen, wir sind zurück.
Ja, weißt du, da bin ich extra, habe ich extra dann Zweitligasendungen angefangen und so weiter. Und jetzt muss ich mit dem Abstieg von Bielefeld wahrscheinlich über Drittligasendungen nachdenken. Es ist einfach ein absoluter Skandal. Aber was soll man machen? Schön, dass du hier bist und schön, dass auch Michael Fischer hier ist. Von den Nürnberger Nachrichten und der Nürnberger Zeitung und dem 4. Flachpass natürlich, dem FÜT-Podcast. Hallo Michi, schön, dass du da bist.
Hallo Max, danke für die Einladung. Und es beweist, dass du ein großer Profi bist, weil du natürlich Matthias Einlitz und mich nachdem Darmstadt und FÜT am letzten Spieltag gegeneinander gespielt haben.
Das ist natürlich auch Ziel der Sendung, dass wir das nochmal… Also eigentlich wollte ich auch nur dieses Spiel noch besprechen. Ich wollte es ankündigen als den großen Zweitliga-Rückblick, aber eigentlich wollte ich nur Minute bei Minute, nennt man das, was ich machen wollte. So wie dieser Matrix-Podcast, der immer eine Minute…
Damit wäre ich raus, offen gestanden. Danke für die Einladung, aber über das letzte Spiel möchte ich nicht sprechen.
Sitzt denn der Schmerz so tief, Matthias, dass es nicht mit der Zweitligameisterschaft geklappt hat?
Also, mich hat es offen gestanden wirklich schon ein bisschen genervt, muss ich sagen, weil wenn man seit Oktober führt und demzufolge was zählbares in die Vitrine stellen kann, neben ein paar Miljönchen vielleicht auch aus den TV-Geldern, dann wäre das nicht schlecht gewesen. Also, ich fand es ein bisschen blöd, wie es gelaufen ist. Es gab auch innerhalb der Fan-Community bei Lilien recht unterschiedliche Meinungen dazu, die einen sagen, was soll es, scheißegal. Auch Präsident Fritsch hat gesagt, scheiß auf die Kirsche, wir haben die ganze Torte. Insofern, der Bundesliga-Aufstieg ist für ihn die Torte und das sei ja auch nicht gering zu schätzen. Aber deshalb sagten einige, das wichtige Spiel war eine Woche davor, das haben wir gewonnen, damit ist der Aufstieg besiegelt und was soll das letzte Spiel und die Jungs dürfen nach Mallorca fahren, um quasi die Feste zu feiern, wie sie fallen und andere, unter anderem mich gab es die dann schon ein bisschen knirscht waren, weil der letzte Eindruck aus der Saison, dieses 0 zu 4, das hätte nicht sein müssen. Es hatte Gründe, Platz war wahrscheinlich nicht ganz unwichtig, in der Hinsicht 60 Minuten Nutzerzahl und dann war wahrscheinlich mit dem 0 zu 1 einfach der Egalfaktor an bei den Kikern. Den kann man ihnen vielleicht auch nicht verübeln, aber ich hätte schon gern die Felge, muss ich sagen.
Ja gut, aber in Fürth, da sind schon andere Mannschaften zerstellt. Nicht, dass mir jetzt gerade eine einfiele, aber Michael, vielleicht.
Ja gut, dass Eva nicht da ist.
Ja, aber Bielefeld ist ja noch an ganz anderen Dingen gestellt. Wir schicken ganz liebe Besserungswünsche an Eva, die eigentlich hier hätte mit dabei sein sollen, aber es leider nicht kann. Es hat nichts mit dem Abstieg zu tun, sondern hat andere Gründe. Schade, dass sie nicht hier ist. Aber ich will nicht gleich mit den negativen Themen starten. Ich erkläre noch kurz, wie man den Rasenfunk unterstützen kann. Und dann reden wir mal erst mal über die Tabellenspitze und über das, was da sich noch getan hat am Schluss. Der Rasenfunk ist werbe-payable und sponsoranfrei. Ihr wisst es, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Unterstützt uns bitte auf rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club. Ich habe das im Rasenfunk-Royal so oft gesagt, dass ich mir total doof vorkomme, das jetzt schon wieder zu tun. Wer immer noch nicht weiß, dass wir rein crowdfinanziert sind und dass wir nur so unabhängigen Journalismus machen können, der hat sich nur nicht genug mit dem Rasenfunk auseinandergesetzt. rasenfunk.de slash-supporters-club, da findet ihr alle Infos. Und jetzt blicken wir dann mal auf die Tabellenspitze, auf die beiden Aufsteiger. Drei sind es ja nicht geworden. Über den HSV reden wir gleich ein bisschen. Ja. Ich wollte noch sagen, vielleicht stelle ich da die erste Frage an jemand anderen, aber das kriegen wir sicherlich hin. Aber jetzt erstmal über Heidenheim und Darmstadt. Die Art und Weise war so, wie es in der 2. Liga sein musste. Vielleicht frage ich mal, fangen wir mal mit Michi an, denn der konnte sich dank eines 4 zu 0s gegen Darmstadt ja völlig entspannt dieses Spektakel mitverfolgen. Ich nehme an, das Spiel in Fürth war dann gar nicht mehr so wichtig. Dieser letzte Spieltag mit dem Ausstieg von Heidenheim in der Nachspielzeit gegen Regensburg. Sie lagen 0 zu 2 zurück. Sie schießen direkt das 1 zu 2. Und dann gibt es eben diese lange Nachspielzeit und noch all das, was dann in Sandhausen passiert ist mit dem HSV. Es musste eigentlich so kommen nach dieser Bundesligasaison, dass da noch so was draufkommt.
Es musste auch so kommen, weil ich im letzten Rasenfunk-Kurzpass ja getippt habe, dass der HSV in die Relegation kommt und ich mir schon schlecht vorkam, dass es dann doch nicht so war. Es war dann so. Und auch dieser ganze letzte Spieltag war für Matthias nicht witzig, für mich endgemaßen schon witzig, weil ich tatsächlich meinen Spielbericht fertiggeschrieben hatte und habe eine freudige Erwartung geschrieben, der Viertel schlägt den Zweitligameister und bin in die Mixed Zone zu den Interviews gegangen und habe dann den Fernsehbildschirm gesehen und die vielen Darmstädter Spieler, die auch da vor dem Sky-Bildschirm standen und dann hatte ich auch die Meistermedaillen schon gesehen, insgesamt gehüllt im Spielertunnel. Ja, und dann habe ich diese beiden Tore eigentlich am Handy mitbekommen. So erlebt man als Journalist einen spannenden Spieltag am Ende, aber es spricht dann auch für den 1. FC Heidenheim, wenn wir vielleicht damit anfangen, dass es in der Nachspielzeit das so noch hinkriegt. Das hätten nicht viele Mannschaften wahrscheinlich geschafft, der 1. FC Heidenheim hat es geschafft. Auch in Fürth ist immer ein Thema, dass die Heidenheimer nie aufhören, als Fürth 2018 fast abgestiegen wäre. Hätte Heidenheim auch noch fast nur das 2-1 gemacht, dann wäre Fürth abgestiegen. Diese Mannschaft hat diesen Willen auch nie aufzuhören, egal wann, egal wie.
Ja, Matthias muss da etwas betrüppelt zwar, aber er muss nicken, der Verweis auf die Medaillen. Er hat dir wehgetan, wir haben es dir deutlich in deinem Blick gesehen. Aber das ist schon das, was man festhalten muss. Neben all den Dingen, die man natürlich zu Heidenheim sagen kann und zu Größe der Stadt und des Vereins und der Fanlager und so weiter und so fort. Aber es ist nicht die Schuld vom 1. FC Heidenheim, dass die 1. Liga Attraktivitätsprobleme hat. Deswegen sollte man das vielleicht nicht auf ihre Schultern abladen. Aber es ist eben einfach sehr konstant, was dann in Heidenheim passiert. Nur fünf Niederlagen. Es gibt kein Team, das so selten verloren hat in dieser Saison. Darmstadt 7 Niederlagen, der HSV und St. Pauli 8 Niederlagen. Und dann sind wir schon im zweistelligen Bereich. Das ist letztlich das, was da jeden einzelnen dieser 67 Punkte ermöglicht hat.
Ja, ich würde auch sagen, dass der letzte Spieltag auch so mit die Ausgeburt dessen war, was Heidenheim auch darstellt. Also diese Mentalität und auch diese Wucht, die die Mannschaft auf dem Platz bringen kann. Ich finde, Heidenheim hat es zum Schluss dann verdientermaßen auf Platz 1 geschafft und auf jeden Fall auch verdientermaßen den Gang in die Erstklassigkeit, weil sie ja beständig sich weiterentwickelt haben. Also es ist ja ein Verein, der ich glaube, beim letzten Kurzpass, bei dem ich zu Gast war, hatte ich gesagt, dass sie, glaube ich, nie schlechter als Platz 8 oder so was in der zweiten Liga waren. Also auf jeden Fall immer weit entfernt von niederen Tabellenregionen und sie haben es auch durch kluge Transferpolitik geschafft, sich immer weiter zu verstärken, ohne jetzt die Hochkaräter zu verpflichten, vermeintlich, sondern einfach auch Leute, die in dieses Bündel Heidenheim reinpassen. Und deshalb war das für mich, wie ich damals glaube ich auch meinte, fast schon überfällig, dass die mal dran sind gegen Werder, vor drei Jahren haben sie ja fast schon dran gekratzt. Und jetzt haben sie es vollendet und ich muss sagen, das ist dann schon verdientermaßen, zweifelsohne.
Tim, wie blickst du auf Heidenheim?
Ja, tatsächlich auch ähnlich wie Matthias. Das ist die logische Konsequenz von jahrelanger, guter Arbeit und immer wieder guter Platzierung. Und dann verliert man gute Spieler, oder die besten Spieler gehen weg nach der Saison, wenn man irgendwie in den Top 6 landet, aber nicht aufsteigt. Aber ein, zwei bleiben dann vielleicht doch hängen im Geflecht und wenn das dann immer mehr und mehr Stück für Stück immer ein bisschen mehr wird, dann hat man irgendwann so ein Kader zusammen und dann holt man noch jemanden wie Tim Kleindienst zurück und hat dann in der Saison, in dieser einen Saison dann natürlich dann auch das Glück, dass so ein Spieler wie Adrian Beck, dass der einschlägt, dass der eine super Hinrunde gespielt hat, aus der Regionalliga hochkommt, dass sowas funktioniert, dass man dann Moa zwar verliert, das ist dieser eine Spieler, den man verloren hat, bei dem man gesagt hat, den hast du verloren in die Bundesliga, weil der schneller gewachsen ist als der Verein im Grunde und dann holst du die Jan-Niklas Beste, der im Grunde, also der hat das schon tätowiert auf seiner Spielweise, Ich glaube, dass er zu einer Heidenheim gehört und das ist einfach das. Es hat einfach dieses Jahr alles ineinander gefasst und logische Konsequenz. Und Frank Schmidt hat das einfach als Trainer, als Mensch, glaube ich, auch einfach verdient. Und wenn man sich auch anschaut, wie er da in der Pressekonferenz von seinen Spielern überfallen wurde, da gibt es ja dieses Video, wo man dann doch gesehen hat, dass er das überhaupt nicht witzig findet, allein aus Respekt. Allein den abgestiegenen Regensburgern gegenüber, das finde ich schon bemerkenswert. Ich bin gespannt, wie die sich in der ersten Liga machen. Weil dieser Fußball, den die spielen, dieses enorm physische, sehr konterstarke Spiel, das kannst du auch als kleiner Fisch in der ersten Liga spielen. Da werden bestimmt so die einen oder anderen Erstligisten, die ganz schön Probleme haben mit Heidenheim.
Das glaube ich nämlich auch. Ich glaube, der Trend geht gerade wieder dahin, im Fußball generell in Deutschland, dass diejenigen, die sehr gut verteidigen können, einen enormen Vorteil haben, weil sie gewisse Dinge nicht mehr zulassen, auf die alle anderen spekulieren. So erkläre ich mir unter anderem den Erfolg von Union Berlin und auch vom SC Freiburg in Teilen. Ich glaube auch, dass Heidenheim so richtig ein unangenehmer Gegner werden könnte und dann so ein bisschen so Matthias wie damals Darmstadt in der ersten Saison, da war die Spielweise natürlich schon noch ein bisschen anders, aber einfach dieses Überraschungsmoment für sich auch nutzt. Und da war es doch auch, glaube ich, der Saisonstart von Darmstadt, der ganz gut war.
Ja, also Darmstadt hatte in der ersten Saison, die dann quasi auch zum Klassenerhalt führte, erst mal immer gepunktet an den ersten drei Spieltagen mit Unentschieden und dann kam Siegen Leverkusen dazu und dann hat man sich immer über dem Strich gehalten und damals war so ein Credo von Dirk Schuster, immer mehr Punkte auf dem Konto zu haben als Spieltage gespielt sind und das hat er in der ersten Saison sehr gut mit seinem Team auf die Reihe gekriegt und dann verließ uns er Richtung Augsburg. Dann kamen eher Pleitenpech und Pannen zusammen, weil einfach der Verein nicht so gefestigt war, um irgendwie den Königsmacher in der Hinsicht Schuster zu ersetzen, der quasi ein Mannbetrieb war an der Kommandobrücke. Aber ich finde, damals mit uns hochgegangen ist auch Ingolstadt. Die haben sich auch gehalten seiner Zeit. Und das war ja eine ähnlich kleine Nummer. Vielleicht auch da der Wiederkehrer in Form von Heidenheim, von damals von Ingolstadt, die Pascal Groß zum Beispiel auch seiner Zeit im Team hatten, der jetzt schon seit eben Zeit in der Premier League reüssiert, was man ihm damals, glaube ich, nicht zugestanden hätte. Also ich glaube auch, Heidenheim ist unangenehm. Und wer die auf die leichte Schulter nimmt, der hat ein Problem, definitiv.
Das war damals noch unter Hasenhüttel im 4-3-3 und mit hohem Pressing. Da kam natürlich noch ein taktischer Kniff mit dazu bei Ingolstadt. Ich denke, wir müssen aber noch kurz über Tim Kleindienst sprechen, der ja auch die Torjäger-Kanone in der 2. Liga gewonnen hat. Mit 25 Treffern, Jan-Niklas Späste mit 12 Treffern, jetzt auch nicht so weit dahinter. Also das sind dann schon mal 37 der 67 Treffer, die Heidenheim gemacht hat. Michi, was macht so jemanden wie Kleindienst aus? Ist das auch der richtige Spieler am richtigen Ort? Kannst du dir vorstellen, er hatte ja auch schon ein paar andere Vereine. Und das war ja eine Rückholaktion, die ihn nach Heidenheim gebracht hat. Funktioniert er da besonders gut oder wie würdest du das einschätzen?
Er funktioniert auf jeden Fall perfekt. Er ist der perfekte Spieler im perfekten Ort, das kann man sagen. Also ich habe vorher der Aufnahme noch mal auch die offiziellen Bundesliga.de-Statistik noch mal durchgescrollt. Da führt er überall. Du hast die teure Kanone genannt. Bei der Abschlusseffizienz plus 11,2 steht hier. Er hat auch sehr viel aus den Möglichkeiten gemacht. Da wird Tim wahrscheinlich mit XG-Werten noch nachhelfen können. Aber auch wenn ich hier weitergehe, bei den Zweikämpfen hat er die meisten geführt. Er führt die intensiven Läufe an. Bei den Sprints ist er weit oben. Er ist auch für diese Heidenheimer Spielweise sehr intensiv prägend. Man kann ihn nicht nur an den Toren bemessen. Deswegen wäre es für Heidenheimer auch ein großer Verlust, wenn sie ihn verlieren würden. Ich weiß nicht, wie der Aktuelle Stand das vor einigen Wochen wurde. Er wurde mal interviewt und hat so viele Sagen darauf geantwortet, ob er weiterhin in Heidenheim spielt. Ich denke, er könnte auch für andere Vereine interessant sein, dieses Paket aus der Physis, die er mitbringt unter Torgefahr. Aber das wäre für ihn auch eine schöne Geschichte, mit Heidenheim in der Bundesliga zu bleiben, mit Frank Schmidt, mit seinem größten Förderer. Er wurde ja auch außerhalb von Heidenheim nicht so glücklich, wie er in Heidenheim bislang ist. Ich würde es mir auch wünschen für den 1. FC Heidenheim. Das wäre eine schöne Geschichte, wenn sie den jetzt verlieren. Denn zu ersetzen, wäre extrem schwierig mit so einem physischen Stürmer, der so treffsicher ist. Er ist nicht nur an einem guten Ort, sondern er ist am perfekten Ort als perfekter Spieler.
Da stimme ich tatsächlich mit ein, vielleicht auch, weil er eben schon die Erfahrung hatte, weggegangen zu sein und dann dort nicht den Erfolg zu haben und wieder zurückgekommen zu sein und dann durchzustarten. Zumindest jetzt in dieser Saison kann ich mir offenbar nicht ausmalen, dass er jetzt einen anderen Weg einschlägt, sondern dass er weiß, das Gesamtpaket stimmt in Heidenheim. Hier hat er eben die Leute um sich herum, die ihn bedienen. Aber was mir auch damals als die Lilien in Heidenheim nach ewigen Zeiten wieder verloren hatten, im März auf der kalten Schwäbischen Alp, da war es dann so, dass es mich überrascht hat, dass er tatsächlich schon auch am Spiel teilnimmt. Also er ist jetzt kein Knipser, der irgendwie im Strafraum oder um den Strafraum wartet, bis er bedient wird, sondern er ist auch ein Spieler, der sozusagen den Angriff mit einleitet. Und das fand ich damals zumindest in dem Spiel isoliert betrachtet sehr bemerkenswert, dass er eben nicht nur der Finisher ist, sondern dass er auch was zum Spiel beiträgt und auch einen gewissen Bewegungsradius hat. Und um vielleicht noch mal einen Gedanken abzuschließen, den ich mir gerade hier so nochmal vor Augen geführt habe, es ist ja nicht nur Tim Kleindienst. Also sie haben ja wirklich eine gewachsene Struktur. Manon Busch zum Beispiel kam ja glaube ich seinerzeit in Bremen in die Bundesliga und wurde vermutlich für ein bisschen zu leicht empfunden. Und hat sich jetzt aber in Heidenheim schon jahrelang einen Namen gemacht auf der Außenbahn oder auch Mein Car als Defensivstabilisator und Kapitän, der damals mit dem Christoph Zimmermann, der bei Lille jetzt zurückgekommen ist, beim BVB 2 gespielt hat. Und beide treffen sich jetzt nächstes Jahr wieder in der Bundesliga. Das ist auch eine schöne Geschichte. Maloney kam auch unter Klassik und ist ein absoluter Anker-Spieler im Mittelfeld. Also auch so einer, der glaube ich nicht totzukriegen ist in puncto Laufwerte. Auch stark und so könnte man noch ein paar andere nennen, ohne jetzt dann nur auf Kleindienst sich zu versteifen. Also da ist schon wirklich ein Gesamtpaket am Start meines Erachtens.
Ja, ich finde, was man bei Tim Kleindienst –ich will gar nicht zu viel auf Heidenheim rumweiten, aber das finde ich total wichtig –der letzte Saison hat er ja nicht so getroffen tatsächlich auch. Er hatte da so ein kleines Tief, aber trotzdem der Impact von ihm war immer noch unfassbar groß, weil der gerade für dieses Pressing, für dieses hohe, für dieses intensive Anlaufen so wichtig ist. Ich glaube, es war Frank Schmidt –aber das ist schon fünf, sechs Jahre her –der hat ihn mal als den besten Defensivspieler der Liga bezeichnet. Und das fand ich damals total spannend, weil ich das überhaupt nicht auf dem Zettel hatte und Tim Kleindienst nie so richtig darauf geachtet hatte und den irgendwie anders verortet hatte. Und dann sagte –ja, ich meine, es war Frank Schmidt –das ist der beste Defensivspieler der Liga. Und dann habe ich darauf geachtet und gesehen, was der abreißt. Also, wie du hast gesagt, die meisten Zweikämpfe in der Liga geführt. Da zählen natürlich auch die Defensiv-Zweikämpfereien. Und was der da an Kilometern frisst für das Team, das ist schon bemerkenswert. Fernab von den ganzen Toren, also der Impact auf so ein Team, der ist echt unfassbar groß und nicht nur mit Toren und Torabschlüssen und Offensivaktionen zu bemessen von ihm.
Ja, er ist so ein bisschen eine Mischung aus Höhler und Hoffmann. Höhler bei Freiburg, der auch mal so wahnsinnig viele Zweikämpfe hat, auch sehr wichtig ist im Anlaufen. Und Hoffmann, der einfach jedes Kopfball-Duell gewinnt. Der hat sogar Kleindienst, vergleichbare Zahlen, 248 gewonnene Kopfball-Duelle. Rang 2 hat da schon über 50 Kopfbälle weniger. Also das ist schon wirklich sehr deutlich.
Und das bemerkenswerte bei der Statistik. Gestern habe ich einen Artikel geschrieben, da habe ich mich mit Ragnar Ache befasst, der ja bei Michael Fischer ja durchaus bekannt sein sollte. Und der führt irgendwie 10 Kopfball-Duelle pro Spiel. Und gewinnt davon knapp mehr als 50 Prozent. Und eine Quote von knapp mehr als 50 Prozent ist ja für einen Stürmer schon mal ein Riesenwert. Und da ist ganz vorne Tim Kleindienst, der 13 Kopfball-Duelle pro Spiel führt, was schon fast top ist. Aber der gewinnt halt 60 Prozent seiner Kopfball-Duelle. Also das ist –oder hat er dieses Jahr gewonnen –das ist unfassbar, was der für Zahlen vorgelegt hat. Das ist wirklich unfassbar.
Das war auch im Hinspiel, als die Lilien gegen Heidenheim 2 zu 2 gespielt hatten. Da hat er zum 2 zu 2 ausgeglichen durch einen Kopfball. Und ich glaube, sein Gegenspieler, in dem Fall Jannik Müller, der muss es bis heute noch fühlen, weil der wirkte wie vom Bus überranend. Also es war unglaublich, mit welcher Wucht er in dieses Kopfball-Duell ging. Da war schon fast die Frage, ist das überhaupt noch fair? Ja, aber es war auf jeden Fall eine enorme Präsenz.
Ja, lustig. Vor allem, dass wir quasi von dem Argument herkommen. Eigentlich kann man bei Heidenheim kaum jemanden so richtig rausheben. Und wir sollten nicht nur über Kleindienst sprechen. Und dann reden wir am Ende dann doch wieder nur über Kleindienst. Vielleicht noch zwei, drei Worte zum Trainer, weil ihr den ja jetzt auch schon sehr lange begleitet. Ich meine, es ist einer der Trainer, die quasi an der Kopfhaltung erkennbar sind. Der schräg gestellte Kopf, so verfolgt er eigentlich alles. Woher auch immer das kommt. Aber Frank Schmidt wird jetzt auch im Herbst, glaube ich, Volker Finke als dienstältester Bundesligatrainer ablösen. Wenn es jetzt dann losgeht, wenn ich mich da richtig erinnere. Es kommt jetzt nämlich auch ein Buch zu ihm heraus. Da hatte ich nämlich jetzt gerade ein bisschen Kontakt mit dem Verlag. Und da haben wir so ein bisschen hin und her geschrieben. Michi, du hast ja viel mit Trainern zu tun gehabt als Reporter der Spielvereinigung. Wie hat denn Frank Schmidt, also welchen Eindruck hat er auf dich hinterlassen?
Es ist blöd, immer mit dem Alexander Zorniger Beispiel in Fürth anzufangen. Aber der ist ja ein Trainer, da könntest du auch sehr viele O-Töne einspielen hier. Der hat sehr viele schöne Dinge auch erzählt. Die Pika's machen sehr viel Spaß, wenn der in Fürth ist. Auch in Hamburg war es ja für Tim witzig damals. Aber er hat damals gesagt, er kennt ja auch Frank Schmidt schon sehr lange. Die kommen ja beide dem Idiom nach aus derselben Gegend. Also beide von der Schwäbischen Alb. Und er hat erzählt, dass er mal in Heidenheim war, als er als Zorniger arbeitslos war, kurzzeitig mal. Und dann gab es anscheinend, soll es eine Ehrung geben für Frank Schmidt für 15 Jahre. Und dann hat sich Frank Schmidt sehr darüber aufgeregt, dass er jetzt im Mittelpunkt steht und für 15 Jahre Frank Schmid sein geehrt wird. Das sagt er schon auch schon sehr viel aus über diesen Menschen, der sich am liebsten gar nicht im Mittelpunkt sehen will, der auch im Moment des Aufstiegs an den Absteiger denkt, der gerade leidet nebenbei. Also das ist menschlich einfach ein sehr, sehr großer Trainer. Und das er fachlich noch super ist, macht ihn mal zu einem sehr interessanten Gesamtpaket und wahrscheinlich auch für viele andere Vereine wäre er sehr interessant. Aber auch er weiß wahrscheinlich, dass er am Standort Heidenheim am besten funktioniert, dass es sein Verein ist, sein Projekt. Er hat das ja auch von ganz unten mit aufgebaut. Ich finde menschlich ein sehr angenehmer Mensch. Die BK in Fürth war natürlich sehr freundschaftlich zwischen den beiden, zwischen Zorniger und Frank Schmidt, aber auch ansonsten, wenn man ihn beobachtet, wenn er spricht. Also ich finde ihn an der angenehmsten Zeitgenossen vielleicht noch mit dem anderen Aufsteigertrainer zusammen. Mit Leverknecht. Da sind schon auch zwei Menschen aufgestiegen. Das fand ich eben auch schön, dass auch die Menschen aufsteigen, die auch in diesem Fußballkosmos menschgeblieben sind, die auch über den Tellerrand hinausblinken, die nicht nur in ihrem Fußball leben und in dieser Fußballwelt Erfolg aufgehen, sondern die einfach auch mensch sind. Also beide Trainer, vor allem jetzt Frank Spilber, den du nach dem gefragt hast, fand ich super. Die ganze Saison über und finde ich auch schon länger super. Also deswegen sei es ihm noch mehr gegönnt.
Ja, das leitet ja fast über zu Darmstadt und Thorsten Leverknecht. Thorsten Leverknecht, den kann man auch sehr gut taktische Fragen stellen. Das haben wir in einem der Kurzversinns diese Saison aufgearbeitet. Da hat sich Tim besonders hervorgetan. Ja, Matthias, lass mal mit Leverknecht anfangen. Was hat er denn bei Darmstadt 98 verändert? Oder vielleicht auch wieder zurückgebracht? Was ist dann letztlich in diesen Aufstieg gemündet?
Ich habe mir mal jetzt im Vorfeld seinen Interview am Anfang der Saison für den Liedenkurier durchgelesen, nochmal, weil das war quasi ein bisschen retrospektiv. Sprich, sein erster Saison am Böllenfalltor mündete ja letztes Jahr punktgleich mit dem HSV. Leider auf Platz 4, durch das schlechtere Torverhältnis. Da wurde er so gefragt, wie er die letzte Saison einschätzen würde. Er hat drei Ziele benannt, die er sich gesetzt hat und seinem Trainings-Team. Das war zum einen eine Mannschaft auf den Platz bringen, die von den Fans angenommen wird, plus Identifikationspotenzial bietet. Die offenen und mutigen Fußballspiele, also offensiven und mutigen Fußballspiele, die beiden Aspekte hat er als erfüllt betrachtet. Und was er eher mit Absprichen als erfüllt betrachtet hat, war die Variabilität im Spiel. Also er hat gesagt, ein Ziel war auch ganz klar, Variabel zu spielen. Das konnten die Lilien wohl in der Vorsaison, sprich 21, 22, nur wenn sie reagieren mussten. Also wenn sie dazu quasi gezwungen waren, Variabel zu spielen, dann hat es mehr oder weniger gut geklappt, aber nicht so per se. Und das hat jetzt in der Saison offenkundig ein bisschen besser gepasst. Und auch ganz interessant war, dass er gesagt hat, man muss die Spieler, also in demselben Interview, man muss aufpassen, dass sich Dinge nicht abnutzen. Also dass man quasi immer auch Reize setzt, neue Reize setzt. Und ich glaube, das hat man in der Umstellung auf die Dreierkette zum Beispiel gesehen. In der letzten Saison waren wir uns mit einer klassischen Viererkette gewohnt zu spielen und hatten zwar schon viele Gegentore gekriegt vergleichsweise, aber dann noch durch eine gute Offensive das Ganze irgendwie dann kaschieren können. Und dann der Stellschraube hat er jetzt mit einer Dreierkette gedreht und ich hatte mich auch mal mit dem Jens Kirschnick von Elfreunde unterhalten, der auch einen schönen Beitrag über die Ligien geschrieben hatte im Frühjahr oder im Spätwinter. Und da hat er noch so zu mir gesagt, Leberknecht hätte ihm wohl zugeraunt. Er hätte vor der Saison das gemacht, um die Spieler auch wieder zu kitzeln, also auch gedanklich wieder eine Aufgabe zu stellen. Und dass man das wohl tun sollte, um nicht irgendwie erwartbar zu sein. Und das fand ich dann auch interessant, um es mal zu paraphrasieren. Und deshalb war das schon mal ein Touch, um zu sagen, warum nicht. Wir sollten an der Stellschraube drehen, gezwungen auch durch Abgänge in der Offensive, die so nicht aufgefangen wurden. Und jetzt ende ich dann gleich mal mit meinem Manolog, weil was ihm immer sehr wichtig ist, was in vielen Gesprächen, auch mit mir hat er vor zwei Jahren vor den Lilium-Kurier gesprochen, was da für ihn rauskommt, ist Identifikation. Also Identifikation zu schaffen mit der Mannschaft und eine Ruhe im Umfeld zu haben und eine, wie soll man sagen, also dass eine Kontinuität aber im Umfeld da ist, was in Darmstadt einfach gegeben ist. Also Präsidium ist seit Jahr und Tag im Amt, er als Trainer jetzt im zweiten Jahr, aber auch ein gewachsenes Umfeld. Das heißt, hier war für ihn glaube ich schon einiges angelegt. Also es war ein ruhiges Umfeld, eine Kontinuität war jetzt über die Sommertransferperiode auch da. Es gab nicht viele Wechsel. Man hat die Identifikationsfiguren und einen Spielstil, der Identifikation stiftet. Mit dem Wort habe ich es heute, Identifikation. Und das ist für ihn wichtig, um was zu erschaffen und Erfolg zu haben. Ich denke, er hat es bewiesen. Er hat jetzt 127 Punkte in zwei Saisons. Das ist schon aller Bonheur. Letztes Jahr, als ich hier saß mit Iamax, da hatte ich noch gesagt, mir tut es ein bisschen weh, dass wir keinen Bonus mitnehmen in die neue Spielzeit. Wir hatten 60 Punkte, was für die Verhältnisse unverhältnismäßig viel war. Jetzt starteten wir wieder bei 0. Jetzt kommen wir mit 67 Punkten raus. Er hat es einfach verstanden, hier etwas zu entfachen und auch die richtigen Stellschrauben zu drehen. Ich glaube, Tim hat sich schon ein paar Mal gemeldet. Vielleicht will er noch etwas aus seiner Warte anfügen.
An der Stelle.
Habe ich mich schon gemeldet?
Du saßt eindeutig so auf wie jemand, der was sagen will. Ich hatte mir nämlich auch schon vorgenommen, jetzt erst mal die Klappe zu halten.
Ich finde es total interessant, was du gesagt hast, weil ich das bei Frank Schmidt, das ist ja fast gegenteilig. Man sagt ja so, Timo Schulz hat mal gesagt, wenn du als Trainer in drei Jahren kannst, eineinhalb Jahre was aufbauen und dann musst du das auch eineinhalb Jahre abreiten. Und er sagte aber auch, dass sich das abnutzt mit der Zeit. Da hat Lieberknecht vielleicht einfach neue Reize und die richtigen Reize gesetzt. Das finde ich dann wiederum bemerkenswert bei Frank Schmidt, der diese Regel komplett ignoriert. Einfach Christian Streicher auch. Also das ist da einfach, weiß ich nicht, ob sie vielleicht doch neue Reize setzen. Bei Frank Schmidt habe ich nicht das Gefühl, dass da so viel Neues kommt. Das meine ich gar nicht negativ, sondern dass er da doch einfach sehr direkt ist und mit dieser Art einfach gut ankommt. Bei Thorsten Lieberknecht finde ich, weil du dein neues Lieblingswort Identifikation auch so viel genutzt hast, fand ich tatsächlich das Zitat der Saison der 2. Liga ist das gewesen von Lieberknecht, als er gesagt hat, dass Trainer und Spieler zuallererst erst mal Gast sind in einem Verein und Fans deswegen das Recht haben, mit ihnen in Kontakt zu kommen. Völlig unabhängig, vereinsunabhängig, der beste Satz, den ich diese Saison auf jeden Fall von irgendwem aus dem Business gehört habe. Und den wollte ich unbedingt hier bringen, deswegen habe ich wahrscheinlich so gezappelt hier. Bevor ich das vergesse, dass ich das nochmal erwähnen wollte, wie toll ich das fand, wie in so einer Situation, wo das für den ganzen Verein ja auch um viel ging, kommt er auf einmal mit sowas um die Ecke, fand ich total klasse.
Du hast absolut recht, das ist natürlich ein Satz, der geht jedem Fan runter wie Öl. Er ist ja auch wirklich so. Trainer und Spieler gehen, die Fans bleiben. Demzufolge ist dieses Zitat zu Gast zu sein tatsächlich ziemlich treffend, aber natürlich auch, was einen anrührt in einer gewissen Art und Weise. Thorsten Lieberknecht hat sich ja auch bei seiner Abschlussarbeit zum Fußballlehrer mit einem ganz interessanten Thema auseinandergesetzt. Ich weiß nicht, was da normalerweise Vorgabe ist, aber ich zitiere mal den Titel. Er hat es genannt, Herausforderung Kultclub, der Spagat zwischen Tradition und modernem Fußball am Beispiel Eintracht Braunschweigs. Also damals war er natürlich dort als Spieler am Ende seiner Karriere und dann am Anfang seiner Trainerkarriere. Und ich glaube, ihn fasziniert es wirklich, in einem Umfeld anzukommen, wo schon was da ist, wo eine Tradition da ist, wo aber auch noch nicht überwortend ist, also wo noch ein Umfeld ist, das geschlossen werden kann zwischen Stadt, Verein, Umfeld. Und das glaubte er damals schon. Da war er gerade erst zehn Tage im Amt, in Darmstadt durchaus vorfinden zu können oder es zumindest entfachen zu können. So eine gewisse Symbiose aus allem. Und wie ich vorhin sagte, also für ihn ist Ruhe im Verein und Kontinuität sehr wichtig, um dann wiederum Identifikationen stiften zu können, Erfolg zu haben, Step by Step. Und was soll ich sagen, hat es wirklich gut geschafft mit Platz 4 und Platz 2. Also da kann man nicht mehr kann.
Die von Matthias angesprochene Stabilität und Kontinuität in so einem Verein ist natürlich auch in dieser Saison, sowohl in der ersten als auch in der zweiten Liga, unabhängig auch von Darmstadt, schon so ein Schluss, den man aus der Saison ziehen kann. Also Darmstadt und Heidenheim sind aufgestiegen, in der Bundesliga die Geschichte von Union, Freiburg, sind ja alles so ähnliche Geschichten von Vereinen, die eine gewisse Ruhe haben, in der es keine Aufgeregtheit gibt, in der es nicht 50 Aufsichtsräte gibt, die ständig irgendwelche Infos durchstechen, wo die Menschen in Ruhe arbeiten können, mit einer gewissen Identität, eine gewisse Spielphilosophie, wo man sich einfach treu bleibt. Es sind ja so viele Parallelen. Klar sind das alles unterschiedliche Standorte, unterschiedliche Probleme und auch Herausforderungen. Aber die Grundidee ist da, finde ich, schon dieselbe. Und es ist sehr schön zu sehen, dass das auch bei vielen Vereinen geht und dass es im Fußball nicht nur darum geht, die besten Spieler für möglichst viel Geld zusammenzukaufen und zu sagen, wir wollen aufsteigen, weil dann klappt es meistens nicht. Nein, das war kein Erfolg gegenüber dem HSV, sondern auch andere Vereine wollen das ja erreichen und schaffen es dann eben auch nicht. Das fand ich sehr schön, diese Saison über die Ligen hinwegzusehen, weil der Rasenfunk ist ja auch so ein liegenübergreifendes Projekt. Da war es dann schön. Als reiner Fußballfan, als Fußballromantiker ist es ja schön, das zu sehen, auch neben den beruflichen.
Und auch wenn du mir damit eigentlich schon die perfekte Brücke zum HSV gebaut hättest, will ich aber noch nicht drüber gehen, über diese Brücke. Ich will nochmal bei Darmstadt bleiben. Denn ich habe eine Frage an dich, Matthias. Also das mit den neuen Reizen, die Torsten lieber Knecht setzen will, alles klar. Da kann man aber auch viele Dinge verändern. Da muss man ja nicht gleich für das Spielsystem auch komplett über den Haufen werfen. Könnte das vielleicht auch den Grund gehabt haben, dass man in der letzten Saison zwar sehr viele Tore geschossen hat, 71, zweitbeste Offensive der Liga, aber man hat mit 46 Gegentoren auch eine ganze Reihe kassiert. Und das hat sich ja wirklich ganz krass verändert. Man hat 21 Tore weniger geschossen, also 50, und man hat aber auch deswegen der Aufstieg 13 Tore weniger kassiert und damit die beste Abwehr der Liga, 33 Gegentore. Nur. Das könnte ja auch ein Grund für eine Fünferkette gewesen sein.
Ja, durchaus. Und das Personal gab es auch her, tatsächlich dieses System spielen zu können. Rechnen wir mal die vier Tore von viert vielleicht raus, dann wären sogar nur unter 30 Gegentore gewesen. Und also am Ende haben sie da noch ein bisschen sich gehen lassen, vielleicht in Anführungszeichen. Also es ist tatsächlich augenfällig, dass die Defensive derart stabilisiert wurde, dass die Mannschaft einfach auch sofort funktionierte. Also der Nackenschlag des ersten Spieltags, man hat in Regensburg 2-0 verloren. Der war auch so in der Retrospective nochmal. Es gibt ja jetzt auch in der ARD-Mediathek eine kurze Doku über das Aufstiegsjahr. Da kamen auch Spieler zu Wort, die gesagt haben, okay, das war wahrscheinlich heilsam. Also ein paar haben vielleicht noch diesen vierten Platz nachgetrauert, wobei man ganz klar sagen muss, der war kein Drama. Also klar gab es Tränen von dem einen oder anderen Spieler, aber die Fans, ihr hättet wirklich am letzten Spieltag, das war 3-0 gegen Paterborn im Stadion sein müssen, das war fast schon egal. Also die Fans waren so euphorisiert von der Art und Weise, wie Darmstadt Fußball gespielt hat, das wurde denen vom Fleck weg verziehen, da jetzt nicht unter die ersten drei gekommen zu sein. Und dann war aber auch tatsächlich die Frage, wie macht man denn weiter? Und die Spieler haben auch gemerkt mit dieser Niederlage am ersten Spieltag, auch in Unterzahl, aber nicht desto trotz, so geht es nicht. Also sie müssen bei sich bleiben, sie müssen hier versuchen, den Gegner ernst zu nehmen und nicht irgendwie zu denken, wir waren letztes Jahr viertel und jetzt wird es schon laufen. Eben nicht. Und sie haben jeden Gegner, glaube ich, mit einer gewissen Demut auch begegnet. Also wer PKs mit Thorsten Klieberg nicht vor dem Spieltag anhört, der mag schon bald im Repeat-Modus sein, weil er immer nicht müde wird, den Gegner zu loben und immer irgendwelche positiven Aspekte rauszukehren. Und dann wurde ihm schon wieder von Umfeld, Twitter und Co. von anderen Fans vorgeworfen. Na ja, was macht er denn? Er kann es sich sparen, dieses Understatement da am Stad ist vorne dran. Aber ich glaube, Thorsten Klieberg nicht betrachtet einfach jeden Gegner als Herausforderung und nicht als drei Punkte, die leicht einzufahren sind. Also er nimmt sie ernst, auch mit seinem Trainerteam. Und um jetzt auf die Ausgangsfrage zu kommen, diese Umstellung auf die Dreierkette. Ich glaube, was für mich wirklich die Kardinalpersonalie war, war Christoph Zimmermann, den ich vorhin schon erwähnt hatte. Der kam ja nach fünf Jahren Norwich zurück, hat hier in Deutschland noch nie wirklich Spuren hinterlassen. Er kam ja über Gladbach 2, BVB 2, über seinen Trainer damals Fahke nach Norwich mit und hat sich dann in der zweiten Liga dort als Kapitän etabliert und ist dann als Kapitän in die Premier League hoch und wurde dann nach einer Knie-OP, war er wieder da, war Kapitän, wurde von Sebastien Allaire ziemlich rüde umgegrätscht und das war dann der Beginn seiner verletzten Historie. Also er war ewig die letzten drei Jahre verletzt und dann holte man ihn sich vor der Saison. Ich kannte den Namen aber nicht mehr, habe dann mit einem englischen Journalisten mich ausgetauscht zu ihm und er hat den über den grünen Klee gelobt. Also ein Spieler, der eine Ikone wäre in Norwich, der einfach quasi einer Persönlichkeit enorm beeindruckend wäre, der an der Uni Vorlesungen gegeben hätte, der sich im Charity-Umfeld sehr engagiert hätte, der einfach an Land und Leuten interessiert war und durch seine Spielweise, aber auch durch sein Verhalten abseits des Platzes so viel Liebe erfahren hat. Das war schon der Wahnsinn. Mir war es vergönnt, mit ihm auch zu sprechen vor Weihnachten. Der ist wirklich nicht auf den Kopf gefallen. Der hat seine fünf Sinne beisammen, der ist geerdet, der weiß, was er kann. Der nimmt aber auch wiederum gesellschaftliche Entwicklungen abseits des Platzes wahr, wie in England, Brexit haben wir uns lange über unterhalten, auch bemerkenswerte Ansichten. Also ihn zu holen und dass er vor allem in der Saison nur ein Ligaspiel fehlt, weil er zum zweiten Mal Vater wird, ist auch die Saison, eigentlich die Story der Saison. Also er kam, man wusste, okay, Verletzungsgeplagt, aber er kann 3a, 5a Kette spielen und er kam, sah und siegte, kann man schon fast sagen. Also war sicherlich ein Punkt, weil wir regelmäßig Verteidiger verloren haben. Also ich habe es mir mal herausgeschrieben. Patrick Pfeiffer ja auch jetzt nach Regensburg, nach Regensburg Platzverweis, aber verletzt uns nach Augsburg, hat neun Spiele verletzt gefehlt, dann auch Giazoula 14 Spiele verletzt gefehlt, der auch in der 3a Kette vorgesehen war. Also wir haben doch schwerwiegende Verluste über einen längeren Zeitraum. Die Spieler müssen ja dann auch erst immer wieder reinkommen. Also das heißt, er war die Konstante in der Abwehr und hat dann auch so Leute wie den 19-jährigen Clemens Riedl neben sich gut gemanagt und gecoacht. Und die Außenbahnspieler waren auch ein Faktor. Also man konnte dann Baader und Holland weiter nach vorne ziehen. Und Baader hat halt unglaubliche Qualitäten in der Offensivbewegung. Das heißt, da war schon mal auch nach vorne was möglich. Und die Doppel-Sechs waren dann am Anfang schnellharten Kämpfe, bis Baader dann auch wiederum verletzt, länger ausfielen. Aber die denken ja per se auch eher offensiv. Sie haben es aber in der Saison bewiesen, dass sie auch definitiv eine Stabilität verleihen können. Und so, wer auch immer ausfiel, er war ersetzbar. Also die Breite des Kaders, auch wenn es nicht die Big Names waren, sie haben funktioniert. Und das ist wahrscheinlich das, was bei Lieberknecht das Herz höher schlagen lässt, weil er wusste, er hat hier ein Team geformt, das ein Team ist. Also jeder, der ins Spiel geworfen wird, zum Schluss hatten sie ein bisschen Probleme, den Sack zuzumachen, aber über lange Strecken der Saison, wer reinkam, wusste, welche Rolle er zu erfüllen hatte. Und zwar in relativ unterschiedlichen Systemen. Also in Hannover ging es ganz in die Hose, da haben sie ein System gespielt, das hatten sie noch nie gespielt. Das musste sich dann Lieberknecht auch danach ankreiden lassen, da nicht frühzeitig reagiert zu haben. Aber es ging einfach viel auf in der Saison. Und diese 3 auf 5er-Kette mit Doppel-6, mit einem variablen Manu, um einen zentralen Stürmer Tietz oder später auch mal kurzzeitig mit Honsack, der nicht auf dem Flügel agierte, sondern zentraler, was ihm dann gut tat. Da griffen eigentlich viele Rädchen ineinander. Und auch ganz wichtig Marvin Melem, der hinter der Spitze das Spiel an sich gerissen hat und so konstant und auf so einem hohen Niveau gespielt hat, wie noch nie, als er seit Karlsruher Zeiten zu uns gekommen ist, als ganz junger Schwund. Also viele Rädchen, die zusammenwirkten und ein Team mit Christoph Zimmermann, finde ich als sehr zentralen Mann in der Defensive. Auch Marcel Schuhn hat gezeigt, dass er was kann im Tor.
Ja, und wenn du dann so eine Dreierkette hast, dann kann nämlich auch mal der Linksverteidiger nachrücken, zentral oder aus dem Halbraum kommen. Das kann man sich sonst nicht leisten. Auch wenn er angeblich dann Sechser gespielt hat. Wobei wir natürlich alle wissen, das stimmt nicht so.
Aber ich finde das durchaus interessant, diese Entwicklung zur Dreierkette von Darmstadt. Wenn man in die taktischen Muster blickt, die so erfolgreich waren in dieser Saison in der 2. Liga und die Teams, die wirklich spielerisch herausgestochen haben, dann war es Darmstadt mit der Umstellung auf eine Dreierkette. Der SC Paderborn hat eine fantastische Hinrunde gespielt. Auch mit einer Dreierkette, auch umgestellt, hin zu einer Dreierkette. Sankt Kauly ist erst richtig gut geworden mit einer Dreierkette. Kreuter Fürth hat unter Soniger auch eine Dreierkette entwickelt. Das ist eine generelle Entwicklung. Darmstadt und Paderborn haben zur richtigen Zeit die richtige taktische Entscheidung getroffen. Sie sind dann die Welle ganz vorne abgeritten, während andere Teams noch versuchten, Lösungen zu finden. Gegen solche Systeme haben die die erste Saisonhälfte dominiert, bevor es taktisch ein, zwei Sachen gab, die Darmstadt und Paderborn schwerer fielen, haben sie diesen taktischen Vorteil auch nutzen können. Das ist generell eine kleine Entwicklung, die man mit einem Zeitversatz in der ersten Liga auch schon letzte Saison hatte. Oder teilweise immer noch. Union Berlin, das knackt ja immer noch nicht so richtig jemand. Aber die hatten ja auch diesen zeitlichen Vorteil von so einem System, mit dem andere Probleme hatten und worauf erst mal Lösungen gefunden werden müssen.
Es war auch so, dass Darmstadt natürlich immer noch –Tim, ich habe dich im Ohr von einer der letzten Aufnahmen –auch Darmstadt spielt natürlich immer noch den langen Ball. Keine Frage. Aber Darmstadt hat es auch verstanden, mit einem sehr spielstarken Mittelfeld, wie Kempe schnell hat, oder Melem, auch den Ball spielen zu können. Oder auch einen Außenverteidiger wie Bader steht jetzt auch nicht mit dem Ball auf Kriegsfuß. Also sie können schon auch einen guten Ball spielen. Man hat aber mit Tietz vorne auch einen sehr guten Zielspieler, der jetzt vielleicht nicht die Menge an Toren schießt, wie jetzt ein Kleindienst, der aber für das Spielsystem Darmstadt sehr wichtig ist. Also der dann auch den Ball verarbeiten kann, weiter ablegen kann. Der auch schon mal phasenweise auf der 10 gespielt hat, also als hängende Spitze eher. Und da wiederum auch Akzente setzen konnte. Also da ging einfach wirklich in der Saison viel auf. Und auch Lieberknecht sagte, ein langer Ball kann auch geil sein, wenn er halt siegerichtet ist, nicht nur aus der Verzweiflung geschlagen. Also mit ihm zog schon so ein gewisser Spielstil dann schon auch mit ein, wobei die Grundlagen unser Gramozas und Anfang auch schon ein bisschen gelegt waren, wobei es Anfang zu sehr auf die Spitze getrieben hat, was dann gar nicht funktioniert hat. Aber das ist eine andere Geschichte, mit der müssen wir uns gar nicht mehr beschäftigen. Vielleicht ein letzter Aspekt von mir, was bei Darmstadt mir nicht so gut gefallen hat. Jetzt auch an zwei Spielen gegen den KSC zuhause. Zuhause haben wir 2-1 gewonnen und in Hannover haben wir 2-1 verloren. Aber da hat Dibock in meiner Wahrnehmung sehr lange gebraucht, bis er reagiert hat. Die Gäste oder die gegnerischen Teams haben in den Spielen irgendwann sehr viel Druck ausgeübt. Hannover von Anfang an, KSC im Laufe der zweiten Halbzeit. Er hat lange gebraucht, bis er personell eingegriffen hat. Gegen KSC ging es gut, gegen Hannover fiel dann noch das 2-0. Das war für mich eigentlich eine Frage der Zeit, bis es fällt. Dann hat er erst reagiert, indem er personell umstellt. Aber er hätte es auch schon im Spiel tun können, indem er Müller auf die Doppel-Sechs zieht. Da hat er allein Holland auf der Sechs spielen lassen, der aus einer längeren Krankheitsphase zurückkam. Also es ging gar nicht auf. Und da nicht frühzeitig zu reagieren, ich finde, das müsste er in der ersten Liga besser tun. Mal so ein bisschen das Haar in der Suppe zu finden. Aber das ist ja immer noch auf hohem Niveau.
Genau, es hat ja dennoch für den Aufstieg gereicht. Aber wenn man Haare suchen möchte, dann kann man vom Ende der Saison her denken, aus den letzten vier Spielen 3 Niederlagen, 1 Sieg. Und das bringt mich so zu der Kardinalfrage. Und ich meine das jetzt wirklich nicht hämisch, denjenigen Teams gegenüber, die es nicht geschafft haben, einfacher natürlich der HSV aufzusteigen. Warum, Michi, du darfst mal anfangen mit einem Erklärungsansatz, warum ist es so schwierig, die Form zu halten? Egal, wie souverän man vorher in der Saison gespielt hat, es scheint so zu sein, dass im April, und zwar nicht nur beim HSV, beim HSV ist es halt das Klischee. Aber es ist ja zum Beispiel jetzt auch Darmstadt passiert, Heidenheim hatte auch seine Wackler drin. Die einzigen, die alles gewonnen haben, aber das ist eine ganz andere Geschichte, war Rostock. Die sind einfach so, aber da kommen wir später zu. Warum ist es so schwer, eine Zweitligasaison auch durch diesen Frühling hindurch, dominant oder stabil zumindest zu Ende zu bringen?
Also bei der Andorte mit dem Frühling habe ich schon wieder eine indirekte Anspielung gesehen, aber gut. Und ich habe auch jetzt auch keinen 5-Euro-Schein, den ich ins Phrasenschwein werfen kann, aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass diese Liga schon sehr ausgeglichen ist. Und das hat da keine Mannschaft konstant performt. Das spricht ja dafür, was von Trainern immer wieder auch betont wird, das kann man so abtun als Gehabe, als Understatement, je nachdem, aber jedes Spiel ist schwierig. Es gibt auch selten so Freak-Spiele. Ich habe jetzt auch geschaut, auch in dieser schlechten Saison zum Beispiel, die haben nie höher als mit zweiter Unterschied, glaube ich, verloren. Und das spricht ja auch für diese Liga, dass es nicht so oft diese Spiele gibt, in denen mal jemand 5-0, 6-0 abgeschossen wird, wie es in der Bundesliga teilweise vorkommt. Sondern es gibt eben Mannschaften, wie du auch Rostock angesprochen hast, die dann plötzlich auf einmal in einen Run hinlegen und mal fünf Spiele gewinnen, mit der sie Fußball spielen, wenn sie gerade gut drin sind. Das hat natürlich auch viel damit zu tun, dass einige Mannschaften mit personellen Problemen zu tun hatten. Darmstadt zum Beispiel, auch andere Vereine. Ich denke jetzt an den 1. FC Nürnberg, der mir zumindest geografisch nicht so fern liegt. Der hatte auch viel mit Verletzungen zu tun. Wenn Schlüsselspieler ausfallen, kann das den ganzen Static auseinanderbrechen lassen. Das ist bei einigen Mannschaften auch los gewesen. Natürlich hatten Darmstadt und Heidenheim was zu verlieren. Der HSV hatte auch was zu verlieren. Ich habe noch mal geguckt. Wenn wir es dann auch überleiten wollen, vielleicht vierte Acht Niederlagen im März und im April. Das war diese Frühlings-Andeutung ja schon da. Aber da hat er eben auch wieder was zu verlieren. Wenn ich über Führts spreche, die ich ja sehr viel gesehen habe in der Saison, nämlich 34 Mal. Die hatten auch irgendwann was zu verlieren. Sie sind aus dem Abstiegskampf rausgekommen und hätten dann den Schritt machen können ins Mittelfeld. Dann ging es wieder darum, okay, es geht nicht mehr darum, irgendwas zu gewinnen, sondern mal wieder was zu verlieren. Dass man gerade wieder abrutschen in der Tabelle. Und so geht es einigen Mannschaften auch. Ich glaube, das Wichtigste ist diese Ausgeglichenheit der Liga. Man hat ja auch gesehen, wie lange und wie viele Mannschaften gegen den Abstieg gespielt haben. Also eigentlich alle ab Platz 10 haben bis in die Endphase der Saison gegen den Abstieg gespielt. Und alle bis Platz 6 konnten oben mitspielen. Das spricht ja auch dafür. Also klar, es gab eine gewisse Zweiteilung, aber trotzdem gab es eine Ausgelegenheit in diesen beiden Tabellenhälften. Und kürt gab es drei Mannschaften, die sich irgendwann mal sicher sein konnten, wo sie nächstes Jahr Fußball spielen, in welcher Liga. Also das macht ja auch Spaß an dieser Liga. Und ich glaube, das wird nächstes Jahr nochmal stärker so. Also ich war auch in einigen PKs, die ich angeschaut habe in den letzten Wochen, der Fall, dass einige schon gesagt haben, okay, die ist die zweite Liga nächstes Jahr. Die wird schon tough. Also da gibt es jetzt keine Mannschaften, in der man sagt, okay, das ist mal ein Aufsteiger, der wird mit Sicherheit mit 20 Punkten wieder absteigen, wie es ja auch schon Mannschaften gab. Wie Ingolstadt mal abgestiegen ist zum Beispiel, hatten sehr wenige Punkte. Diese Saison hatten auch alle Absteiger relativ viele Punkte, auch wenn am Ende dann Regensburg und Sandhausen etwas haben abreißen lassen. Aber es gibt es auch nicht mehr, dass da jetzt Mannschaften reinkommen, die völlig chancenlos sind. Sondern es kann dann auch mal der FC Magdeburg zweimal gegen den HSV gewinnen, als Mannschaft, die gerade mal das zweite Jahr in der zweiten Liga spielt.
Also waren zwar schon mal in der zweiten Liga, aber war einer der drei Aufsteiger mit Lautern und mit, you name it, Braunschweig. Ja, du brauchst, um Eva nochmal reinzuholen, ohne dass sie dabei ist. Aber sie ist ja auch eine Verfechterin, die sagt, man braucht einen Lauf. Also man muss mehrere Serien starten, am besten über den Verlauf der Saison weg, um irgendwie was zu gewinnen. Und die Lilen hatten halt mal 21 Spiele umgeschlagen. Deshalb konnten sie auch leisten, die letzten, von den letzten vier Spielen nur einen Sieg zu landen. Das hat natürlich sehr geholfen, zeigt aber auch, dass einfach die Basis über die Saison weggelegt wurde. Und zum Schluss, du hast Rostock erwähnt, Max, die hatten natürlich auch durch den Trainerwechsel einfach das richtige Pferd auf das gesetzt haben. Aber da sollten wir doch nochmal über den HSV reden, bevor wir jetzt schon eher in die niederen Tabellenregionen kommen. Und wenn ich vielleicht gerade mal meine 5 Cent mache, also das ist natürlich schon eine Nüchtern zu sehen, wenn der Zweitligist gegen den Erstligist so irgendwie doch chancenlos ist mit 0 zu 3 und 1 zu 3. Das kann man nicht gut finden, macht natürlich die Diskussion wieder auf um die Sinnhaftigkeit der Relegation. Ich finde, die ist einfach nicht gegeben, weil die Erste Liga mehr oder minder mit 16 Teams relativ gut wirtschaften kann. Vielleicht nicht immer richtig wirtschaften kann, aber dennoch, wenn zwei Absteiger da sind, dann ist dann doch die Kluft irgendwann so groß. Und zwischen denen, als es mal keine Relegation gab, waren die, die als dritte aufgestiegen sind, regelmäßig wettbewerbsfähig. Also ich habe da zuletzt mal für eine Kolumne recherchiert. Die landeten im Schnitt zwischen Platz 13 und 14 und hielten sich zwischen drei und vier Saisons. Also da war eine Wettbewerbsfähigkeit da. Aber heutzutage wird einfach einem dieser Platz genommen. Der HSV war jetzt leider zum zweiten Mal der Enige, der die Zenite gezogen hat. Und mit 66 Punkten ist es natürlich schon extrem bitter, da mit leeren Händen da zu stehen.
Wie ist das immer? Ich glaube, seit 2017 ist man eigentlich immer mit 66 Punkten direkt aufgestiegen.
Ja, ich glaube, es gab nur einmal jemanden, der einen Punkt mehr oder so was hatte, Braunschweig oder so, und auch nicht aufgestiegen sind. Aber das ist schon wirklich die Ausnahme. Ja, woran lag es? Also ich habe mir so den Kader ein bisschen angeguckt, der in den Reglationsspielen war. Da war auf der Bank gar nicht so wahnsinnig viel vorhanden, was auch zeigt, dass die Breite vielleicht auch bei einem HSV nicht mehr so tief ist. Na klar, das Beispiel Vuskovic hatte die ja auch zuletzt mit Lando hier an der Stelle sehr gut auseinandergedröselt, wie Doping zu verstehen ist, Epodoping oder eben auch nicht. Der hat ihnen sicherlich gefehlt, weil sie in der 2. Halbserie nur 3-mal zu Null gespielt hatten, in der 1. Halbserie 6-mal. Also vielleicht war auch die Qualität des HSV dann doch nicht mehr so groß, wie es der Name vielleicht suggerieren mag. Aber da kann Tim als Lokalrivale vielleicht noch etwas anderes beisteuern.
Ja, ich würde schon sagen, da würde ich dir absolut zustimmen. Man merkt dem Kader des HSV schon an, dass die schon ein paar Jahre in der 2. Liga spielen. Das muss man schon ehrlich sagen. Wenn man das vergleicht, das ist immer noch der beste Kader der Liga aus meiner Sicht gewesen, von den individuellen Qualitäten, aber eben nicht mehr so diese Übermannschaft, die sie in den Jahren davor hatten. Da gab es jetzt auch viele Stimmen, die dann gesagt haben, mit dem Kader muss man eigentlich aufsteigen, ist der dritte Platz überhaupt kein Erfolg. Da würde ich auch gar nicht unbedingt sagen, dass das irgendwie das große Problem gewesen ist. Weil, wie du gesagt hast, wenn du am Ende der Saison spielst, wenn du in der Innenverteidigung gerade mit Jonas David spielst, sobald da irgendwas im Spiel nicht so lief, wie er sich das vorgestellt hat, hat man die Unsicherheit bis in den letzten Wipfel des Stadiondachs gespürt. Sein Ersatzspieler war Montero, der, ich glaube, die größten Probleme aller Verteidiger in der Liga hatte. Das ist natürlich schwierig gewesen. Die Breite im Kader war nicht mehr gegeben. Was ich bemerkenswert fand, war, dass man das Hinspiel, als der HSV und Stuttgart war, man hat kommen sehen. Man wusste genau, was die Schwächen des HSV sind. Man wusste genau, dass sie offensiv spielen und wie sie zu knacken sind. Stuttgart hat ganz stumpf genau auf diese Schwächen ausgespielt. Der HSV ist genau sehenden Auges in dieses offene Messer reingelaufen. Das war bemerkenswert. Einige sagen, das ist arrogant. Ich glaube, es ist eine innere Überzeugung, die da vorhanden ist, die aber nicht mehr funktioniert. Gerade wenn man dann sieht, da sind dann vielleicht die individuellen Qualitäten, die reichen, dann in der 2. Liga in den meisten Spielen. Ich meine, 66 Punkte ist halt auch gut. Aber wenn das System dann nicht hundertprozentig passt und die individuelle Qualität dann vielleicht nicht mehr ganz so hoch ist, dann passiert so was wie im Hinspiel in der Relegation, wo Stuttgart vielleicht 6, 7 Tore machen muss. Da muss man dann auch ehrlich sagen, man hat auch erkannt, warum Stuttgart nur 16. in der Tabelle geworden ist am Ende. Das fand ich schon bemerkenswert. Dieses Hinspiel war so ein bisschen so das I-Tüpfelchen auf die gesamte Rückrunde des HSV, wo man gemerkt hat, der Walther Ball scheint so ein bisschen decoded zu sein vielleicht. Viele Teams in der Zweitligasaison haben das knacken können, haben da gute Antworten drauf gefunden. Und Stuttgart hat das einfach ganz stumpf genauso gemacht wie viele andere Zweitligisten auch.
Ich weiß nicht, ich meine, es stimmt natürlich, dass Tim Walther einen sehr eigenen Fußball spielen lässt und es da eben auch viele Angriffspunkte gibt, aber ich glaube, dass es eben offensiv geprägter Fußball ist. Ich weiß aber nicht, wie sehr ich da jetzt das Hinspiel in der Relegation gelten lassen würde. Denn wenn du mit der ersten Aktion des Gegners nach 45 Sekunden 0 zu 1 zurückliegst, auswärts, der HSV hatte bis dahin einen Ballkontakt, das war die klärende Aktion zur Ecke, ey, das ist auch ein so schlechter Start, dass ich es dann wirklich auch jedem zugestehe, wenn er dann erstmal 10, 15 schlechte Minuten hat. In diesen 10, 15 schlechten Minuten hat sich der VfB ein Füllhorn an Chancen erarbeitet. Ich meine, der Strafstuss, der dann verschossen wurde, der war ein bisschen später. Aber ich glaube, das war einfach so, es gibt halt einfach so Tage, an denen hast du Pech, und dann läuft es auch nicht. Und da fand ich es eher bemerkenswert, dass der HSV noch zu einzelnen Chancen gekommen ist. Und klar, der VfB hätte den Sack da locker zumachen können, und dann hätten wir über 04,05 gesprochen. Aber ich muss sagen, da würde ich so eine emotionale Klammer drum setzen wollen, weil das so ein Ausnahmespiel ist, was besonders scheiße einfach gelaufen ist. Ich habe jetzt überlegt, ob ich das anders formulieren kann, aber es war einfach mega kacke. Und da möchtest du wirklich kein Spieler sein. Und dafür, finde ich, hatte der HSV dafür sogar noch halbwegs gute Momente. Und ist ja auch das Rückspieg gut angegangen. Also mit dieser frühen Führung von Kittel, eine unfassbare Stimmung im Stadion überhaupt generell. Also beides, keines dieser Fanlager, hat es verdient, in der zweiten Liga zu spielen. Beide Fanlager, wirklich erstklassig. Es war richtig, richtig gut. Aber man kann natürlich nicht drüber hinwegsehen, dass es während der laufenden Rückrunde schon Probleme gab. Und da spielt eben sowas wie Vuskovic schon rein. Und Matthias, du hast jetzt auch schon sehr viel genickt. Eben diese Ausrechenbarkeit des HSV, das tut dich vor allem. Und da kommt jetzt nicht nur dazu, dass man immer hoch anläuft und dass es dann Räume gibt, in die du reinspielen kannst, wenn du aus dem Pressing rauskommst. Sondern ich fand, dass es auch so war, wenn du dem HSV das Flügelspiel weggenommen hast, dann wurde es oft dünn offensiv. Und das zweite war, und das ist so ein bisschen schwierig, weil das ist so eine Henne-Ei-Frage, aber ab einem gewissen Punkt war auch klar, na irgendwann werden die Fehler machen. Irgendwann machen die einen Fehler und dann haben wir einen ganz kurzen Weg zum Tor und dann müssen wir einfach da sein. Also da müssen wir wach sein. Ich meine, in der Relegation ist es natürlich jetzt auch ganz schlimm passiert mit Heuer-Fernandes. Aber das war noch so ein Faktor, der, glaube ich, dazugekommen ist in dieser Rückrunde, was dann eben manche Gegner ausgenutzt haben. Weil es haben auch Gegner gegen den HSV gewonnen, die nicht besser gespielt haben, fand ich.
Ja, sie hatten aber auch so ein Spiel wie beim KSC zum Beispiel. Da hätten sie ja noch richtig massiv unter die Räder kommen können. Also es gibt immer mal so Ausreise. Ich glaube, das Umfeld, auch von den HSV-Fans, die hier zu Gast waren oder HSV-Begleiterinnen, die sind ja schon auch irgendwie versöhnt. Hat man so den Eindruck, mit dem, was der HSV jetzt unter Walter darstellt und dass er doch eine gewisse Identifikation darstellt? Also er hat seinen Spielstil. Er hat einfach auch ein gewisses Spektakel am Start. Und wenn man natürlich Dom P und Jatta auf dem Außen hat, dann kann da schon was gehen. Klar, keine Frage. Aber es ist doch ein bisschen zu eindimensional, mir ganz ehrlich. Also es ist, wie du sagst, man kann den HSV sich schon auch mal ganz gut ausgucken und weiß dann halt, dass sie da weniger Lösungen drauf finden. Also auch diese Fähigkeit, Fehler auch irgendwie abzustellen. Das kommt mir ein bisschen zu kurz beim HSV, so über die gesamte Saison hinweg betrachtet. Wenn sich dann jetzt natürlich Katterbach auch noch ein Kreuzbandriss holt, klar. Aber jeder Verein hat irgendwo Verletzungen, Sorgen und muss zusehen, dass Lösungen gefunden werden. Und da ist mir der HSV gerade was so, sagen wir mal, das Defensivverhalten und auch vielleicht die mangelnde Schnelligkeit in der Defensive anbetrifft, das ist mir da doch ein bisschen zu wenig. Also ich muss da schon mich wundern, wie das beim HSV dann so in einem Treue-Schwurm mündet. Also ich finde es ja gut, dass man einen Trainer festhält. Und ich habe es vor zwei Jahren nicht ganz verstanden, wieso man Walther holt, der maßgeblich einen ganz anderen Fußball propagiert als seine Vorgänger und der vielleicht für die zweite Liga auch manchmal ein bisschen naiv ist. Dann in eine zweite Saison zu gehen, fand ich konsequent, weil irgendwo muss ja auch eine gewisse Kontinuität her. Aber jetzt bin ich sehr gespannt, was folgt. Also Bolt und Walther wollen bleiben und wollen weiterarbeiten. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das Umfeld mit dabei ist. Die Resonanz nach dem Spiel in Hamburg sprach ja auch dafür. Aber ich finde schon, dass irgendwo auch in der Defensive oder im Defensivverhalten was geändert werden muss. Heuer von anders allein kann es auch nicht retten in letzter Konsequenz. Ich weiß nicht, wie Michi es sieht, der da auch vielleicht einen strategisch-taktischeren Blick drauf hat. Aber da habe ich schon so meine Zweifel, ob das in letzter Konsequenz nächstes Jahr erfolgreich sein wird.
Also ich habe keinen strategischen Blick auf den HSV. Das ist ja tatsächlich so. Man sieht alle Vereine mal, dass es gut ist, um einen Überblick zu haben. Aber ich habe zwei Spiele vom HSV wirklich intensivst gesehen gegen Fürth, die habe ich bei ihrem Stadion gesehen. Da hat man eben schon gemerkt, was es dem HSV für Probleme bereitet, wenn er auch selbst hoch angelaufen wird. Das ist eben die von Tim auch angesprochene Qualität oder der Qualitätsabfall in großen An- und Abführungszeichen, der halt einfach über die letzten Jahre dort passiert. Das war, wenn man natürlich weniger Geld hat, eben jedes Jahr weniger. Es wird nächstes Jahr wieder weniger, das ist ja auch klar. Also die Erstliga-Jahre sind jetzt dann auch rausgefallen, aus den TV-Geldwertungen weitgehend. Also dann ist man eben ein guter Zweitligist, aber das ist trotzdem nochmal ein großer Unterschied zu jemandem, der dann eben vier Jahre Erste Liga oder drei Jahre Erste Liga in seiner TV-Geldauswertung stehen hat. Und das merkt man der Mannschaft einfach an, dass da halt einfach nicht mehr die Qualität da ist. Und wenn selbst Viertes schafft, die wahnsinnig nett vor Selbstbewusstsein gestrotzt haben in der Saison, dem HSV in zwei Spielen solche Probleme zu bereiten, mit hohem Pressing, haben andere Mannschaften auch getan, dann spürt man eben, dass da die Qualität nicht mehr so da ist. Und auch das fand ich im Stadion immer bemerkenswert. Am Anfang beim HSV dachte man immer, die werden mit jedem Wechsel nochmal besser gefühlt, von den Namen, zumindest von der Bank. Und das ist einfach auch nicht mehr so. Also wenn der HSV wechselt, der Erste Elf ist immer noch wahnsinnig gut gewesen, aber die Wechsel waren dann eben auch nicht mehr so gut. Und man hat es ja in der Relegation auch gesehen, als Suhun kam, das war ein völlig unnötiger Platzverweis in der Situation, den er sich da geholt hat. Also jemand, der klug Fußball spielt, begeht diesen Fehler da einfach nicht in dem Spiel. Deswegen bin ich auch sehr gespannt, wie es weitergeht. Aber es klingt für mich alles danach, als ob das weitergeht. Ich fand auch, dass die Harmonie in Hamburg, auch so auf der Pressekonferenz zwischen Journalisten, klar, dem Walde hat mit manchen Journalisten vielleicht ein Problem, das lässt er auch gerne raushängen. Aber so insgesamt auch im Stadionumfeld, da war eine gewisse Harmonie da, eine gewisse Ruhe, die ich früher beim HSV nicht wahrgenommen habe. Und deswegen, das wurde ja auf Twitter teilweise auch schon diskutiert, das ist eine Abführungszeichen-Ambitionslosigkeit, dass man zufrieden ist mit einem Platz 3 in der 2. Liga. Andererseits, wie gesagt, es waren 66 Punkte, es war trotzdem eine gute Saison, man hat eben 8 mal verloren, mehr als die anderen beiden oben. Und das ist wahrscheinlich dann der ausschlaggebende Grund, dass man eben in solchen Spielen wie gegen Fürth, wie gegen Magdeburg, das sind natürlich alles keine schlechten Zweite-Liga-Mannschaften, aber dass man gegen solche Mannschaften muss man einfach dann auch gewinnen. Und der 1. FC Heidenheim hat zum Beispiel 2-mal gegen Fürth gewonnen. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie gegen Heidenheim gewonnen haben, aber das ist eben auch so eine Sache, dass ich gegen diese Mittelklasse-Mannschaften, ich habe sehr viele anderen Abführungszeichen heute, um meine Wertungen nicht so arg zu gewichten, aber das ist dem HSV nicht geglückt. Und natürlich wird das in den nächsten Jahren, wenn es dann noch mal ein Jahr und noch mal ein Jahr ist, dann wird die Qualität der Mannschaft natürlich nicht höher werden, weil man einfach immer viel weniger Geld hat. Und außer man setzt hat wirklich auf Tim Walther, und irgendwann hat man so viel Spektakel, dass man in jedem Spiel 5-4 vielleicht gewinnt und damit dann aufsteigt. Aber die 2. Liga wird nächstes Jahr auf jeden Fall in der Spitze, nicht schlecht, da würde ich mal tippen. Da wird es einige Mannschaften geben, die neben dem HSV wieder hoch wollen, unter anderem 2 Absteiger. Aber es werden auch andere Teams. Das wird für den HSV in keiner Saison leichter, ist klar. Deswegen mal schauen, was das mit Tim Walther wird.
Was man Walther natürlich zugute halten muss, er ist jetzt zweimal auf Platz 3 eingelaufen, besser als seine Vorgänger. Mit 66 Punkten, wie wir vorhin schon sagten, kannst du ihm kaum was an Fahrlässigkeit vorwerfen. Aber ich finde, die Balance im Spiel des HSV, die muss einfach ausgebaut werden, nach meinem Empfinden, nach meinem Dafürhalten.
Ja, ich würde dem auch zustimmen. Also Ambitionslosigkeit, das würde ich auch nicht sagen. Sondern ich würde sagen, es ist vielleicht auch so eine gewisse Art von Realismus, die da eingesetzt hat, dass man eben nicht diese Übermannschaft hat und jetzt halt eben das Maximum rausholt aus dem Team, wo vielleicht die Balance nicht gegeben ist. Mich würde mal interessieren, wie jemand wie Tim Walther, wie das funktioniert, wenn der defensiv richtig, richtig starke Leute zur Hand hat. Das kannst du ja auch haben, dass dieser Fußball… Ich frage mich immer, wie würde Pep Guardiola funktionieren bei Nichts gegen den Verein, aber bei Eintracht Braunschweig zum Beispiel, oder so, ne? Also wie gehen Trainer mit so was um? Und ich könnte mir bei Tim Walther zum Beispiel vorstellen, dass der, wenn der tatsächlich ein Team hat, was qualitativ echt gut ist, und da denke ich gar nicht an Bayern oder Dortmund oder so, aber vielleicht auch. Ich glaube, da könnte er vielleicht sogar noch, noch, noch viel besser sein. Und alle würden sagen, er ist der beste Trainer der Welt, weil er so eine klare, überzeugende Idee hat, und ja auch offensiv durchaus radikale Elemente da drin hat, und ja durchaus auch ansehendlichen Fußball spielen lässt und so. Und das finde ich alles total gut. Es ist vielleicht in der ein oder anderen Situation, und vor allem jetzt in der Rückrunde, wurde das ziemlich deutlich, dass da die Anpassungen nicht vorgenommen wurden. Vielleicht konnten sie auch einfach nicht vorgenommen werden. Vielleicht ist es so radikal in die eine Ecke geschoben, dass es eben nur so ein One-Way-Ding war und es eben nicht mehr zurückging. Es eben keine Abstufung gibt in diesem Spiel, in dieser Spielidee und es deswegen halt schwierig wird. Er hat es auch verbal, rhetorisch immer wieder herausgehoben, dieses Selbstbewusstsein. Ich glaube, da würde ich fast mal vermuten, dass das auch so eine Art Schutzschirm ist, den er um sich und sein Team herum aufbauen wollte. Dass er gesagt hat, ja hier, die, die uns kritisieren, die wissen nicht, dass wir nächstes Jahr Bundesliga spielen. Das ist natürlich ein Satz, der ihnen unfassbar um die Ohren gehauen wurde jetzt die letzten Tage. Aber das sagst du ja als Trainer nicht, weil du absolut davon überzeugt bist, wir sind die Geilsten, sondern weil du vielleicht auch irgendwen schützen willst, dein Team schützen willst, das stark reden willst und, und, und. Deswegen, mich würde es mal interessieren, wie das mit Tim Walter funktioniert in einem anderen Kontext, wo vielleicht defensiv oder vielleicht die Balance einfach in so einem Team mehr gegeben ist. Und das war jetzt beim HSV in dieser Saison vielleicht nicht so. Aber ja, genau, man muss es vielleicht abstufen. Vielleicht müssen wir uns alle auch ein bisschen neu justieren, weil in meinem Kopf ist der HSV immer noch der große HSV, sozusagen die absolute Übermannschaft, die in der zweiten Liga eigentlich nichts verloren hat, so ungefähr. Und das ist er halt einfach nicht mehr, das muss man auch sagen. Und da sind dann vielleicht 66 Punkte auch schon echt eine richtig gute Ausbeute. Ich meine, die haben, muss man auch sagen, eine richtig gute Saison gespielt. Nur acht Mal verloren, das ist eben auch… Das ist eben auch nicht alles andere als schlecht, ne? Also man muss das jetzt auch nicht niederreden, aber es gab eben diese, wenn man die Kritikpunkte finden will, dann ist es eben so was wie diese fehlende Anpassungsfähigkeit, obwohl die Probleme offensichtlich sind für alle.
Ja, aber dafür sind sie auch nicht weggeknickt. Also es gab eben zum Beispiel dieses Derby gegen St. Pauli, was man 4 zu 3 gewinnt.
Ja, aber wie? Also da muss man ja dazu sagen, das war ja auch so, das war ja, also ich möchte, also das Derby, das sind ja vier individuelle Fehler.
Ja, aber du hast es gewonnen, ist doch drauf. Also alle haben doch erwartet, dass der HSV wieder ausrutscht. Vor allem weil die haben doch das Spiel davor, glaube ich, damals verloren. Und das war wieder, ach, jetzt geht es wieder dahin. Genau, auf Lautern am Betzenberg haben sie 0 zu 2 verloren. Und dann gewinnen sie aber dieses Derby. Dann verlieren sie Magdeburg. Und man denkt sich so, ach, der HSV ist wieder da. Sie schaffen es einfach nicht. Meine Güte. Und dann, ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man das 2 zu 2 gegen Paderborn, da waren aber auch schon gute Elemente mit drin. Und sie gewinnen aber die letzten drei Spiele. Sie stolpern nicht in Regensburg, sie stolpern nicht zu Hause gegen Fürth, sie stolpern nicht mal auswärts in Sandhausen. Und das sind alles –und letztlich wissen wir doch alle genau, was passieren muss, damit man aufsteigt. Es liegt so sehr auf der Hand, dass es schade ist, dass ich es sagen muss. Sie haben fast die identische Bilanz, die Darmstadt hatte. Nämlich 70 Tore und 45 Gegentreffer. Darmstadt hatte 71,46, habe ich vorhin gesagt. Also Umstellung auf Fünferkette. Nächste Saison geht es ganz entspannt nach oben. Ich nehme mein Honorar dann gerne im nächsten Sommer entgegen.
Der HSV hat jetzt zumindest eine Ahnung, wie es funktioniert. Die mangelnde Balance oder Anpassungsfähigkeit haben wir schon erwähnt. Aber jetzt ist er zweimal Dritter geworden. Von oben kommt die Hertha, wenn sie nicht noch weiter durchgereicht wird. Das wird sich ja wohl nächste Woche entscheiden. Und Schalke. Also da will ich erstmal, wenn Hertha in der 2. Liga bleibt, sehen, dass die des Unterhauers rocken. Vielleicht ist der HSV da wiederum ein bisschen im Vorteil. Who knows?
Also ich muss sagen, ich habe dieses Jahr beim HSV ein viel besseres Gefühl gehabt als noch im letzten Jahr. Auch wenn es jetzt wieder nicht geklappt hat, aber ich finde, da haben trotz aller Widrigkeiten viele Dinge gut funktioniert. Und ich fand wirklich sensationell, wie sich Tim Walter nach dem Ausscheiden präsentiert hat. Er war dabei Patrick Wasserzieher am Mikrofon und hat davon gesprochen, dass er jetzt sich richtig wie ein Hamburger fühlen würde, sehr, sehr demütig auch den Fans gegenüber, dass er so dankbar sei, bei so einem Verein zu trainieren und so weiter und so fort. Und das hatten schon viele, also wenn wir vorhin Thorsten Lieberknecht und Frank Schmidt loben, dann gab es da natürlich auch andere Momente bei Tim Walter, aber diesen Moment fand ich sehr stark und das war auch eine Seite, die ich so von ihm, zumindest in einem Field-Interview, wo ja schon noch viel Adrenalin mit im Spiel ist, auch wenn früh klar war, also gut, das wird jetzt nichts mehr mit dem Aufstieg, vielleicht ist da auch eine Weiterentwicklung zu erkennen und deswegen, es hat halt wieder nicht gereicht. Relegation ist einfach mega scheiße. In 80 Prozent gewinnt es der Erstligist. Was soll der Kack? Na gut, wir wissen, was der Kack soll. Es hat seine Gründe. Aber es gab sehr viele positive Dinge und ich glaube, das hat man dann auch nach Schlusspfiff gemerkt beim HSV. Und damit kommen wir dann zu den Teams, die es nicht geschafft haben. Wir müssen jetzt nicht mehr jedes Team hier einzeln durchgehen, auch wenn ich das Gefühl habe, dass wir über den FC St. Pauli noch ein kurzes Weichchen sprechen werden. Aber jetzt gibt es einen Drop-Off in den Punkten, Tim. Also 66 Punkte hat der HSV, 67 haben Darmstadt und Heidenheim. Jetzt 8 Punkte Cut. Dann kommen Fortuna Düsseldorf und der FC St. Pauli, dass es in dieser Reihenfolge war. Das hatte damit im letzten Spieltag zu tun. Dann Paderborn mit 55 und dann sprechen wir über den nächsten Cut. Warum haben es denn da andere Teams nicht geschafft, bis zuletzt dran zu bleiben? Wir hatten ja diesmal nur die Frage, wie die ersten drei Ränge verteilt sind.
Tja, gute Frage. Ein ganz wichtiges Spiel war St. Pauli gegen Fortuna Düsseldorf. Das 0-0. Das war für beide richtig ätzend. Das war das eine Ergebnis, das auf gar keinen Fall passieren darf. Da habe ich heute immer noch Fragezeichen auf der Stirn. Fortuna hat, glaube ich, eineinhalb Mal aufs Tor geschossen während der ganzen Partie. Ich weiß immer noch nicht, wie die sich vorstellten. Wie sie sich vorstellten, das Spiel zu gewinnen, aber St. Pauli hat es auch nicht geschafft. Das spielte im HSV natürlich enorm in die Karten. Ich glaube aber, wenn man das über die Saison betrachtet, über die gesamte Saison bei St. Pauli, war die Hinrunde nicht ganz so gut. Die Rückrunde war natürlich mega stark. Bei Fortuna Düsseldorf war es tatsächlich eher so ein Auf und Ab, aber die haben nie so richtig diese Serie zum Laufen gekriegt. Die waren immer richtig gut, aber haben auch immer wieder, ich weiß gar nicht, ich weiß überhaupt nicht, ob die eine Serie hatten, aber ich würde sagen, die haben keine drei Spiele am Stück nicht verloren. Oder so, so in dem Sinn. Wir haben zwei gewonnen, dann eins verloren, vielleicht wieder eins gewonnen, eins unentschieden, irgendwie so. Die waren immer mit oben dran, aber haben nie diese Serie gehabt, wie Darmstadt, haben auch nie so eine Serie wie Heidenheim gehabt, oder wie der HSV dann auch zwischendurch. Also, die haben diesen Lauf nicht bekommen. Also, sieben Spiele gab es mal, die man quasi …Ja, verdammt, jetzt hauen wir doch nicht so eine Statistik. Nein, aber ich finde, man hat bei Fortuna Düsseldorf gemerkt, dass da irgendwie was fehlt. Als Kovnacki dann in der Rückrunde noch mal richtig stark aufgekommen ist, da ging es ja dann auch noch mal hoch. Aber ich finde, da hat man so in gewisser Art und Weise gemerkt, dass da irgendwas fehlt. Ich kann das bei Fortuna aber nicht genau benennen, was gefehlt hat, weil ich eigentlich das Gefühl habe, dass so vom Kader her und auch vom Trainer her und auch von den Spielanlagen her, die haben ja Ende der letzten Saison auch schon richtig gut im Fußball gespielt, also haben sozusagen den Schwung auch mit rüber genommen so ein bisschen. Eigentlich hat das alles gepasst, aber irgendwie hat dann doch das Letzte ein bisschen gefehlt. Bei Paderborn hat wohl das Ende der Hinrunde gefehlt. Da haben sie ja glaube ich drei oder vier Spiele in Folge verloren. Ich glaube, das hat denen das Genick gebrochen im Nachhinein, weil da gab es eigentlich, naja, optisch auf dem Feld, gibt es eigentlich nicht viele Sachen, die Paderborn gefehlt haben. Eigentlich gar nichts. Also finde ich spielerisch das beste Team der Liga gewesen über die ganze Saison, aber dann eben in den entscheidenden Momenten, so kurz vor der Hinrunde, vor Ende der Hinrunde, vor dieser langen Winterpause, diese Nackenschläge sich abzuholen, das tat glaube ich unfassbar weh. Und das rückblickend betrachtet wahrscheinlich auch echt wahrscheinlich der Genickbruch gewesen für die. Und ja, bei St. Pauli war es natürlich schön zu träumen, aber jede Serie muss man reißen, danach zehn Siegen in Folge und dann doch nochmal in Darmstadt gewinnen und da irgendwie Partycrasher spielen und dann doch nochmal hoffen. Es war natürlich alles schön, aber man wusste auch, dass das irgendwie irgendwann funktioniert halt nicht mehr ganz. Irgendwann kommen halt, sind diese Coinflip-Spiele, die da drin waren, die funktionieren dann nicht mehr so richtig oder die gehen dann mal in die andere Richtung aus. Und so ist es halt gewesen. Also das sind so die drei Teams, die halt eben diese Schwächephasen hatten bzw. nie so richtig über die gesamte Saison das konstant irgendwie abrufen konnten. Und entsprechend reicht das dann nicht. Und das Punkte, der Abstand ist ja dann riesig. Das war ja drei Spieltage vor Schluss. Sah das ja überhaupt nicht so aus. Also da war das ja relativ eng. Aber der Abstand liest sich jetzt riesig. Das liest sich so, als wenn da drei Überteams waren.
Ja, das ist ja das Erstaunliche, dass wir hier eigentlich über sechs Teams sprechen, die eine ganz ähnliche Tordifferenz haben. Und normalerweise sagt die Tordifferenz schon ein bisschen was aus darüber, wie sich so eine Liga durchstaffelt. Aber wir haben eben Fortuna Düsseldorf 60 Tore 43 Gegentore, St. Pauli 55 39, Paderborn 68 44. Da sieht man auch so ein bisschen den Spektakelgehalt. Also das ist im Grunde genau dasselbe, was die anderen haben. Nur eben die Verteilung auf die einzelnen Spiele war halt so, dass es weniger Punkte ergeben hat. Das finde ich, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da jetzt was überinterpretiere, Matthias, aber das finde ich schon interessant, dass es so viele Teams gab, die auch in der Lage waren, viele Tore zu erzielen in dieser Zweitliga-Saison.
Definitiv. Also da nehmen sich die Ligien ja fast schon gering aus, im Vergleich zu den anderen. Ich finde auch, dass Paderborn ein sehr dickes Brett war, das in den Duellen mit den Ligien zu bohren war. Die haben wir zweimal 2 zu 1 geschlagen. Das war sicherlich wichtig, die da auf Distanz zu halten, weil Paderborn schätze ich auch als enorm stark ein. Und zwar, Tim hatte es schon gesagt, diese Schwächephase am Ende der Hinrunde, die kam für mich aus dem Nichts, weil die waren bis dahin absolut in Schlagdistanz oder sogar mit einer Tabellenspitze und dann so Punkte liegen zu lassen, auch gegen schlagbare Gegner, das hat mich überrascht. Aber auch 11 Spiele zu verlieren bei 16 Siegen zeigt ja auch, dass da vielleicht auch nicht die Balance so durchweg gegeben war. Also, dass sie auch im Stande waren mit 44 Gegentreffern auch ein paar zu viel zu kassieren. Also, dass dann auch an der Stelle zwar nach vorne viel Wucht da war, aber nach hinten vielleicht in letzter Konsequenz, würde ich es jetzt mal anhand der Zahlen ablesen, doch nicht alles in Butter war. Aber Paderborn, klar, das sehe ich auch als enorm spielstarke Mannschaft ein.
Michi, hast du Gedanken zu diesen drei Teams?
Ich tue mich da auch schwer, wie ihr es vorhin schon sagtet. Bei Vatuna Düsseldorf, jedes Jahr denkt man sich dieser Kaders eigentlich gut, dieser Verein mit den Zuschauerzahlen. Das haben wir beim HSV vorhin weggelassen. Das wollte ich noch anhängen. Beim HSV natürlich, man da eine gewisse Entwicklung hat, mannschaftlich, dass es sich der Zweite Liga angleicht, aber rein im Umfeld ja überhaupt nicht. Also Düsseldorf ist ja auch so ein Standort, wo man denkt, der müsste eigentlich in der Bundesliga spielen aufgrund der Finanzkraft, aufgrund der Historie, aufgrund des Stadions, aufgrund so vieler Dinge. Und da tut es mich so schwer, auch seit Jahren schon das zu greifen. Wir hatten es ja im Kurzpass vor, ich weiß nicht, vor eineinhalb Monaten oder so, dass Düsseldorf eben gegen den 1. FC Nürnberg dreimal eine Saison verloren hat, der wirklich einfach nicht gut war. Und sowas kann ich mir nicht erklären, wie das funktioniert. Also weil Spitzenmannschaften machen sowas nicht. Also die verlieren nicht zweimal oder dreimal gegen Nürnberg, verlieren gegen Fürth oder holen einen Punkt gegen Fürth. Das darf ja eigentlich nicht passieren. Das sind auch die Punkte, die ihnen am Ende dann fehlen gegen solche Gegner. Und die erklären ja auch so ein Auf und Ab, wenn man denkt, ja gut, jetzt gewinnen sie dann mal ein Spiel gegen eine Mannschaft aus der oberen Tabellenhälfte und verlieren dann gegen den Tabellen 14., 15. immer mal wieder. Und das ist ja auch seit Jahren so. Und das ist nie für mich greifbar, weil der Kader ist, es gibt es immer her. Aber sie überzeugen mich auch nicht. Also vielleicht sehe ich zu wenig Fortuna Düsseldorf-Spiele, aber sie sind keine Mannschaft, die mich jetzt komplett zu 100% überzeugt. Das war in Heidenheim zum Beispiel anders. Die halt einfach ihren Spielstil immer durchziehen und der auch dann an 30 Spieltagen von 34 funktioniert. Und das sehe ich bei Fortuna Düsseldorf zum Beispiel nicht. Bei Paderbornes hat durch diese Spektakellastigkeit, da gibt es immer die Gefahr, dass mal was hinten passiert. Auch da hat die gegen Fürth, als Fürth so schlecht war, als Fürth letztes Jahr war, glaube ich, oder zumindest weit hinten drin, die war die erste Mannschaft, die gegen Fürth verloren hat, am achten Spieltag oder so. Auch das sind so unerklärliche Dinge, dass Mannschaften es eben nicht schaffen, konstant zu sein. Und du steigst eben auf, wenn du die konstanteste Mannschaft bist. Das hat man jetzt schon mehrmals hier. Ich könnte mal zwei in fünf Euro scheinen, ins Frasenschwein werfen. Ich habe keinen hier. Aber das zieht sich ja durch die ganze Liga durch. Und es gibt eben Mannschaften, die können an guten Tagen gegen jeden gewinnen. Die spielen dann auch oben mit. Aber die haben halt eben diese guten Tage nicht konstant. Und das wird auch in den nächsten Jahren spannend zu sehen sein, weil ich nicht sehe, dass Vortur und Düsseldorf jetzt diesen Flow hat, auch mit dem Kownazki-Abgang. Dass sie da jetzt dann einfach nächstes Jahr Tabellen-Erster werden oder Zweiter und auf jeden Fall sicher aufsteigen. Das sehe ich bei denen nicht. Und natürlich spannend der Verein auch mit dem –das habt ihr, glaube ich, mal größer besprochen gehabt schon in der Vergangenheit –mit dem Projekt, das wir in der nächsten Saison angehen wollen. Was dafür eine Euphorie vielleicht entwickelt wird, wenn das Stadion immer voll ist aufgrund kostenloser Eintrittskarten. Da lohnt sich es auch nochmal hinzublicken. Aber so richtig fassen kann ich das nicht. Und bei St. Pauli war es ja auch so –im März war es, glaube ich, mit Tim, da haben wir das Spiel gesehen, am Millantor gegen Fürth von St. Pauli. Auch da waren einige Spieler dabei, die mussten nicht gewinnen als FC St. Pauli. Und es war klar, dass dann irgendwann diese Coinflip-Spiele, wie Tim sie nannte, dass es irgendwann nicht mehr gut ausgeht. Also sie hätten auch gegen Fürth verlieren können zu Hause. Es gab andere Spieler, die mussten sie auf keinen Fall gewinnen. Aber die haben sie gewonnen. Aber klar, trotzdem war die Hinrunde bärenstark. Und die Erklärung ist natürlich, im Jahr 2022 zu finden. Und nicht im Jahr 2023.
Ich glaube St. Pauli wäre ohnehin, wenn es Ligen gäbe, die nach Kalendera gespielt werden würden. Ich glaube 2021 war doch auch schon herausragend. Ja, genau. Also 2020 eher schlecht, dann 2021 herausragend, 2022 wieder schlecht, jetzt wieder hervorragend. Also sind wir gespannt, was die nächste Hinrunde ergibt. Aber ich glaube, ich habe vorhin mal gespickt, St. Pauli war nach der Hinrunde 15. Und in der Rückrunden-Tabelle war Kaiserslautern 15. Also das heißt im Umkehrschluss, beide haben eine Halbserie überzeugt. Der FCK war 14 nach der Hinrunde und hat sich da richtig gut geschlagen und war auch gut aus der Winterpause gekommen. Und St. Pauli hat halt in der Rückrunde die Story geschrieben mit unfassbar vielen Punkten und vielleicht manchmal etwas glücklicheren Siegen. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, die haben die Bälle geritten. Und Kaiserslau schon, um dem Verein kurz nochmal zu seinem Recht zu verhelfen, hat als Aufsteiger in der Hinrunde einfach überzeugt und das Umfeld angezündet. Und ich bin mal gespannt, wie die dann sich in der neuen Saison schlagen jetzt doch mit einer relativ schwachen Halbserie. Da muss einfach dann doch ein bisschen Konstanz rein.
Ich finde das übrigens interessant, was du gesagt hast, Michi. Da muss ich dran denken, also ich glaube, man könnte bei jetzt den sechs Teams, die wir besprochen haben, selbst Kaiserslautern könnte man mit reinnehmen. Da können wir nur bei den dann sieben Teams, da könnte man bei sechs von sieben Teams könnte man klar Muster erklären oder erkennen und sagen, was die für einen Fußball spielen. Offensiv, was die für Grundideen haben. Walther Ball völlig klar, bei Darmstadt nur, das ist mir jetzt gerade bei Fortuna Düsseldorf ist das ein komplett schwarzes Blackbox für mich. Da kann ich überhaupt nicht sagen, wie das funktioniert. Aber bei allen anderen sieben Teams, die jetzt hier bisher Thema waren, kann man das eigentlich relativ genau definieren, wie die versuchen zu turnen zu kommen. Vielleicht ist das ein Grund, warum das bei Fortuna vielleicht dann nicht ganz so funktioniert hat. Vielleicht tue ich den auch komplett unrecht, aber das ist mir jetzt auf jeden Fall gerade aufgefallen, dass das bei allen anderen ziemlich klar ist und bei Fortuna Düsseldorf eben irgendwie für mich zumindest nicht.
Ja, Fortuna hat auch wirklich, auch was die Statistiken angeht, ist es total weird. Also nur mal drei Beispiele von ganz vielen, die ich jetzt nennen könnte. Bei den Schüssen aufs Tor ist man auf Rang 3 in der Liga. Bei dem Kreieren von Großchancen ist man auf Platz 9 in der Liga. Und bei den vergebenen Großchancen, also wo man sehr weit hinten landen möchte, ist man Rang 15. Jede Statistik scheint etwas anderes zu sagen. Die eine scheint zu sagen, die sind ja super effizient. Die andere sagt, sie sind eher so mittelfeld, wenn es darum geht, sich Großchancen zu arbeiten. Und die andere sagt, die schießen aber ständig aufs Tor. Hä? Da bin ich jetzt dann, der sich dann leider auch viel über Statistiken erschließen muss. Es tut mir leid, Fortunfans da draußen. Ich kann Düsseldorf nicht erklären. Aber bevor wir jetzt vielleicht über die drei Aufsteiger dann noch mal sprechen sollten, die ja alle drin geblieben sind, habe ich noch eine Frage an dich, Tim. Ich weiß, dass der FC St. Pauli gerne Understatement betreibt und dass das auch so ein bisschen der berühmte Präventiv-Pessimismus ist, dass ihr den natürlich auch pflegen musst im Mildern-Ton. Ist es aber nicht eigentlich inzwischen langsam so, dass man auch, was die finanziellen Strukturen zum Beispiel angeht, anerkennen muss, so Teams wie Düsseldorf, St. Pauli, Paderborn, muss ich gerade mal gucken, ob man die dazu rechnen kann. Nee, Paderborn fällt schon raus. Düsseldorf, St. Pauli, HSV. Und jetzt dann die, die runterkommen. Die spielen schon so halbwegs in einem ökonomischen Cluster. Und danach gibt es einen kleinen Drop-Off. Müsste St. Pauli jetzt nicht eigentlich dann mal sagen, na ja, über kurz oder lang, Rang 5 ist natürlich wunderbar, will das jetzt nicht schlecht reden und so weiter. Es ist ungefähr das, wo man auch stehen sollte. Aber man ist eigentlich doch so ein bisschen wie Union. Vor vier Jahren war es ja dann, wo man dann nach dem Aufstieg gesagt hat, die haben den ganzen Aufstieg lang gesagt, ja, wir wollen ja gar nicht hoch, wir können ja gar nicht, guckt uns doch mal an, wir können das doch alle gar nicht. Aber eigentlich mal auf die Zahlen geguckt hat und im Nachhinein haben sie es auch zugegeben, haben sie gesagt, nee, eigentlich mussten wir schon langsam mal aufsteigen, nachdem, was wir da so reingesteckt haben.
Ja, ich meine, man sagt ja schon so, dass vieles beim FC St. Pauli im Umfeld, dass das schon erst ligerreif ist, also in vielen anderen Bereichen, in denen da gearbeitet wird, aber der sportliche Bereich da nicht so, das verpasst hat, da nachzuziehen. Der eigene Anspruch ist Top 25. Das schließt das ja ein. Und Andreas Bornemann, der Sportchef, oder ich war oke-göttlich kürzlich, der hat gesagt, wenn man Top 25 sagt, ja, dann schließt das auch Platz 7 in der 2. Liga ein, aber es schließt halt eben auch Platz 1 in der 2. Liga ein und eben auch Platz 1 in der 1. Liga. Also da möchte man hingehören. Das ist für den FC St. Pauli tatsächlich schon ein relativ deutliches Statement, wo man sich verortet. Aber das ist tatsächlich, wie du sagst, das gehört auch damit hin, wenn man sich die ökonomischen Verhältnisse anguckt. Der FC St. Pauli ist nicht mehr der Pleiten-Pech- und Pannenclub, der vor 15 Jahren noch gewesen ist, sondern das ist einer der, ich würde fast sagen, wenigen Vereine, die haben natürlich auch unter der Pandemie, unter den Einschränkungen da gelitten. Aber die sind, dadurch, dass sie vorher 8 Jahre lang jeweils immer schwarze Zahlen geschrieben haben, haben sie, glaube ich, das relativ gut weggesteckt und da auch immer noch einen Vorteil jetzt anderen Clubs gegenüber. Das sieht man ja auch dann an sowas wie den Investoreneinstieg bei der DFL, wie klar sich dann einige Clubs dann positionieren können und wie groß die Not bei anderen Clubs vielleicht dann auch einfach ist, dass sie dann so solchen Dingen vielleicht versuchen zuzustimmen, um schnelles Geld machen zu können. Das braucht der FC St. Pauli momentan nicht. Das ist schon völlig logisch und daraus leitet sich natürlich auch der Anspruch ab, über kurz oder lang in die 1. Liga aufzusteigen. Da gehört der FC St. Pauli mit Fortuna Düsseldorf eben da oben hin, die Absteiger Schalke, Hertha, HSV. Die würde ich alle drei vielleicht noch ein bisschen höher ansehen, wobei Hertha –weiß ich nicht –Schalke hat auch einen riesengroßen Schuldenberg. Ich glaube, was den finanziellen Gesundheitszustand angeht, ist der FC St. Pauli wahrscheinlich sogar einer der am besten geführten Vereine in der 2. Liga. Aber da gehören sie auch hin, also zu den Top 5, Top 6. Das muss auch der Anspruch sein. Dann gibt es natürlich so Teams wie Paderborn, Karlsruhe. Die machen da auch sehr gute Arbeit, die da dann doch mit geringeren Mitteln auch immer wieder reinstechen können. Aber der FC St. Pauli gehört da auf jeden Fall hin, wo sie jetzt auch gelandet sind, da Top 5. Das muss auch der Anspruch sein, auch für die folgenden Jahre. Und wenn man sich anguckt, wo das endet. Darmstadt hat jetzt zwei Jahre lang dann auch da oben mitgespielt und auch schon unter Gramozzi super gespielt und so. Hatte über Jahre da oben mitgespielt. Heidenheim hat über Jahre da oben mitgespielt. Du hast das Beispiel Union Berlin gebracht. Die haben auch über Jahre da oben mitgespielt. Irgendwann läuft mal alles zusammen. Aber nur dann, wenn du halt über Jahre da oben mitspielst. Natürlich gibt es so Zufallsprodukte, dass Teams durchmarschieren, dass Teams plötzlich einen super Kader zusammen haben und alles ineinander läuft. Aber ich meine, die größere Wahrscheinlichkeit hast du dadurch, wenn du über Jahre da oben mitspielst und die Strukturen einfach immer Stück für Stück verbessern kannst. Und da hoffe ich ein bisschen drauf, dass nachdem Darmstadt und Heidenheim jetzt so sind, dass jetzt der FC St. Pauli dran ist, die eben jetzt auch sich unter in den letzten vier Jahren einfach stetig immer verbessert haben in der Tabelle.
Schön auch diese Leitbilder zu kennen. Also Top 25. Bei Lilen heißt es die Top 20 angreifen. Also so hat jeder Verein sein Leitbild, dass sich den Bar interpretieren lässt.
Was heißt bei den Vörtern, Michi?
In Top 25 habe ich glaube ich schon 400 Mal gehört in den letzten Jahren.
Aber wisst ihr...
Das lässt einem immer die Hintertür ja auch offen, dass man dann sagt, na gut, Platz sieben, Platz acht, wir haben es ja fast geschafft, ist ja auch okay. Platz zwölf, na ja, wir haben es fast geschafft.
Ja, ich würde auch quasi so, wenn es jetzt um die Chartplatzierung des Rasenfunk geht, würde ich mir auch aktuell einen Stand angucken, einfach zehn Plätze draufrechnen, dann bin ich immer safe und habe immer meinen Soll erfüllt. Aber Tim, Michi, kleine Quizfrage für zwischendurch. Könnt ihr mir denn aus dem Kopf sagen, welcher eurer Vereine mehr Jahre Zweitliga-Zugehörigkeit hat?
Ich würde jetzt einfach viert sagen, weil sie in der ewigen Zweitligatabelle vorne sind. Das ist die einzige Herleitung, die ich habe.
Ja, ich würde sagen St. Pauli, weil Greuda führte ja zwischendurch auch Greuda 5 hieß, weil sie immer Fünfter geworden sind. Und ich glaube, die sind von den Platzierungen einfach besser gewesen in der zweiten Liga. Das heißt, ich würde sagen, St. Pauli hat mehr Saisons, aber steht in der Tabelle dahinter.
Nee, es ist tatsächlich so. Furt, 33 Jahre, St. Pauli, 31 Jahre. Oder Saisons ist es ja eigentlich dann richtig. Und tatsächlich in der ewigen Tabelle der zweiten Liga liegt Furt auch vorne. Aber es sind tatsächlich die Mannschaften mit der längsten Zweitligazugehörigkeit im deutschen Fußball.
Ja, und es ist jetzt bemerkenswert, weil wenn man sich so das Dienstalter der Zweitligisten anschaut, dann ist es sehr nach Norddeutschland gewandt. Der FC St. Pauli geht jetzt in sein 13. Jahr in Folge in der zweiten Liga. Also wir haben echt schon richtig Staub angesetzt da. Dann kommt Holstein-Kiel und dann kommt schon der HSV. Also das ist, was so das Dienstalter angeht von den Zweitligisten.
Oder aufgrund eines Ausflugs von Fürth, der ganz sehr kurzer war. Sonst hätte man da ja auch 10, 12 langsam stehen.
Ich habe so ein Fun-Fact für Nerds. Und zwar hatte ich mal die Tabellenführer-Liste der 2. Bundesliga selber eruieren müssen, weil es einfach nirgendwo verfügbar war. Und mich hat es mal interessiert, wo denn die Lilien da stehen, weil sie einfach jetzt so lange Tabellenführer waren. Also die Lilien sind siebter mit 82 Tabellenführungen. Davon sind 49 noch in die Zeit der Nord- und Südstaffel gefallen. Aber die zwei Partnerclubs hier in dem Podcast, also St. Pauli, was würdest du sagen? Vielleicht hast du auch schon gesehen, Tim.
Ja, ich habe den Artikel gelesen von dir. Ich rate mal nicht mit.
Nee, also St. Pauli ist 13. mit 43 Tabellenführungen, 14 in Nord- und Südstaffel-Zeiten und 4 als Urgestein in der 2. Liga, wenn man so will. Tatsächlich nur auf Platz 16 mit 40 Tabellenführungen. Und erster ist –soll ich euch mal raten lassen? Vielleicht habt ihr das aber auch schon gesehen.
Das müsste doch der Klub sein. Der ist auch ständig hochgegangen.
Nee, der hat sogar weniger als die Lilien. Die hat 78 erste Plätze. Also der erste ist tatsächlich Köln, der erste FC mit 109. Und der zweite ist Freiburg mit 108. Diese Urgesteine sind oft vielleicht nicht aufgestiegen. Deshalb sind es auch Urgesteine. Und dann in der Tabelle zumindest nicht so weit vorne. Aber Heidenheim mit der zweiten Tabellenführung –ever –die Meisterfelge abgekrallt. Also alles richtig gemacht.
Aber echt, Schapo, noch mal nach Heidenheim. Also das sind die Urgesteine. Dann lass doch mal noch über die Neulinge, zumindest in dieser Saison die Neulinge, sprechen. Nämlich Kaiserslautern, Magdeburg und Braunschweig. Denn die sind, Michi, alle drin geblieben. Wie war das denn möglich?
Ich glaube, da gibt es keine allgemeingültige Antwort. Da muss man schon den Blick genauer auf die verschiedenen Vereine richten. Also man kann jetzt nicht sagen, Magdeburg und Braunschweig sind mit den gleichen spielerischen Mitteln, mit der gleichen Herangehensweise drin geblieben.
Geht sich zu.
Das sieht man schon, wenn man diverse Statistiken durchschaut. Also da ist Magdeburg sehr oft für einen Aufsteiger erstaunlich oft sehr weit oben zu finden. Und Braunschweig eben sehr weit unten. Man kann das ja einfach durchgehen, dass ein Aufsteiger auf Platz 2 im Ballbesitz ist in der 2. Liga. Und weit oben ist bei den Pässen das letzte Drittel bei den Pässen insgesamt. Das spricht ja schon dafür, dass man dann in Anfangs der Liga einen radikalen Ansatz hat. Wir hatten es vorhin bei Tim Walther. Christian Titz ja auch. Man will eben radikalen Ballbesitz-Fußball spielen. Dann will man auch immer spielen. Das wollte Föhrt auch mal eine Zeit lang. Da hat Magdeburg in der ersten Halbzeit 66 Prozent Ballbesitz gehabt. Das war schon krass zu sehen. Mit welcher Selbstverständlichkeit sie diesen Weg auch durchziehen. Aber man sieht eben dann auch, dass die Klasse individuell nicht ausreicht, um das auch auf 34 Spiele durchzuziehen. Im Endeffekt ist es sehr souverän drin geblieben. Das war auch schön, weil es verdient ist für diese Herangehensweise. Die mag ich einfach als Fußballbeobachter. Aber natürlich hat man da auch gesehen, wenn dann mal der Torwart patzt, wenn er hoch steht, wenn der Verteidiger patzt, wenn die Bälle nicht so gut kommen, wenn auch allgemein das Übergangsspiel auch nicht immer wahnsinnig gut ist. Das sieht jetzt nicht nach Pep Guardiola aus. Das ist schon klar. Das hat der erste FC Magdeburg. Aber es ist ein wahnsinnig guter Ansatz gewesen. Und man sieht auch da wieder, meine These von vorhin, wenn man seinen Ansatz kontinuierlich verfolgt, dem treu bleibt, auch personell dem treu bleibt mit dem Trainer, dann zahlt sich das sehr oft aus in der 2. Liga und allgemein im Fußball. Und allein dafür hat Magdeburg schon verdient, drin zu bleiben. Plus auch das Umfeld in Magdeburg ist auch Wahnsinn. Du hast vorhin gesagt, Max, das ist Erstligareif. Vielleicht ist Magdeburg von der schieren Ansatz noch nicht Erstligareif, aber diese Lautstärke in dem Stadion, was da für eine Power von den Rängen kommt. Ich war in der Hinrunde dort, das war wahnsinnig gut. Auch Kollegen von mir, die dort waren, haben das gesagt. Das macht natürlich auch noch mal was aus. Da ist bei Heimspiel schon eine gewisse Power da. Ich habe jetzt nicht den Platz in der Heimtabelle vor Augen. Wahrscheinlich ist das gar nicht so gut. Das ist nur ein Gefühl. Magdeburg ist einfach aufgrund seiner Idee und seiner Zielstrebigkeit in dieser Idee drin geblieben. Das ist sehr, sehr schön. Darf ich gerne jemand anderes Braunschweig erklären?
In der Heimtabelle Rang 13 muss ich noch kurz nachliefern. Auswärtstabelle dann Rang 9. Aber es ist halt auch fehleranfällig, das Spiel, was Magdeburg macht, mit so viel Ballbesitz und so weiter. Das hast du halt auch in so manchem Heimspiel gesehen.
Aber Magdeburg, für die würde ich auch gerne eine Lanze brechen. Wir haben es zwar am vorletzten Spieltag gegen Magdeburg gezogen, 1-0 am Bödle, aber eine unfassbare Zockertruppe. Was die schon an Ballbesitzphasen und auch Passagen haben, also à la Bonheur, ich finde auch, das ist alles andere als selbstverständlich, dass ein Aufsteiger sich so treu bleibt und ja auch am Anfang schon zu struggle hatte. Also durchaus im Tabellenkettlerstand sich dann doch nicht zu einer Trainerentlassung oder sonst was hinreißen lässt, sondern an diesen Spielstil glaubt mit einer Truppe, die man durchaus als No-Name-Truppe bezeichnen kann, finde ich, dass da so eine Ballgewandtheit, so eine Idee von Fußball spielen zu wollen da ist, die dann auch verfängt. Also da kann ich nur sämtliche Hüte ziehen. Das ist für mich schon fast, wenn man nur den Spielstil und wo sie herkommen betrachtet, für mich eine Mannschaft der Saison tatsächlich. Und sie haben ja die dritte Liga gewissermaßen dominiert und auch Baris Atik, der eine kleine Liga in Vergangenheit hat, hat es in der zweiten Liga auch bewiesen, dass er hier Schritt halten kann. Also echt wirklich krass. Und auch jetzt Spiele, die einfach aus niederen Klassen zu denen kamen und wie Elhan Kouri plötzlich phasenweise Mittelstürmer spielen, phasenweise Außenverteidiger, da denkt man sich auch so, wie geht das? Bei Magdeburg ging es auf und das Torverhältnis 48 zu 55 ist jetzt auch vollkommen okay. Also die Anzahl der Gegentore ist jetzt nicht desaströs, zwar auch nicht wirklich hurra, aber sie haben es durch ihr Offensivspiel wettgemacht. Also da finde ich auch Magdeburg ein absoluter Ehrenschleifchen.
Ich vermute mal, Tim, dir wird das auch sehr gut gefallen haben, denn ich weiß ja, dass du auf solchen Fußball stehst, Ballbesitzfußball.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also Magdeburg, da würde ich jetzt auch mal die These wagen, dass wenn einer von den drei Aufsteigern der letzten Saison, wenn der in der nächsten Saison ganz oben mitspielen könnte, dann ist der erste FC Magdeburg. Wenn da transfermäßig vielleicht ein bisschen was passiert. Man darf ja auch nicht vergessen, die haben ja auch vor der Saison mit Obermeier zum Beispiel, haben sie ja auch einfach unfassbar wichtige Spieler auch abgegeben und haben trotzdem da so eine Rolle gespielt. Und wie du das gesagt hast, Matthias, dass die dann die Ruhe auch haben, als es dann sportlich auch nicht lief, was ja auch irgendwie zu erwarten war, dass sie dann daran festgehalten haben, ich muss sagen, Christian Titzer so ein bisschen was geändert hat, so ein ganz klein bisschen hat er Anpassungen vorgenommen, aber er hat sie eben vorgenommen, ohne diese Grundprinzipien, diese Grundidee loszulassen. Das ist schon richtig gut. Also sportlich ist Magdeburg auf jeden Fall eines der aufregendsten Teams der Liga gewesen. Das habe ich auch gerne zugeschaut immer. Und auch, ihr habt jetzt von den Spielen von Darmstadt und Fürth berichtet, St. Pauli war, glaube ich, das war in der Hinrunde, das einzige Spiel, in dem ein Gegner, das mehr Ballbesitz hatte als St. Pauli, war gegen Magdeburg tatsächlich. Und in der Rückrunde hat Magdeburg die in der ersten Halbzeit komplett an die Wand gespielt, mit diesem hohen Verteidigen allein. Also, dass die dann mit dem letzten Mann 35 Meter vor dem gegnerischen Tor direkt nach vorne verteidigen, ist halt auch einfach ein Statement, was dann gemacht wird, mit einer Aggressivität, die man sonst ja ganz selten vielleicht auch sieht. Das ist schon gut. Magdeburg habe ich gern geschaut in dieser Saison. Da gibt es so ein paar Teams, die ich gern geschaut habe. Magdeburg gehört auf jeden Fall dazu.
Und trotz all der Lobhudelei ist Magdeburg gar nicht der beste Aufsteiger gewesen. Das ist nämlich der FCK, der ist auf Rang 9 eingelaufen. Und Rang 9 ist tatsächlich auch die schlechteste Saisonplatzierung gewesen. Einmal war man da schon in der Hinrunde und jetzt am Ende. Das heißt, eigentlich war man sogar noch besser als Rang 9. Vor allem die Hinrunde war sehr gut. Matthias, was ist zum FCK zu sagen? Also man sieht da, es gibt wieder so ein paar Ingredienzien, die gibt es oft bei Lautern. Also zum Beispiel irgendwie Zuschauerschnitt von 40.000. Also Heimspiele, einfach wieder sehr stimmungsvoll. Da gab es ja auch –war das nicht sogar gegen Darmstadt am allerersten Spieltag? Am allerersten Spieltag gegen Hannover.
Ja, da hatten sie doch, glaube ich, einen späten Siegtreffer erzielt. Und auch in der Rückrunde den ersten Spieltag logischerweise dann in Hannover. Da lagen sie zur Halbzeit 1-0 zurück, und da habe ich zur zweiten Halbzeit dazugeschaltet, und das war beeindruckend. Also das haben sie an 3-1 gewonnen in Hannover, und Hannover war ja zu dem Zeitpunkt der Saison durchaus noch Anwärter auf vorderen Plätze und hat dann richtig abgekackt. Aber da fand ich, hat Kaiserslauternes verstanden, so dieses Momentum des Aufstiegs, das haben sie ja auch schwerer gemacht als notwendig. Also unter Antwerp ist noch den Aufstieg, den direkten verspielt. Dann kam Schuster, was ja ein sehr unkonventioneller Move war, der dann aber aufging. Und ich glaube, wenn man was kann in Kaiserslautern, dann durch erdliche Arbeit das Publikum auf seine Seite ziehen. Und sie haben ja auch spielerische Elemente drin gehabt mit Clement und Co. Also da war eine gute Mischung am Start. Und ich glaube, so diese Aufstiegsseuphorie hat sie über lange Strecken der Saison getragen. Und ich habe sogar bis um Spieltag 23, 24 gesagt, na, pass mir auf Kaiserslautern auf. Der Schuster weiß, wie so ein Durchmarsch funktioniert. Aber dann haben sie doch, glaube ich, so ein bisschen die Decke erreicht. Und mit der Punktgrenze damals, irgendwie 39 sind sie ein bisschen festgeklebt, dann 40, dann war irgendwie die Luft raus. Also da bin ich jetzt wirklich gespannt, welche Lehren aus dieser Rückrunde gezogen werden. Sie hatten gleich wohl auffällige Spieler. Also eine Lute als Torwart kann sich jetzt auch nicht jeder Drittliga-Aussteiger leisten. Ich glaube, da hat ja die ganze Geschichte mit Insolvenz und Corona etc. Da kennst du dich mehr aus. Max hast ja auch mal hier ausgiebig besprochen mit einem Gast. Das hat denen natürlich gut getan. Und vorne Beuth hat sich auch in der 2. Liga zurechtgefunden. War ein Anker-Spieler, auch einer, der emotional ist, der die Sprache der Fans spricht, der genau weiß, welche Klaviatur man da an der Stelle zu spielen hat. Und da ging einfach viel auf. Also im Moment würde ich es fast jetzt mit der etwas schwächeren Rückrunde, mit der Euphorie des Aufstiegs erklären, dass da so lange diese Welle geritten wurde. Im Endeffekt bin ich wirklich dann eher gespannt, wie es nächste Saison geht, also welche Antworten dann Schuster hat, dass das wieder in ein gutes Spielsystem passt, das dann auch die Punkte bringt und nicht irgendwie am Endeffekt dann nur ein Punkt und man ernährt sich eher schlecht als recht. Da bin ich eher jetzt ein interessierter Beobachter, um das erstmal weiter stricken zu können.
Beim FCK hat man schon auch gemerkt, was dieses Stadion ausmachen kann, also das ist ja immer so das Stadion-Gewinnenspieler, das ist beim FCK einfach auch so. Es ist natürlich nie so, man denkt immer, dieser Mythos Betzenberg an einem Samstagnachmittag ist der jetzt auch nicht so furchteinflößend, aber wenn die Mannschaft mal gut spielt, wenn sie die Tugenden auf den Platz bringt, wenn sie die Zweikämpfe gewinnt, sind da so einfache Dinge oft, die dann dazu führen, dass dort so ein Stadion eine Wucht entwickelt. Als ich dort war, war das auch zu spüren, dass dann der FCK, wenn da mal ein Tor schießt, dann wird das immer mehr. Die Menschen sind sehr begeisterungsfähig. Ich glaube, da müssen sie wieder hinkommen. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen verloren gegangen in der Rückrunde, weil sie einfach nicht mehr recht den Tritt gefunden haben, aber das wird auch weiterhin für den FCK wahrscheinlich das Wichtigste sein, dass sie mit diesem Stadion, mit der Wucht, die der ganze Verein entwickeln kann, einfach wieder in der 2. Liga zu einer Größe werden. Und es ist ja trotzdem, du hast gesagt, Max Beste, Aufsteiger, Platz 9. Das ist ja trotzdem schon mal gut nach den Jahren, die der FCK hinter sich hat. Also hat er auch mal vor einigen Jahren noch unten in der 3. Liga mitgespielt und das ist noch gar nicht so lange her. Deswegen ist das schon mal gut. Und jedes Jahr 2. Liga bringt natürlich auch finanziell wieder sehr, sehr viel. Das haben wir jetzt auch schon an dieser Stelle oft besprochen. Und deswegen ist der Platz 9 für den FCK in der 2. Liga mehr als okay, glaube ich. Und es kann jeder damit gut in den Sommer gehen, aber es wird schon auch jetzt dann spannend zu sehen sein, wie es weitergeht in der nächsten Saison. Also weil, wenn man natürlich das nicht in den Tritt findet und so weiter spielt, dann kann man natürlich immer unten festhängen. Das ist auch klar.
Also ich glaube, Sylvain Višuštov steht schon auch für eine gewisse Demut, der auch, glaube ich, Dinge recht gut beobachten kann und einzuschätzen weiß. Ich glaube, er ist an der Stelle richtig, weil ich glaube, die Pfalz lässt sich auch gerne mal euphorisieren. Und er ist dann jemand, der dann auch die Bremse findet und sagt, guck mal, wo wir herkommen. Das ist in dem Fall nicht nur eine Platitüde, sondern ein Fakt. Und ich glaube, dass das Umfeld auch mit dem 9. Platz schlussendlich sehr zufrieden und einverstanden ist. Sie waren nie ein Abstiegsnöten. Max, du hast gesagt, immer in der ersten Tabellenhälfte. Und deshalb läuft da einfach viel in die richtige Richtung. Und als die Ligen dort 3 zu 3 gespielt hatten, da hatten sie 2-0 geführt bis zur 70. oder 65. Da war für mich das Spiel schon fast gegessen. Und dann wird mit einem Tor das Stadion angezündet und es steht 2 zu 3. Und auf den letzten Drucker noch ein 3 zu 3, was den Ligen, glaube ich, dann für den weiteren Saisonverlauf gezeigt hat. Den Deckel drauf machen ist wichtig, aber wir können auch zurückkommen. Also sie haben danach dann auch Spiele gedreht wie gegen KSC, wie gegen Paderborn. Also für die Ligen war dieses Erlebnis Betzenberg auch ganz wichtig. Und das ist ein Faktor. Und solange die Fans hinter dem Verein stehen und mit Schuss haben sie einen ehrlichen Arbeiter vorne dran. Ich glaube, da kann schon was zusammenfinden. Aber ich bin dennoch gespannt und ein bisschen abwattend, wie das weitergeht.
Ja, da gab es einen schönen Artikel von, auf der Betze brennt, glaube ich im März oder April, als es eben um diese Demut ging, als es sportlich nicht mehr ganz so rund, euphorisch lief, wie noch in der Hinrunde, dass man da doch einmal durchatmen solle und auch schauen soll, wo man herkommt. Also ich glaube, Platz 9 ist eine super Platzierung als Aufsteiger aus der dritten Liga. Und da die Bedingungen, auch die wirtschaftlichen Bedingungen wahrscheinlich im Kaiserslautern sind relativ gut, um sich dann doch das schwierige zweite Jahr eines Aufsteigers vielleicht ein bisschen besser zu überstehen als andere.
Und es war eben gar nicht die Heimstärke letztlich, auch wenn das quasi so ein bisschen das Klischee von Lautern ist, aber in der Heimtabelle glaube ich nur Rang 13 in der Hinrunde, die war ja so besonders stark, da ist man ja auf Rang 4 rausgekommen. Auswärts ungeschlagen gewesen. Vier Siege, vier Unentschieden. Und ich denke, die Hausaufgabe an den FCK ist klar. Schießt bitte auch mal in der ersten Hälfte Tore, denn ihr seid gut darin zurückzukommen. Kein Team hat mehr Punkte nach Rückstand geholt. Nur ein Team hat glaube ich endlich viele Tore geschossen. Ich glaube, 18 der Tore waren in der letzten Schlussviertelstunde plus Nachspielzeit und sie haben insgesamt 47 gemacht, also ordentlicher Anteil. Hätte man allerdings zur Halbzeit schon das Spiel abgepfiffen, dann wäre Lautern direkt wieder runtergegangen. Vorletzter Platz, nur 30 Punkte hätte man da geholt. Man hat nur 11 Tore in der ersten Hälfte geschossen. Also bei Lautern wusste man immer, Anteil verpasst ist kein Problem, schau dir nur die zweite Hälfte an, dann kriegst du noch das Wichtigste mit beim FTK. Da bin ich mal gespannt, ob man daran doch drehen kann. Und dann sind wir ja mit Eintracht Braunschweig im großen Abstiegssegment dieser Tabelle. Ich weiß nicht, Michi, warum, da ich mich jetzt dann doch wieder an dich wende. Na gut, ich weiß es, weil wir werden auch in dem Zuge jetzt dann auch sicherlich auch noch über Fürth unter anderem sprechen. Aber um jetzt mal quasi mit Braunschweig zu beginnen, wie haben die es denn dann letztlich geschafft, drin zu bleiben mit 36 Punkten deiner Meinung nach?
Da stellt sich mir die zweite schwierige Frage an, weil es ist ähnlich wie Düsseldorf. Ich tue mich da auch schwer, mir das zu erklären. Natürlich kann man es erklären mit einzelnen Spielern. Das ist vielleicht der einfachste Ansatz mit Spielern wie Uca, wie Feray, auch mit Benkovic in der Abwehr. Wahnsinnig gute Einzelspieler. Eigentlich fast schon zu gut für einen Aufsteiger, diese Einzelspieler. Aber sie haben sich nach Braunschweig gelotst. Man kann es vielleicht mit dem Trainer erklären, Michael Schiele, der auch eine gewisse Ruhe ausstrahlt. Er ist einfach anpassungsfähig. Wir haben über Trainer gesprochen, vorhin Tim Walther, der seine Idee verfolgt. Ich glaube, Schiele ist eher so ein Trainer, der doch anpassungsfähiger ist und mit dem, was verfügbar ist, das Beste rausholt. Der steht jetzt nicht für eine klare Idee. Wenn du auch Freund Pürth genannt hast, ist es auch mit einem Trainer zu tun, der oft für eine klare Idee steht. Das ist Michael Schiele eben nicht. Aber es ist auch eine Kunst als Trainer, das Beste aus den vorhandenen Mitteln herauszuholen. Wenn du drei Spieler hast, die potenziell Unterschiedsspieler sein können in der 2. Liga, mit Freirei, einem wahnsinnig kreativen Spieler, den man jetzt auch nicht bei einem Aufsteiger erwartet. Das ist schon auch gut. Das sind einfach gute Transfers gewesen. Ich finde es immer ganz amüsanter, das auf Twitter zu sehen. Ab und zu gibt es Diskussionen, dass Braunschweig eine so gute Transfers macht, dass sie manchmal im Scouting Altbacken arbeiten. Diese drei Transfers waren auf jeden Fall sehr gut. Das zahlt sich dann eben aus. Wenn man diese drei Spieler hat, dann können die an guten Tagen das Spiel entscheiden. Ich habe es noch gut vor Augen. Vor einigen Wochen hat Föhrt gegen Braunschweig gespielt. Freirei zu sehen, das war Wahnsinn. Dann hätte ich mir jetzt auch bei allen anderen 17 Zweitligisten vorstellen können. Der wäre auch beim HSV mit Sicherheit nicht abgefallen. In den Phasen, in denen Ludovic Reis schlecht war, hätte Freirei mit Sicherheit auch spielen können. In den letzten Wochen und Monaten. Das ist ein bisschen übertrieben gesagt. Natürlich ist es auch viel Wille, diesen Aufsteig auch mitbringen muss. Ich habe das Spiel vor Augen, das Derby gegen Hannover, wo sie in der Nachspielzeit das Spiel einfach gewinnen, weil sie es gewinnen wollen. Und den Ball hat dann einfach in der Nachspielzeit, ich glaube, es war nach einer Ecke, noch ins Tor irgendwie reinbringen. Aber das sind halt auch so Spiele, die muss dann eben gewinnen, und die geben natürlich auch einen Push im Laufe einer Saison. Derby gegen Hannover gewinnt, in Viert war es ähnlich, mit dem Derby sie gegen Nürnberg, da dachte man auch, der gibt einen Riesen-Push, war es eigentlich ganz so. Aber solche Spiele sind ja auch wichtig, um vielleicht mal in diesen Flow zu kommen, von dem wir gesprochen haben, um auch mal Serien aufzubauen. Das ist jetzt Braunschweig auch nicht dauerhaft gelungen, aber sie haben es eben dann doch geschafft, immer wieder wichtige Spiele zu gewinnen, auch wenn sie jetzt am letzten Spieltag natürlich, das gehört auch zur Wahrheit, großes Glück hatten, dass Amine Bielefeld eben die Einladung nicht angenommen hat, weil wenn Bielefeld gewonnen hätte, wäre Braunschweig in der Relegation gewesen. Und das als Mannschaft, die sehr, sehr selten da unten dann eigentlich fest drin war, also die wären ja auch dann abgestürzt am letzten Spieltag und das wäre natürlich auch für den Kopf nicht einfach gewesen, weil du bei Bielefeld gesehen hast, was der Kopf dann in der Relegation ausmachen kann.
Ich muss dir fast ein bisschen widersprechen, Michi, weil ich bei Braunschweig fand ich, dass man da über die Saison doch schon eine ziemlich klare Handschrift von Schiele gesehen hat, nämlich diesen krassen Fokus auf das Umschaltspiel. Diese sind eine der, was die Distanz angeht, eine der laufschwächsten Teams der Liga, was die Anzahl der Sprints angeht. Dann wieder ziehen sie mit zu den stärksten. Da ist Heidenheim natürlich überall top, aber dahinter kommt eigentlich irgendwie, glaube ich, bei den Sprints ist Braunschweig zumindest nicht ganz so weit weg. Und das fand ich schon enorm. Damit sind sie auch aufgestiegen mit dieser Spielweise, mit diesem Fokus auf das Umschaltspiel. Da haben Sankt Pauli da. Die sind ja die Zerstörer der Serie gewesen in der Rückrunde. Die haben Sankt Pauli da die Niederlage zugefügt. Und es war völlig klar, wie gespielt wird. Es war allen klar, wie gespielt wird, was Braunschweig vorhat. Und Sankt Pauli ist ja nicht in die Falle reingetappt, aber hat sich trotzdem zwei Konter gegen Tore gefangen. Und da konnten sie dann doch das ein oder andere Mal während der Saison vor allem zum Ende, oder ich sage mal so im Mittleren bis letzten Drittel, so einen Zwischenabschnitt, so einen kleinen Run hinlegen, der sie dann auch gerettet hat, glaube ich. Also gerade in der Hinrunde hatten die eine Phase, wo sie richtig gut gepunktet haben. Und da lief eben dieses Umschaltspiel enorm gut mit Uca, mit Ferai, wie du gesagt hast, aber auch… Kaufmann, Lauberbach, da sind Leute dabei, die sind genau dafür da. Und dann hast du hinten so jemanden wie Benkovic drin, der einfach alles rausköpft. Patrick Pfeiffer war ja immer der Kopfversteckste Spieler, bis Philipp Benkovic in die Liga gekommen ist. Dann hast du auf einmal noch mal ein ganz anderes Level erreicht an Kopfballstärke im Zweiten Liga-Fußball. Und die Handschrift fand ich schon relativ klar. Und Michael Schüle fand ich irgendwie beeindruckend. Als er mit St. Pauli oder am Millantor war, auf seiner Pressekonferenz, da hat er sich so relativ authentisch gezeigt und auch geäußert dazu. Und sehr realistisch dazu auch geäußert, was sein Team kann und was es auch eben nicht kann. Also der versucht da gar nicht, den dreifachen Rittberger sozusagen mit dem Team, weil es das einfach nicht kann, weil der Kader nicht darauf zugeschnitten ist, sondern spielt dann defensiv Karo einfach und offensiv mit viel Tempo so ungefähr. Und wie nachhaltig das ist, muss man dann sehen. Aber es hat sich auf jeden Fall in der Saison gerettet mit einem Kader, der ja klar, Ferrei muss man vielleicht ein bisschen ausklammern, aber doch ein bisschen limitiert ist. Das fand ich schon, finde ich schon beeindruckend. Es ist auch wieder bei all drei Aufsteigern, muss man sagen, haben alle drei Trainer eine ganz klare Handschrift mit. Das finde ich persönlich total toll, dass man das so doch deutlich erkennen kann dann immer.
Und vor allem haben alle drei ihre Trainer behalten. Also keiner hat einen Trainer entlassen. Alle gingen durch die 34 Spieltage mit den Trainern. Das ist natürlich auch schon mal ein Zeichen, dass was funktioniert oder zumindest, dass nicht so der Handlungstruck ganz groß ist. Und Ferey und Utscha habe ich jetzt gerade mal gesehen, haben 19 Tore geschossen von 42. Also der Anteil von den beiden ist natürlich schon massiv. Wenn da jemand verlustig gehen sollte, müssten sie natürlich reagieren. Ansonsten ist mir auch noch vom Spiel am Bölle, was sie relativ unglücklich in der Nachspielzeit verloren haben, doch eine gewisse körperliche Präsenz auch vor Augen. Und mit so Spielern wie dem Donkor oder auch Bonga haben sie sogar zwei im Kader, die Brüder haben, die in einem amerikanischen Profisport untergekommen sind. Bonga hat in der NBA gespielt und Donkor, glaube ich, in der NFL. Also auch so ein Seitenaspekt, der mir damals noch so untergekommen ist. Aber Braunschweig sicherlich auch nicht ganz unwichtig gegen Bielefeld noch 3 zu 3 gespielt zu haben, nachdem sie 13.0 zurückgeladen haben. Dieses Spiel hat Bielefeld vielleicht auch Körner gekostet und führte ja dann zur Entlassung des Trainers, des zweiten dann schon in der Saison, woraufhin dann der nächste kam, mit dem sie jetzt dann tatsächlich auch trotzdem runter mussten. Aber das erste Spiel unter ihm haben sie gegen die Ligien 3 zu 1 gewonnen, und zwar auf den letzten Drücker. Durch ein Traumtor in der 89. oder so und in der Nachspielzeit ein Tor durch Kloss, wo man dachte, also jetzt ist in Bielefeld alles gesettelt. Also so ein Spiel gegen den Serwellenführer gewonnen auf den letzten Metern aus dem 0 zu 1, 1 zu 3 zu machen, Kloss als die Galionsfigur macht sogar mal nach lang, meine ich, wieder ein Tor. Also da ging, glaube ich, in dem Moment so viel auf, wo ich dachte, okay, Bielefeld safe, da gibt es kein Vertun, die man sich locker retten. Aber dann kamen auch Spiele, wo man gegen Lundberg zum Beispiel in der 97. noch einen Elfmeter kriegt und die drei Punkte liegen lässt. Also da war nie, glaube ich, so auch unter dem neuen Trainer. Das nahm ich jetzt die ganze Zeit nicht ein, der mir helfen kann. So ist es, danke. Auch unter ihm hat man es nicht verstanden, mal so einen Lauf zu kreieren. Also es war eher so mühsam, immer wieder Punkte zu sammeln oder auch mal ein Dreier, aber es hat nicht wirklich verfangen. Also schwierig.
Schwierig. Elegant übergeleitet.
Aber wirklich. Jetzt sind wir mitten im Abstiegssumpf. Bevor wir aber zu den Teams kommen, die wirklich abgestiegen sind, würde ich gerne an dich fragen. Michi, also Greuther Fürth hat sich mit 41 Punkten gerettet. Hans-Or Rostock hatte diese irre Serie, hat damit 41 Punkte geholt. Der Club hat es in all seiner Clubhaftigkeit trotzdem geschafft, mit 39 Punkten drin zu bleiben. Ich sage das mit höchstem Respekt, weil ich komme aus dieser Gegend. Ich weiß, wie sehr die Leute darunter leiden, aber sie wissen es ja selbst, wie der Club drauf ist. Dann sind Bielefeld, Regensburg und Sandhausen letztlich abgestiegen. Was war das für ein Abstiegskampf? Wir haben sehr oft über viele Teams gesprochen, die darunter hingen. Erst auf den letzten, wie auch im Ausstiegskampf, wo sich am Ende drei auskristallisiert haben. Ein bisschen war es am unteren Ende der Tabelle auch so.
Aus persönlicher Sicht war das ein nervendes Aufreiben, weil es anstrengend war, weil man bis zum 33. Spieltag aus Fürth nicht wusste, wo man nächste Saison spielt. Ich weiß es noch gut, ich bin mit unserem Fotografen nach Hamburg gefahren. Wir haben die Konferenz an dem Samstag angeguckt. Fürth war dann gesichert, als Bielefeld nicht gegen Paderborn gewann zu Hause. Das spricht auch dafür. Es wurde oft positiv über Fürth gesprochen. Sie haben es aber auch nie da unten raus geschafft, weil sie es auch nie geschafft haben, so wirklich mal einen Flow zu entwickeln. Das haben alle Mannschaften da unten nicht geschafft, mal da groß wirklich rauszukommen. Ich hatte es auch in Vorbereitung auf einem Podcast mit Alexander Zornig und Rashida Sousi. Fürth war gefühlt immer im Abstiegskampf. Am Ende hatten sie jetzt zehn Punkte Vorsprung auf den direkten Abstiegsplatz. Das klingt so wahnsinnig was für ein souveräner Klassenerhalt. Sie haben das geschafft und sogar sieben Punkte Vorsprung auf den Relegationsplatz waren es am Ende. Das täuscht ein bisschen darüber hinweg. Es war wirklich sehr, sehr eng. Marz Braunschweig und Bielefeld war es am Ende eng. Für den Club war es auch sehr, sehr eng. Das war für alle da unten. Man hat natürlich auch die Angst gespürt bei vielen Vereinen in Fürth. Bielefeld ist natürlich diese Angst, als Aufsteiger durchgereicht zu werden. Das wurde von beiden Vereinen auch mannigfaltig betont. Also als Absteiger. Als Absteiger aus der Bundesliga wieder nach unten durchgereicht zu werden und zweimal abzusteigen in Folge. Das war natürlich eine Parallele zwischen Fürth und Bielefeld, dass die Angst da auch riesig ist und dass beide Vereine natürlich auch nicht mit dem wahnsinnig großen Selbstbewusstsein abgestiegen sind. Das ist ja klar als Absteiger. Es ist in Fürth immer schön, dass man sagen kann, so schlimm war die Saison, gar nicht Bielefeld hat es noch schlimmer erwischt. Das ist vielleicht nicht eine positive Erklärung, aber das wird oft geäußert, also klar. Aber diese Last war bei beiden zu spüren. Wenn ich jetzt auch über Fürth spreche, das war nie befreit ausgesehen. Matthias hat es dann gesehen, wozu Fürth in der Lage ist, wenn sie mal befreit aufspielen können, dann ist das schon eine ziemlich gute Mannschaft. Der HSV hat das auch gemerkt. Der HSV hat zwar gewonnen, aber da mangelt es noch an gewissen Dingen. Da ist kein Kontertor geschossen in der ganzen Saison. Das sind so Dinge, die müssen besser werden. Und auch die Tore aus Beute muss besser werden. Da gibt es viel zu verbessern. Aber der Kopf ist da ein ganz, ganz wichtiges Thema. Und auch der Umgang mit Widerständen im Abstiegskampf. Das hat Zornigaard bestimmt –ich habe vorhin mal die Z400 genannt, wahrscheinlich 800-mal das Wort Widerstände genannt. Weil das natürlich auch so etwas ist, wenn du aus einer Saison kommst, in der du sehr viel verlierst. Wir haben auch in der Bundesliga-Maxi oft über Fürth gesprochen, wo sie immer verloren haben. Und das sind ja der Kern der Mannschaft, das ist immer auch der gleiche. Und der hat dann eineinhalb Jahre lang jede zweite Woche verloren. Und das macht was mit einem Menschen, das macht was mit einem Spieler. Und wenn du dann, wie jetzt in der HSV, in der Relegation nach 45 Sekunden einen Gegentor kassierst, dann ist es im Viertel ähnlich. Du hast wahnsinnig gut gespielt und zack kommt ein Gegentor. Und dann kommen wieder 15 schlechte Minuten. Und so ist es in einigen Vereinen da unten drin. Klar, der Trainerverschleiß war groß. Hans Rostock genannt, der Klub genannt mit drei Trainern. Bielefeld, drei Trainer, also das war ja schon sehr, sehr viel. Und das bringt natürlich auch keine Ruhe rein. Und man hat ja gesehen, wozu die Ruhe dann führt. Nämlich zu Klassenhalt von den drei Aufsteigern, die eben festgehalten haben. In Fürth war der Trainerwechsel überfällig, da war er auch gut. Da hat man jetzt ja noch an der Punkteausbeute gesehen, wozu er geführt hat. Aber ich persönlich als Reporter möchte den Klassenhalt einen Abstiegskampf nicht noch mal so erleben. Weil das ist schon anstrengend. Also man spielt lieber für etwas als gegen etwas. Das hat Alexander Zonnecke auch mal betont. Da hat man mehr zu gewinnen als zu verlieren.
Gleichzeitig ist da das Interessante, du hast es angesprochen. Die Aufsteiger haben alle ihren Trainer behalten. Und Föhrt und Bielefeld haben da Trainerabfindungen durch den Club geschmissen, wie Fuffis im Club. Bei Föhrt geht es, der Club. Der Club und Bielefeld, stimmt. Aber man hat ja auch das Gegenbeispiel mit Rostock, Tim. Dieser irre Lauf, es ist ja eigentlich nur, auf den Trainerwechsel zurückzuführen. Oder habe ich noch etwas übersehen?
Darf ich kurz reingerätschen, bevor Tim anfängt?
Bitte, du darfst Rostock komplett übernehmen, wenn du magst.
Du hast einen wichtigen Faktor unterschlagen, Max. Nämlich den Aufbaugegner für Hansa Rostock, der ein gern genommener Aufbaugegner in der 2. Liga ist. Nämlich Föhrt. Das war tatsächlich der erste Sieg von Rostock. Danach waren dann vier Siege am Stück oder fünf. Das war dieses Spiel, da kamen sie mit sieben oder acht Spielen ohne Sieg und haben dann gegen Föhrt zuhause gespielt. Ein wahnsinnig schlechtes Spiel von Föhrt und Rostock. Ein Rostockhaftiges Spiel und ein Alois Schwarzhaftiges Spiel. Sehr körperlich, auf gute Defensive bedacht. Und dann halt vorne mit Pröger zum Beispiel, einfach doch ein guter Zweitligaspieler. Aber ich kann das nur so erklären, dass Föhrt zur rechten Zeit kam und dann auch einen Flow entwickelt hat. Anders kann ich es mir auch nicht erklären.
Ja, ich meine, das war ja damals schon total strange. Alois Schwarz wird entlassen in Sandhausen als gebrannt markt, als erfolgloser Trainer und wechselt zu Rostock, die zu dem Zeitpunkt noch besser als Sandhausen dastanden. Und da funktioniert es dann auf einmal. Ich meine, Alois Schwarz, muss man ja auch sagen, der spielt jetzt nicht den kreativsten Fußball, lässt jetzt nicht den kreativsten Fußball spielen. Aber der ist für einige Teams, gerade im Abschließkampf, vielleicht auch einfach genau der Richtige, den man spielen kann. Ich leite mir das gerade alles her, weil ich habe da auch keine wirkliche Antwort darauf, wie sowas dann funktionieren kann wie in Rostock. Ich persönlich denke, dass der Kader selbst in Rostock gar nicht so schlecht war, wie sie zwischendurch standen. Die haben da richtig gute Spieler. Dennis Dressel, zum Beispiel, finde ich tatsächlich, passt da unfassbar gut rein. Ein richtig guter Zweitligaspieler, der –ich weiß gar nicht, ob das seine erste Saison war oder seine zweite –in der zweiten Liga, aber der hat da sehr gut reingepasst. Und dann eben Kai Pröger ist halt auch so ein Arsch-auf-eimer-Ding, der da aus Paderborn da hingekommen ist. Also da passen schon einige Sachen zusammen. Eine ziemlich physisch sehr starke Defensive da mit Ryan Malone da ganz hinten drin. Also da sind schon gute Leute dabei und irgendwie sind die aus dem Tritt gekommen. Ich habe diese Entlassung von Herthel, habe ich nicht verstanden, weil ich Herthel als Trainer eigentlich sehr, ja mochte, möchte ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber zumindest geschätzt habe, was für Arbeit er da geleistet hat, auch sehr pragmatisch da rangegangen ist, taktisch sehr flexibel hat spielen lassen. Und dann ist das Projekt mit Glöckner komplett in die Hose gegangen. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, was Schwarz da am Ende noch gemacht hat. Vielleicht hat er einfach mit Erfahrung von so jahrelangen Abstiegskämpfen, war das vielleicht einfach nötig, um das Team da zu stabilisieren. Ich meine, Rostock hat auch in der Saison davor, haben sie auch zumindest so einen Zwischenlauf gehabt, auch in der Rückrunde. Da sind die Aufbahn, die tabellarisch auch gar nicht so gut. Sie hatten dann so einen starken Zwischenlauf, wo sie auch auf Schalke gewonnen haben und, und, und. Und da, ja, mehr kann ich zu Rostock nicht sagen, möchte ich auch gar nicht eigentlich.
Und sie haben auch, sie haben halt gegen die richtigen Gegner auch die Punkte geholt, das ist halt auch ganz eindeutig. Also sie haben in Braunschweig, also gegen Braunschweig haben sie jetzt am Ende sechs Punkte geholt. In Bielefeld haben sie gewonnen, in der Rückrunde haben sie auch sechs Punkte geholt, in der Hinrunde nämlich auch gewonnen. So, wen haben wir noch da unten drin? Was haben sie mit dem Club gemacht? Okay, zweimal unentschieden. Also da konnte der Club gegen Rostock keine Punkte sammeln. Fürth wissen wir schon, Aufbaugegner ungeschlagen, auch ein Sieg, ein Unentschieden. Also ihr merkt schon, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wenn wir gucken, wo kommen denn eigentlich diese Punkte her von Rostock? Ja, daher kommen die aus diesen Duellen gegen diese Teams. Gegen Sandhausen haben sie immerhin einmal verloren, aber in der Rückrunde dann gewonnen. Und das war eben dann eins dieser ganz wichtigen Spiele. Also da kam Alois Schwarz und hat die Abwehr stabilisiert. Man hat gegen Fürth kein Gegentor kassiert und gewonnen. Man hat am Betzenberg kein Gegentor kassiert und gewonnen, egal wie. Und dann kamen die beiden Spiele gegen den Tabellen 17., den Tabellen 18., einmal zu Hause gegen Regensburg, einmal auswärts in Sandhausen. Und da wussten alle, wenn die das irgendwie durchziehen können, und es ist egal wie –und so waren ja auch manche Spiele auch, dass man da jetzt im Nachhinein nicht drüber sprechen möchte, wie sie das gewonnen haben. Aber dann wusste man ja gut, dann ziehen die sich am eigenen Schopf da unten raus. Und das haben sie geschafft. Und am Ende waren es dann fünf Siege in sechs Spielen, ungeschlagen, noch 0 zu 0 gegen Nürnberg. Und so bleibt man dann in der Liga. Aber es ist halt schon interessant, weil es gibt anscheinend kein richtig und kein falsch. Man kann die Trainer wechseln wie der 1. FC Nürnberg und drin bleiben. Man kann den Trainer wechseln wie Hansel Rostock und eine Serie starten. Man kann am Trainer festhalten und drin bleiben. Es hängt halt an vielen Faktoren.
Die Frage bei Alos Schwarz ist natürlich immer, wie nachhaltig das ist. Das hat man bei allen Stationen ja auch gemerkt. In Sandhausen und in Nürnberg ist es irgendwann relativ schnell wieder gegangen. Alias gegangen worden. Weil es eben dann auch nicht nachhaltig war, weil diese Art von Fußball auch leicht durchschaubar ist und man da immer auch Schwächen findet. Als Führer hast du gesagt, 2. Nürnberg und Rostock klingt jetzt wie ein souveränen Sieg. Da hätte es so viele Räume und Möglichkeiten gegeben, in die man reinspielen könnte. Das war weit davon entfernt, ein wahnsinnig souveräner Heimsieg zu sein. Aber mit dieser Körperlichkeit haben eben auch viele Vereine in der 2. Liga Probleme, unter anderem der, den ich begleite. Das reicht oftmals ja auch schon aus, wenn man halt dann lautern war. Es ist ähnlich, diese Körperlichkeit tut Spielern, die gut oder die gerne Fußball spielen wollen, die nicht so kämpfen wollen, das tut denen nicht gut. Aber das nutzt sich eben auch schnell wieder ab. Mir fehlt da auch die Fantasie, dass Alois Schwarz jetzt dann plötzlich in Rostock eine Mannschaft bildet, die nächstes Jahr dann Achter wird. Das sehe ich nicht. Aber ich lasse mich gerne lügen.
Ich glaube, das sehen, ehrlich gesagt, wenige Menschen. Wahrscheinlich sogar inklusive Alois Schwarz, so wie ich ihn einschätze. Aber Michi, du bist jetzt, weil du regional am allernästen dran bist, und arg viel näher dran, kann man kaum mehr sein, Außermann übernachtet direkt im Max-Morlock-Stadion. Du musst mir jetzt bitte den Club erklären. Also man ist ja drin geblieben mit 39 Punkten. Dieter Hecking hat am Ende das Hacking-Miracle dann doch vollendet mit dem Kader, den er selber zusammengestellt hat. Wir haben schon viel über den Club gesprochen in der Saison. Und ich kenne ja den Club quasi aus meiner eigenen Kindheit und Jugend und so weiter und so fort. Und Fränkische Landeszeitung und Nürnberger Zeitung und so weiter. Ich habe bei der Nürnberger Zeitung mein erstes Praktikum gemacht. Michi, ich weiß gar nicht, ob ich diesmal erzählt habe. Da wurden die Weichen auf Journalist gestellt. Das kann man schon so sagen. Also das heißt, ich kenne den Club. Und ich weiß auch schon, dass das oft so ist. Und ich kenne auch den Fatalismus aller Fans, die einem auch immer sagen, was hast du denn erwartet, Max? Und dennoch verstehe ich es nicht so ganz. Warum hat man sich denn schon wieder so schwer getan in dieser Saison?
Da hätte es jetzt den Kollegen Fadike Blami nochmal einladen müssen. Der hat den Club so viel häufiger gesehen. Ich tue mich da auch wahnsinnig schwer. Wir haben ja für jeden Tag eine Besprechung. Und wir sprechen auch persönlich sehr oft über die 2. Bundesliga und über den Club und die Spielverhandlung. Aber solch erklärbar ist es ja natürlich nicht, was der Club da macht. Der Kader ist nicht so schlecht, dass man am Ende 13. oder 14. Platz werden muss. Auf keinen Fall. Da sind auch gute Einzelspieler dabei. Aber sie haben es eben nie geschafft. Das würde ich konstant abzurufen. Und natürlich haben sie auch wahnsinnig –also das ist ein Erklärungsanz, aber der darf nicht der einzige sein –wahnsinnig viel Verletzungspech gehabt. Also sie hatten halt gefühlt vier Linksverteidiger im Kader, aber keiner davon hat gespielt regelmäßig. Also jeder hat sich immer wieder verletzt. Dann haben sie im Winter Janis Horn dazugeholt aus Bochum geliehen. Trainingslager, zack, erst das Spiel wieder verletzt. Also das ist natürlich auch nicht –aber das darf nicht der einzige Grund sein. Sie haben im Sommer 2 Millionen Euro für neue Stürmer ausgegeben. Und zum Beispiel Christoph der Ferner, der da kam, ich weiß nicht, ob er jetzt drei Tore hat, drei, vier. Er hat auf jeden Fall sehr wenig Tore gemacht dafür, dass er so viel gekostet hat. Dua hat zumindest die Tore gemacht. Er hat das zumindest gewissermaßen zurückgezahlt. Aber auch die Abwehr stand da nicht so fest. Da sind auch Schindler am Ende ausgefallen. Natürlich ist es ein Fakt, wenn Mannschaften eingespielt sind und wenn sie einen Rhythmus entwickeln können, ist das wahnsinnig viel wert. Der Klub konnte das eben nie. Aber das darf nicht der alleinige Erklärung sein. Das wird ein sehr guter Ansatz sein. Was ich beim Klub nie verstehen werde, das sag ich jetzt leicht, als beobachte er nie den Menschen da in die Augen schauen muss, auch wenn er fern da dransitzt, aber ich werde nicht verstehen, wie man ein so gutes NLZ haben kann und dann kommt dann nichts nach oben. Also die zweite Mannschaft vom Klub ist 4. Platz in der Regionalliga Bayern geworden. Die U19 hat auch wieder oben mitgespielt. Letztes Jahr waren sie Vizemeister in der U19-Staffel und das ist ja die Staffel in der Bayern, Hoffenheim und Stuttgart und alle guten NLZs, Mainz, Augsburg ist ja auch stark, die spielen da alle mit und da ist der Klub letztes Jahr Vizemeister geworden. Das heißt, sie haben schon einen großen Fundus an Talenten, die aber irgendwie nie oben ankommen. Also sie haben es jetzt mal am Ende geschafft, mit Can Usun zum Beispiel, der da gespielt hat. Sie haben auch jetzt bei der U17-EM, war es glaube ich, U17-EM, hatten Nürnberger Spieler mitgespielt. Also Finn Yeltsch zum Beispiel, die haben ja in ihrer Jugend sehr viel, woraus sie ein solides Fundament bauen könnten, wo man auch das, was wir vorhin hatten, die Identifikation schaffen könnte, dass Menschen, die beim Klub ausgebildet wurden, für den Klub in der zweiten Liga spielen. Aber irgendwie schaffen sie das nicht und ich kann nicht erklären, woher das kommt. Stattdessen hat man immer wieder sehr viel Wechsel im Kader. Jetzt habe ich auch schon letztes wieder gesehen, dass es Spieler gab wie Tempelmann, der jetzt in die Bundesliga geht, angeblich. Das kann ich mir auch nicht erklären, warum. Weil ich fand seine Leistung nie so berauschend, dass das ein Bundesligaspieler ist. Und mir fehlt da auch ein bisschen die Perspektive. Man wird jetzt weitermachen mit der Combo, anscheinend mit Hacking und mit Christian Fjeld als Co-Trainer, der jetzt dann Cheftrainer wird. Man hat ja schon die Weichen auf die Zukunft gestellt. Und alle haben sich in Nürnberg sehr viel versprochen von Christian Fjeld, weil er eben diese erfolgreiche U21 eben lang trainiert hat. Er hat eine klare Spielidee entwickelt, auch in einem 4-3-3 gespielt hat. Also ein spieleres, starkes 4-3-3 kann auch Spaß machen, dazu zu schauen. Bei der zweiten Mannschaft des Clubs hat es sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Sie haben zum Beispiel das Derby gegen Fürth im Hinspiel 5-1 gewonnen gegen das kleine Kleblatt.
Das Klebblättchen.
Das Klebblättchen, ja, 5-1 haben sie gewonnen. Dafür hat Fürth das Rückspiegel gewonnen, 3-1. Muss ich auch gleich anerkennen. Aber vielleicht ist es möglich, andererseits war es auch Fjeld trotzdem mit Hacking zusammen verantwortlich für diese Mannschaft. Mir fehlt jetzt die Fantasie, dass der jetzt so einen Rieseneinfluss hat und alles anders wird. Aber auch das kann natürlich sein, wenn er alleine arbeiten darf in Hacking, dann doch nur Sportvorstand bleibt und nicht mehr Trainer auf der Trainerbank sitzt und seine Ideen von Fußball vielleicht vermitteln will. Es kann funktionieren, aber ich glaube nicht, dass es passiert. Und beim Klub ist natürlich auch die finanzielle Sache immer eine, die man mitdenken muss. Weil er eben jetzt dann doch seit einigen Jahren auch immer in der 2. Liga unten mitgespielt hat. Also man hat vor drei Jahren Relegation gespielt, hat dann alles auf Null gesetzt und hat neu angefangen. Und jetzt ist man halt drei Jahre später und hat wieder fast Relegation gespielt. Und jetzt muss man irgendwie wieder anfangen, von da unten rauszukommen. So baut man natürlich auch keine Substanz auf. Drei Trainer verschlissen jetzt dann. Man will ein Stadion bauen, das kommt auch noch dazu. Das begleitet den Klub auch schon lange. Da muss man auch nach Finanzierungsmöglichkeiten nebenher suchen. Und dafür war es natürlich sehr wichtig, dass man in der 2. Liga geblieben ist als 1. FC Nürnberg, weil das ist ein städtisches Stadion. Die wollen mit Investoren zusammen ein Stadion bauen. Ich glaube, das wäre nicht so einfach, da auch in der Stadt Mehrheiten zu finden für einen Stadion, für einen Drittligisten, der dann in dieser Liga spielt, in der man auch mal gut und gerne zehn Jahre festhängen kann. Also, es war sehr, sehr wichtig, für den Club drin zu bleiben, aber wie sie es geschafft haben –sie haben die wichtigen Spiele gewonnen, das ist auch eine Erklärung. Sie haben gegen Düsseldorf zu Hause zum Beispiel gewonnen. Sie haben nicht gegen Rostock verloren in diesem Spiel am Ende. Haben sie auch noch einen Punkt geholt. Aber ja, natürlich hängt das auch von der Konkurrenz ab, also das darf auch nicht außer Acht lassen. Bielefeld hat dann einfach am Ende doch abreißen lassen. Das war auch ein Glück für den Club.
Ja, stimmt, wobei natürlich die Bilanz mit 39 Punkten ist dann schon eine sehr gute, muss man sagen. Aber was eben schon seit, also seit Marek Minter ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen weitgegriffen. Aber dass halt einfach der Club so wenige Tore immer schießt. Wieder die schlechteste Offensive der Liga. Es war in der letzten Saison nicht ganz so schlimm, wird jetzt nicht so tun, als wäre es immer. Aber zumindest seitdem wir wieder intensiver über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer sprechen im Rasenfunk, ist das Thema der Stürmerfrage und der Frage, wer Tore erziehen soll beim Club, schon sehr häufig hier zur Sprache gekommen.
Sie haben es ja versucht, mit zwei Millionen, die sie ausgegeben haben für zwei Stürmer. Und es hat im Falle von Quadro Dua ja geklappt, 11 Tore sind gut. Also für einen Zweitliga-Stürmer, das ist okay. Da müssen ja die anderen in der Mannschaft noch Tore schießen. Also es kann ja nicht ein Stürmer alleine, außer man heißt FC Heidenheim und hat Beste und Kleindienst, dann geht das. Aber wenn ein Stürmer halt 11 Tore schießt und man hat aber noch ein paar 8er und 10er, die noch ein paar Tore schießen und ein Innenverteidiger da 4, 5 Tore nach Ecken macht, dann geht es schon irgendwann. Aber wenn halt dann einer mit 11 kommt –ich weiß nicht, wer die Zweitmeisten hat, wahrscheinlich irgendjemand mit 4 oder so, 3 oder 4 Tore beim Klub –das ist einfach zu wenig. Sie haben die Spiele, die sie gewonnen haben, meistens auch dann halt mit 1 oder 2-0 gewonnen. Oder mal 2-1, glaube ich, nicht nur unter Inzernhausen. Aber sie haben ja auch dann nie hohe Siege gefeiert. Das wäre auch mal wichtig für Selbstbewusstsein womöglich. Man wird sehen, ob da jetzt jemand anderes kommt. Sie haben ja mit Shura Now auch schon eines ihrer Talente abgegeben, der jetzt gar keine Rolle mehr gespielt hat. Dua Villain gebe ich auch irgendwo, höher Klassik spielen. Da weiß man auch nicht zurecht, da ist jetzt auch noch nicht das Gerüst da für die nächste Saison, dass man sagt, ok, darauf können sie jetzt wahnsinnig aufbauen. Ob der spielet, vielleicht ist es besser geworden fußballerisch. Aber mir fehlt zu dir auch beim Klub die Fantasie, dass der nächstes Jahr auf jeden Fall ganz oben angreifen wird. Ich bin nicht so gut im Tippen, aber das wird glaube ich nicht passieren.
Ich finde das total bemerkenswert, weil ich immer denke, dass von den Namen her, dass der Klub gerade was die Stürmerposition angeht, eigentlich total gut besetzt ist. Ich meine, da hat man sich beim FC St. Pauli echt drüber geärgert, dass der nicht zu St. Pauli gekommen ist vor der Saison. Die haben da ja mitgeboolt drum. Und am Ende…
Hey, zweiterfolgreichster Torschütze beim Klub. Drei Tore ist nämlich die richtige Antwort auf deine Frage, Freund Michi.
Genau. Aber ich meine, also da, ja. Und das ist auch in den Jahren davor gewesen. Ich meine, Felix Lokämper, finde ich zum Beispiel, ist ein super Stürmer. Ich glaube, da bin ich relativ alleine. Pascal Köpke, er hat auch total gute Anlagen, er hat auch schon richtig gut gespielt. Und ich habe irgendwie das Gefühl, ich weiß nicht, ob es an den Stürmern liegt oder an der Verbindung zum Mittelfeld oder vielleicht einfach so ein Geist da in dem Kader ist, den man einfach über Jahre nicht rauskriegt. Das ist ja häufig das Problem bei Teams, die sich da trotz personeller Veränderung irgendwie nicht vom Fleck kommen, dass da irgendwie sich so ein Geist, so ein Charakter gebildet hat. Weil St. Pauli war das ganz lange die sogenannte Wohlfühloase, dass die Spieler sich einfach ja dann doch irgendwie so ein bisschen so eine Ambitionslosigkeit entwickelt haben, die jetzt glücklicherweise raus ist. Bei Heidenheim ist es dann vielleicht eher umgekehrt, dass es allen Spielern klar ist, unter so einem gewissen Leistungsminimum geht es einfach nicht. Wenn ich nicht Vollgas gebe, dann schaffe ich es sowieso nicht im Kader. Und das ist dann der positive Effekt da drin. Beim Club hat man irgendwie das Gefühl, dass da genau so negative Mechanismen am Werk sind, die dafür sorgen, dass Spieler, die auch zum Club kommen, einfach ihr Leistungsniveau nicht da erreichen können.
Es ist für uns alle die sechste Stunde heute.
Ja, aber wenn wir gerade bei schlechter Stimmung sind und bei Dingen, die nicht so funktioniert haben, dann können wir jetzt auch noch abschließen über Bielefeld, Regensburg und Sandhausen sprechen. Matthias, in Abwesenheit von Eva müssen wir das jetzt irgendwie uns selber ergründen. Ich meine, wir haben ja auch schon viel darüber gesprochen im Rasenfunk. Aber nachdem du das ja auch mal erlebt hast, also Durchmarsch von unten nach oben und ja auch in die andere Richtung, mit auch schon großen Problemen dann in so einer Zweitliga-Saison, hast du da Parallelen säsen können?
Ja, wobei ich gedacht hätte, dass Bielefeld schon ein gesetzterer Club ist. Die hatten sich auch zwei Jahre jetzt in der Bundesliga gehalten. Und für mich war Bielefeld ein Club, den ich einfach am Anfang so dachte, okay, die tun sich schwer reinzukommen. Das wird aber schon wieder, aber es wurde nie so richtig. Und ich konnte mir jetzt auch nicht erklären, wieso das nie so richtig gefuchtet hat, diese Zehnchen, die ineinander greifen müssen. Weil sie haben schon auch Namen im Kader. Aber offenbar wurde da keine Mannschaft draus, oder zumindest keine, die sich nachhaltig als solche empfindet. Jetzt auch bei den jüngsten Relegationsspielen war das –das erste habe ich nicht gesehen, dass es so in die Hose ging, dass gestern die erste Hälfte, da war viel Wille, aber wenig Kopf, so will ich es mal umschreiben, am Start. Für mich war das nicht absehbar, dass sich dieses Team gar nicht einspielt. Als Koshinat kam und die Lilen da verloren hat, dachte ich, das lässt sich gut an. Da kommen die jetzt in ruhiges Fahrwasser oder kämpfen sich da relativ schnell unten raus, weil Koshinat ja auch ein eher emotionaler Trainer ist, der glaube ich auch in so einer Situation weiß, wie er ein Team zu nehmen hat. Und dann verlieren sie am letzten Spiels halt gesangenglanglos in Magdeburg 4-0 und hätten sogar noch höher verlieren können. Also ist für mich nicht wirklich klar, was da nicht so aufging. Ich meine, ein Hack, der hat Darmstadt in der Hinrunde alleine Probleme bereitet. Den schon in den Griff zu kriegen, ist nicht so einfach, aber offenbar konnte er sich in dem Umfeld auch nicht als Leistungsträger schlussendlich darstellen. Und ich sehe da wirklich viele Fragezeichen. Wir hatten sie ja auch 2014 im Relegationsduell nach unten gezogen in die Trittplastikkeit. Da haben sie sich dann sehr schnell erholt davon und haben ja auch damals einen sehr beeindruckenden Zweitliga-Aufstieg hingelegt in die Bundesliga, sich dort auch gehalten. Also es ist mich eher wirklich überfragt, was da gar nicht aufging in diesen letzten –man muss ja dann womöglich über die Saison hinausblicken –auch schon in der letzten Saison, was da an falschen Stellschrauben gedreht wurde. Womöglich, ich glaube, sie haben auch relativ schnell den ersten Trainer verschlissen. Nach wenigen Spieltagen, schon im August, glaube ich, ging es auseinander. Da konnte man denken, okay, es war ein unbeschriebenes Blatt für deutsche Verhältnisse, aber warum nicht? Sie hatten ja damals auch irgendwann, glaube ich, den Luxemburger aus dem Hut gezaubert, der sie schnell wieder in ruhigeres Fahrwasser gezogen hat. Ja, schwierig. Also ich kann mir keinen rechten Reihen drauf machen.
Ich würde sagen, dass Amine Bielefeld das über die gesamte Saison nicht geschafft hat, die Defensive stabil zu bekommen. Also offensiv war das ja nie ein Problem, die haben ja die …also du sagst, dass Robin Haag, Fabian Kloss, Janis Herra hat da am Ende ja gar keine Rolle mehr gespielt, obwohl das ein echter Superstürmer ist, mit Laszme ist da ein richtig guter Spieler dabei. Okugawa, einer der wahrscheinlich kreativsten Spieler der Liga, finde ich, das war nicht das Problem. Ich glaube, die Defensive war das Problem. Die haben sich einfach …die waren immer gut für zwei Gegentore, egal gegen wen und egal wann im Spiel konnten die sich völlig aus dem Nichts auf Gegentreffer fangen und das haben die einfach die gesamte Saison nicht dicht bekommen. Was du gesagt hast, mit dem Trainerwechsel so früh, das ist natürlich auch ein Problem, wenn du …das führt ja auch diesen Trend gehabt, du kommst irgendwie steigst ab, du hast einen Kader, der dann vielleicht auch ein bisschen zusammen bleibt, der gar nicht so auseinanderfällt, einen Kader, der ein Jahr lang auf den Deckel bekommen hat im Grunde und da musst du erstmal die Bremse ziehen, du musst das erstmal rumreißen und dann kommt ein Trainer, der war noch nie in der Liga, war noch nie im deutschen Fußball, hat dann schöne Ideen, nämlich im Schweizer Fußball läuft das vielleicht alles ein bisschen anders und dann hast du schöne Ideen, wie du dein 4-3-3 oder was irgendwie, wie du da rotieren willst, dann spielst du das erste Spiel in Sandhausen und merkst, das ist ja alles egal. Hier geht es um ganz andere Dinge in der zweiten Liga und das ist natürlich super bitter für so Clubs und da fand ich interessant, weil Führt und Bielefeld sich da so ähnlich gewesen sind zu Saisonbeginn, dass die da beide mit so einem Trainer, mit einer Spielidee einfach an der zweiten Liga als solche gescheitert sind und nicht an dem Spielermaterial oder an dem Kader oder an den Ideen vom Trainer, sondern an der zweiten Liga, an dieser Physis, die da drin ist und so anders, wie die einfach ist, da waren die sich schon ähnlich und Führt hat es halt geschafft, das mit Sonniger dann anzunehmen und Bielefeld ist trotz, obwohl ich die den Kader sogar individuell höher einschätzen würde als von Führt, hat es nicht geschafft, da irgendwie die Defensive stabil zu bekommen.
Also da muss ja in den Köpfen auch irgendwann mal was gegriffen haben. Entweder man hat sich gedacht, too big, too fail, wir werden das schon irgendwie schaffen oder Angst essen Seele, aber vielleicht auch das, dass sie dann irgendwann verstanden haben, oh Gott, also jetzt schlägt es aber wirklich zwölf und wir finden aber gar keinen Stellhebel oder kriegen keinen Knopf dran, und das ging, jetzt Wiesbaden war ja offenbar wirklich hoffnungslos.
Und auch da war die Defensive ja wieder das Problem bei den Toren. Also wie einfach diese Tore gefallen sind für Wiesbaden, die werden wahrscheinlich auch Danke gesagt haben, die kamen ja auch nicht mit der breitesten aller Brüste, die man haben kann, nachdem sie eigentlich auch schon aufgestiegen waren wie der HSV. Ich dachte ja, das wäre so das Glück für Bielefeld, dass da ein Drittliges kommt, der eben nicht mit der Wucht kommt, wie es aus einer Brücke gekommen wäre oder wie es durchgezogen hätte, die aus einem positiven Lauf in die Relegation kamen, sondern sie kamen eben mit einem Rückschlag in die Relegation und trotzdem waren sie in der Lage, vier Tore zu schießen gegen einen Zweite-Liga-Absteiger, der im Jahr zuvor noch Bundesliga gespielt hat, auch mit Spielern, die noch in der Bundesliga waren. Das fand ich schon erschreckend zu sehen. Und diese Sache im Kopf, diese Angst, die war sehr stark zu spüren. Ich glaube, es war ja der 31., der 30. Spieltag, als Bielefeld und Fürth aufeinandertrafen auf der Alm, die Stimmung im Stadion war sehr von einer gewissen Angst geprägt, fand ich. Also die Angst, einfach jetzt zu verlieren und die Angst abzusteigen, die war greifbar in diesem Stadion und sie haben ja das gegen Fürth dann fast noch rumgerissen, haben in der Nachspielzeit das Tor gemacht, aber wegen Abseits wurde das Tor aberkannt und so haben sie es dann eben nicht gewonnen, dieses Spiel gegen Fürth. Das war am Ende für Fürth ein extrem wichtiges Spiel, weil dann Bielefeld noch mal wahrscheinlich herangeschnuppert wäre ansonsten, also man erkennt die Größe und die Wichtigkeit mancher Spiele erst im Nachhinein und das war für Fürth eben dieses Spiel zum Beispiel, ein Bielefeld 1 zu 1 gespielt zu haben, da bestanden zu haben in so einem Spiel, aber auch da hatte Bielefeld defensiv wieder krasse Probleme, also Fürth hätte da auch zwei oder drei Tore schießen können in der ersten Halbzeit, haben sie nicht gemacht, wieder Fürth großes Problem, Tore schießen, auch wenn es gegen Darmstadt nicht so aussah, aber über die Saison hinweg war es auch nicht so, die trifft sich erst die Mannschaft. Und dann ist es eben einfach so, wenn du diese Bremse nicht reinbekommst, egal wie, also sie muss halt irgendwie rein in Fürth, wenn ich ganz kurz was zu Fürth noch sagen darf, war es halt so, dass du diese Bremse reinbekommen hast mit 10 Punkten aus den ersten vier Spielen der Zorniga, dass du in der Hintenrunde auf Platz 9 abgeschlossen hast. Das war für Fürth das Wichtigste, was passieren konnte, dass du da einmal wieder diese Gewissheit hast, Spiele zu gewinnen. Und Bielefeld hat solche Serien, zumindest meines Wissens, wahrscheinlich mag ich es gleich wieder sagen, sie haben sieben Spiele in Folge mal nicht verloren. Aber ich glaube es nicht. Also sie haben diese Serie eben nicht gehabt. Und auch die wichtigen Spiele haben sie eben dann am Ende doch nicht gewonnen. Also sie hätten ja das ziehen können. Sie hätten in Magdeburg gewinnen können. Sie hätten in der Relegation gegen Wiesbaden gewinnen können. Sie haben gegen Fürth, wir haben die Vergleiche von Rostock, Bielefeld gegen Fürth, einen Punkt geholt, die lange auch da unten mitgespielt haben. Das ist halt einfach dann zu wenig. Und ja, es sind Siege schön gegen Darmstadt, haben sie gewonnen.
Das war übrigens auch der Fünf-Spiele-Streak, in dem man ungeschlagen war.
Ja, oder Koschin hat die super gestartet. Das darf man auch nicht vergessen. Das Koschin hat das eigentlich, die auch stabil bekommen hat. Also das, was Matthias sagt, ist ja genau richtig. Also an Uwe Koschin lag das, glaube ich, nicht, sondern der Abstieg war im Grunde vorher schon besiegelt, muss man ja fast sagen. Dann am Ende war es natürlich Angst in den Relegationsspielen. Dann hat einfach nichts mehr funktioniert. Und dann wurde ja durchaus auch öffentlich von Fabian Kloss auch die Charakterfrage ganz klar gestellt. Aber Koschin hat selber, ist glaube ich nicht derjenige, den man da irgendwie die Schuld in die Schuhe schieben sollte.
Aber irgendwie ja Vorte und Schernig auch nicht. Weil wenn sich etwas so lange durchzieht, und da kannst du eigentlich ja auch die Erstliga-Saison, zumindest die Rückrunde mit reinnehmen, dass du eben einfach nicht stabil bist hinten. Und ich meine, in der Offensive –sie haben die acht beste Offensive, 50 Tore –es war wirklich die Abwehr. Zwei schlechteste Abwehr. Und wenn das keiner dieser Trainer hinbekommt, und aber auch keiner von denen die Zeit bekommt, sich da rauszuarbeiten. Natürlich gibt es –es gab super Gründe, Uli Vorte sehr früh zu entlassen, haben wir hier auch besprochen. Und auch mit Czerny geht es dann irgendwann nicht mehr weiter. Man konnte das schon nachvollziehen, aber wie soll denn sich da auch irgendwie eine Stabilität herausbilden, wenn du das nicht hast? Und das, was dann Fabian Klos dann nach diesem 0 zu 4 in Wiesbaden gesagt hat –also Matthias sei froh, dass du es nicht gesehen hast –man hat sich fast ungut dabei gefühlt, da hinzugucken. Weil das einfach so spiegebildlich war wie Stuttgart gegen HSV, wo auch der VfB noch viel höher hätte gewinnen können. So war das an diesem Spiel auch dann plus noch mit den Fans, die dann auch nicht mehr an sich halten konnten und das Spiel lange unterbrochen wurde usw. Und Fabian Klos war dann alles in einem. Fabian Klos war der einzige Typ auf dem Feld, der irgendwie noch eine Aggressivität in Zweikämpfen hatte und vielleicht noch so einen Hauch von Chancen. Fabian Klos war dann Pressesprecher, hat danach alle Interviews alleine gemacht. Fabian Klos war der Sicherheitsbeauftragte, er ist zu den Fans gegangen, hat mit Gegenspielern, Ordnungsdienst und anderen Leuten gesprochen, wie man da jetzt weitermachen könnte. Und Fabian Klos hat aber als allerletztes auch noch die komplette Mannschaft unter den Bus geworfen als Kapitän. Aber der wird das nicht leichtfertig gemacht haben. Und alle Bielefeld-Fans standen an der Seite von Fabian Klos. Ich kenne keinen einzigen, der danach gesagt hat, das gibt es ja nicht. Was hat der sich denn erlaubt? Alle haben gesagt, ja, er hat so recht. Wir sind einfach keine Mannschaft. Und das war einfach nicht gut. Also bei Bielefeld sind so viele Dinge schlecht gelaufen. Also mich hat es fast noch gewundert, wie positiv eigentlich das Rückspiel fast so lief. Also klar hat man da wieder wahnsinnig dumme Gegentore kassiert. Also wirklich wahnsinnig dumm wieder. Aber wer Bielefeld-Spiele gesehen hat, den hat das nicht gewundert. Aber man hatte immerhin eigene Chancen und lag auch mal in Führung. Das war fast schon positiv. Aber was da bei Bielefeld, glaube ich, einschließlich so Personalien wie Sami Arabi, Abgang im Umfeld des Vereins, also ich meine, Eva erzählt das ja immer hier wunderbar im Rasenfunk und wird das ja bestimmt auch wieder tun in der Zukunft. Aber das war einfach ein Clusterfuck. Und während so eine Saison läuft, sieht man das immer nicht, weil man immer das Gefühl hat, so wie du, Matthias, dachte ich auch. Man hat dieses 3 zu 3 gegen Braunschweig. Das war zwar unglücklich, weil nach Führung und so weiter, aber dann dieses 3 zu 1 gegen Darmstadt, 2 zu 2 gegen Nürnberg, 3 zu 2 in Kiel, 2 zu 2 gegen Düsseldorf. Da dachte ich auch, ha, Korschenat, der hält da jetzt mal kurz die Hand drauf. Und dann klappt das. Aber das, worüber er da die Hand gehalten hat, das war halt schon irgendwie in mehrere Teile zerbrochen. Und das hat man da noch nicht gesehen. Und im Nachhinein ist es dann so ein Abstieg, wo du dann rückblickend sagen kannst, die haben darum gebattelt. Das musste irgendwie so passieren. Während die Saison läuft, kann man es sich nicht vorstellen, aber das ist wie Schalke vor drei Jahren runtergegangen ist, so wie Hertha jetzt runtergegangen ist in der ersten Liga. Ich kenne mich halt in der ersten bisschen besser aus, deswegen kommen daher jetzt mal Beispiele. Und so ist es jetzt aber auch, dass Bielefeld durchgereicht wurde. Ich glaube, in zwei, drei, vier, fünf Jahren wird man zurückblicken und wird sagen, ja, das war völlig logisch, da waren einfach ganz viele Dinge schief in diesem Verein.
Ja, also du hast ja gerade schon begonnen, gewisse Resultate aufzurufen. Ich habe gerade mal überschlagen, Koschnert war jetzt inklusive Relegation in 13 Spielen da und hat gerade mal drei gewonnen. Das ist natürlich auch keine Bilanz, die ich ihm jetzt zugeschrieben hätte, aber unterstreicht womöglich das, was du sagst. Also, dass da einfach schon was angelegt war, was er nicht beheben konnte.
So ging es jetzt runter für Arminia Bielefeld in einer wirklich schlimmen Relegation, aber decken wir den Mantel des Schweigens darüber. Und dann haben wir noch Regensburg und Sandhausen. Wir müssen da nicht mehr ganz tief ins Detail gehen, weil gerade zu denen habe ich den vorletzten oder letzten Kurzpass gemacht. Ich bin mir gerade gar nicht mehr sicher, aber wir haben da quasi ausführlicher drüber gesprochen. Aber irgendwie ist es ja auch so Tim, der Abschied der Urgesteine so ein bisschen. Also, weißt du, Heidenheim steigt in die 1. Liga auf, Sandhausen in die 3. Liga ab. Was ist denn jetzt dann der Verein, zu dem alle hin müssen, den wir als Symbol nehmen für die ach so schlimme 2. Bundesliga? Und Regensburg ist… Elbersberg. Muss man ja nicht mal weit weg. Also, ist er sogar geografisch irgendwie noch in der Nähe. Aber wie schaust du auf den Abstieg von den beiden? Also, bei Regensburg vielleicht ein bisschen, da hat man schon öfter gesehen, dass es knapp wird. Aber Sandhausen war ja eigentlich so, naja, die bleiben irgendwie immer drin. Keiner weiß warum, aber alle fahren dann hin.
Ja, es ist ja bei beiden so gewesen, dass man immer dachte, ja, Sandhausen, Regensburg, ich weiß gar nicht, wie oft die –also, wir machen bei Mellantoon ja auch immer so ein Tippspiel vor der Saison –wie oft die beiden auf die letzten beiden Plätze getippt werden. Und ich meine, das waren ja hinter dem FC St. Pauli waren ja Heidenheim, Sandhausen und Regensburg eben die dienstältesten Clubs in der Liga. Und die sind jetzt alle drei weg sozusagen. Gerade bei Sandhausen ist es dann doch –ja, ich will gar nicht sagen, dass mit der Verein, aber einige von den Leuten da, mit denen man auch zu tun hatte, die sind mir doch ganz schön ans Herz gewachsen. Und das war schon echt schmerzhaft, das zu sehen, wie da auf Bielefeld –hast du gerade sehr schön ausgeführt, Max –dieses Totalversagen auf vielen Ebenen, das ist, glaube ich, in Sandhausen vor allem dann, seit Uwe Koschin da weg ist, tatsächlich auch passiert, ne? Da gab es auch viele Entscheidungen, die dann nicht nachvollziehbar waren. Da hörte man dann auch immer, dass das im Kader auch intern nicht stimmt. Da sind dann Leute irgendwie, also ganz komische Dinge dann vorgefallen und da passte dann einfach vieles nicht. Und ja, dann wird es auch schwierig so, ne? Also dann war es jetzt auch einfach mal Zeit für Sandhausen. Muss man ja fast schon sagen, die sind ja in den letzten Jahren, haben sich dann doch immer irgendwie geschafft, da dem Abstieg noch von der Schippe zu springen. Aber dieses Jahr hat es das statistisch schlechteste Team seit Jahren, das schlechteste Team, hat es dann auch mal erwischt, kann man sagen. Und bei Regensburg tut es mir ja fast ebenso leid, weil ich da Meersatzsäle Bergovic sehr schätze. Auch ein Trainer mit einer ganz klaren Handschrift, der aus sehr wenig Mitteln da in Regensburg immer sehr viel rausgeholt hat, sehr gute Spieler da entwickelt hat, sie auch besser gemeint hat, wenn ich da am Besuschkopf denke, Benedikt Gimba, so einer der Aggressiv-Lieder schlechthin in der 2. Liga eigentlich, das war, Regensburg war auf jeden Fall echt so der Inbegriff des unangenehmen 2. Liga-Teams. Und das ist schon schade, dass die beiden gehen, auch wenn das jetzt nicht die schönsten Auswärtsfahrten waren, allein aufgrund der Länge, gehörte das irgendwie dazu, diese Schmerzen, die diese Clubs auf dem Platz den Gegnern bereitet haben.
Ich habe vorhin natürlich auch über diese Ruhe gesprochen in den Vereinen, die hatte Regensburg auch lange, und das hatte der in der letzten Kurzpassfolge mit Max Gieser, aus Regensburg. Diese Ruhe war eben nicht mehr da, also mit Christian Keller hat das irgendwie alles funktioniert, hat alles in der Hand gehabt, alles lief einfach fast schon zu perfekt. Jetzt merkt man mal, was eine Person ausmachen kann, wenn sie eben so stark ist in einem Verein. Und Tobias Werner konnte diese Lücke eben nicht ausfüllen, wer das nochmal näher hören will, ich fand das ja sehr anzündlich dargestellt, wie das da alles lief in Regensburg. Und jetzt wird es spannend zu sehen sein, wie der Verein sich in der dritten Liga entwickelt, weil da ist jetzt dann eben kein Schwergewicht, das da runterkommt, wie Aminia Bielefeld, die schon mal nachgewiesen haben, dass es schnell wieder nach oben gehen kann, sondern der Jan. Klar, der war auch schon mal in der dritten Liga, aber er ist jetzt da auch finanziell jetzt nicht der größte Verein, noch nicht mit dem größten Zuschauerschnitt zum Beispiel da unten drin. Also das kann schon auch zäh werden, wenn man jetzt nicht die komplett richtigen Entscheidungen trifft im nächsten Sommer und auch wieder Ruhe in diesem Verein bekommt, weil das hat den Verein ausgezeichnet und das war einer der Gründe, warum sie abgestiegen sind, aber hat natürlich auch gepaart damit, dass sie eben einer dieser Vereine waren, die ihre wichtigen Spiele auch nicht gewonnen haben. Also sie haben an den Viertsten zum Beispiel in einem sehr, sehr wichtigen Spiel im Abschließkampf die klar bessere Mannschaft in der ersten Halbzeit und am Ende hat er dann 2-1 verloren. Danach war Khan Chalis Khaner in der Mixed Zone und er hat dann gesagt, das ist beschissen zu spielen, weil du weißt, du kannst mit jedem mithalten, du kannst sehr guten Fußball spielen. Das fand ich auch, wie Tim sagt, Basile Minkovic, die Weiterentwicklung fand ich da so krass. Die haben wirklich guten Fußball gespielt in der ersten Halbzeit, was man von Jan Regensburg neben diesem Körperlichen gar nicht so gewohnt war. Aber dann sieht man auch wieder, dass die Kaderqualität nicht die allerhöchste ist. Wenn du bis zum 16er guten Fußball spielst, hast du keine Lösung im 16er und auch keinen Stürmer, der dir wahnsinnig viele Tore garantiert hat, wobei Uwe Wussow ja auch 9 oder so gemacht hat. Die hatten einen Stürmer, aber dahinter war nicht so viel. Aber ich glaube, schlimmer war natürlich diese Unruhe, die jenes im ganzen Verein aufgekommen ist. Das wird die größte Baustelle sein, das wieder zu befrieden und in ruhige Bahnen zu lenken und dann einen koordinierten Neuaufbau zu starten.
Was mir auffällt, also Sandhausen und Regensburg waren letztes Jahr auch knapp über dem Strich. Deshalb kommt es nicht überraschend, dass der Middentunnel die regelmäßig auf die letzten beiden Plätze tippt, sondern dass sie da jetzt auch tatsächlich angekommen sind, was bei Regensburg ins Auge sticht. Sie hatten letztes Jahr ein Torverhältnis von 50 zu 51, also minus eins auf Rang 15. Das ist schon bemerkenswert. Und dieses Jahr ging es doch deutlich nach hinten mit minus 24 beim Torverhältnis 34 zu 58. Und da lohnt es sich vielleicht schon auch ein Blick auf die Transfers, also wen haben sie denn alles verloren? Und das hat man vielleicht nicht mehr so vor Augen. Aber sie haben zum Beispiel Besuschkow, viele hier schon als Einwort oder als Einnahme haben sie verloren, Wegesser nach Nürnberg, der auch immer eine Giftigkeit an den Platz gelegt hat, die unangenehm war, Mayer als Torwart natürlich auch zu Dortmund gegangen, nicht zu unterschlagen. Und Bukalfa ging jetzt zu St. Pauli, da hat er, glaube ich, nicht wirklich eine Rolle gespielt, aber der war auch letztes Jahr schon wichtig. Also es fielen doch ein paar Säulen weg, die, glaube ich, für den letztjährigen Klassenerhalt wichtig waren und diese nicht in der Form ersetzt bekommen haben. Ich glaube, wir haben ja auch zur Winterpause einen ganz jungen Keeper von Köln geholt und reingeworfen, der sich, glaube ich, auch alles in allem achtbar geschlagen hat, aber zeigt ja auch, da hängen die Trauben eher hoch, was dann auch das Transferfenster anbetrifft und da muss halt was sitzen, was jetzt dann doch nicht so saß, aber Tim, hebt schon die Hand.
Ich habe nicht die Hand gehoben, ich habe nur gerade bei den Spielern, die weggegangen sind, habe ich gerade überlegt, Jan-Niklas Beste ist doch bei den Regensburgs gewesen.
Klar, auch er, allen voran.
Und dann war Sarpit Singh, der konnte ja die ganze Hinrunde nicht spielen, der war ja in der letzten Saison auch eine tragende Rolle gespielt, in der Rückrunde, anfangs auch, jetzt noch. Ich glaube, da ist ja viel zusammen gelaufen, viel auch unglücklich gelaufen und das hat man irgendwie nicht aufheben können. Ich finde das interessant, diese Personalkeller, wie wichtig die ja dann doch gewesen ist und was so eine Personalie dann in so einem Umfeld doch auch auslösen kann, was für eine Ruhe sie ausstrahlen kann und was es dann bedeutet, wenn die Person dann vielleicht nicht mehr da ist und das dann irgendwie anders verteilt werden muss, dass das dann auch richtig schiefgehen kann. Also wie krass so ein Unternehmen, ich meine selbst Regensburg ist so eine Multimillionenunternehmung, wie sehr das dann von den unternehmerischen Entscheidungen einzelner Personen abhängt, das finde ich dann doch immer noch bemerkenswert.
Aber wirklich, und es ist eine Mammut-Aufgabe, Ende Mai, vielleicht hat sich inzwischen was getan, aber Ende Mai hatte der Jan weniger als fünf Spieler im Kader stehen für die Drittligasaison, die ja auch nicht so wahnsinnig lange auf sich warten lässt. Also Probleme haben natürlich viele Absteiger, gerade von der zweiten aus der dritten Liga, weil du da eben nicht mehr auch noch die Drittliga-Zugehörigkeiten, die Verträge reinschreiben kannst. Das machen die Spieler nicht mit, kannst du dir nicht leisten und so weiter und so fort. Erste zu zweite Liga klappt es ja noch häufiger. Also das wird schwierig und wir werden es dann begleiten, was die drei Absteiger machen und ob sie wieder hochkommen. Bielefeld, Regensburg und Sandhausen. Wir haben jetzt ein paar Vereine logischerweise nicht angesprochen, ich glaube die sind aber die meisten davon sind sogar relativ happy. Also Hannover 96 ist ganz gut weggekommen, weil wir haben nicht über sie gesprochen. Herzlichen Glückwunsch dazu. Holstein Kiel leider ein bisschen unterbelichtet in dieser Rasenfunk-Saison. Es ist mir bewusst, es haben sich ein paar von euch bei mir gemeldet. Ihr habt völlig recht, aber in der Phase, wo ihr dann darum gebeten habt, dass Holstein Kiel Schwerpunkt wird, hatten die wirklich so gar nichts mehr zu gewinnen. Und es war überall noch spannend oben und unten. Deswegen, es tut mir leid, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Ich habe es aber für die nächste Saison auf dem Zettel. Abschließende Frage an euch alle drei. Derjenige, der den ersten Gedanken hat, muss einfach nach vorne preschen. Gibt es irgendeine schöne Geschichte, irgendeine Anekdote, irgendetwas, wo ihr zumindest jetzt das Gefühl habt? Daran könnte ich mich immer erinnern, wenn ich an diese Saison zurückdenke. Vielleicht ist es bei Matthias am einfachsten, weil der hat so Aufstiegserinnerungen. Aber auch liegalübergreifend, wenn dir was einfällt, gibt es noch Geschichten, die hängen bleiben, sage ich mal.
Also bei mir macht sich allen voran die Erinnerung natürlich an das Spiel gegen Magdeburg breit. Aber da war es nicht eine Euphorie, sondern eine Erleichterung. Also man hatte zwei Matchbälle liegen lassen und man wusste am letzten Spieltag jetzt nach Fürth. Da ist dann nach dann womöglich drei vergebenden Matchbällen der Druck noch größer. Also deshalb war es da tatsächlich eine Erleichterung, dieses Ganze eingetüte zu haben, was jetzt auch nicht super erwartbar war. Also man war Fürther, ja, in der vorangegangenen Saison und dann wird man automatisch auch irgendwie in den Kreis der Ausstiegsanwärter gezählt, aber das war kein Selbstläufer und deshalb war das einfach die Erleichterung, die sich bei mir breitgetan hat. Aber ich denke gerne noch ein bisschen auf einen prägnenden Moment vielleicht rum oder einen ganz schönen Moment. Vielleicht haben wir die anderen in der Zwischenzeit ausgeguckt.
Es gab einmal diese tolle Konferenz –ich muss einmal kurz gucken, wann das war –genauer, Samstag. Das war der letzte Spiel vor Ende der Hinrunde. Da gab es eine tolle Konferenz. HSV Sandhausen 4-2, KSC St. Pauli 4-4, Heidenheim Regensburg 5-4. Das war toll. Da habe ich das St. Pauli-Spiel im einzigen Stream geguckt und mir das andere in der Konferenz angeschaut. Das habe ich sehr genossen.
Ich kann mich daran erinnern, weil ich bei einem Spiel meines Sohnes war, der sein letztes Spiel in der Runde gehabt hat, so die kleinen ABC-Schützen. Ich dachte mir, was ist jetzt auf Notification gestellt, warum geht so etwas da ab? Da kann ich mich auch daran erinnern. Es war ein Trister drüber, ein grauer Tag.
Samstag 13 Uhr ist normalerweise das echte Mal. Man muss das ehrlich sagen, 2. Liga, Samstag 13 Uhr. Das ist einfach eine scheiß Anschlusszeit. So sind häufig die Spieler auch um 13 Uhr. Dann kommt so eine Konferenz dabei raus. Daran erinnere ich mich gerne zurück, auch wenn das 4-4 von St. Pauli ist. Der KSC hat überhaupt vier Tore gemacht. Unding, aber das ist eine andere Sache.
Ja, ihr erwartet wahrscheinlich sehnsüchtig auf meine Antwort. Aber es war so eine Saison aus vierter Sicht. Es ist schwer, viel sich auf andere Dinge zu freuen. Ich freue mich darüber, dass Magdeburg mit so einem schönen Fußball drin geblieben ist. Es sind so kleine Dinge, aber so große Dinge gibt es einfach nicht. Weil diese Saison einfach auch als Begleiter, der jede Woche darüber schreiben und sprechen muss, so aufreibend war, dass ich einfach nur froh bin, dass die Saison vorbei ist, und dass ich es aus meinem Gedächtnis irgendwann streichen kann. Wahrscheinlich ist die schönste Geschichte, aus der führte sich tatsächlich, dass Alexander Zorniger hierher kam. Weil dieser Einfluss, da haben wir auch wieder, was ein Mensch ausmachen kann in einem Verein. Man hat trotzdem den dritthöchsten Zuschauerschnitt in 25 Jahren Probi-Fußball seit Wiederaufstieg 97. Und das, finde ich, liegt viel am Trainer, der viel über den Tellerrand hinaus schaut, der mit den Fans auch kommuniziert. Ich hatte vorhin Thorsten Lieberknecht, der diese schöne Aussage hatte. Zorniga geht zu einem ähnlichen Weg in Fürth auch. Dass er die Rolle der Fans betont. Das ist ja auch immer schön, wenn Trainer, finde ich, nicht nur in PKs darüber gesprochen haben, war schön, Glückwunsch an den Gegner und nächste Woche wollen wir gewinnen, sondern auch Geschichten liefert. Und das hat Thorsten Lieberknecht in meiner PK erwähnt. Das ist schön, dass so Typen wie Zorniga auch in der Liga zu haben, die mehr liefern als nur ein Fußballtrainer. In der Gänze sind es viele schöne Momente, die dich damit verbinden. Aber mit dem Fußball in dieser Saison ist es schwierig.
Ich finde, was man abschließend sagen kann, dass die 2. Liga schon eine attraktive Liga ist. Eine Liga, in der der Wettbewerb funktioniert. Offenbar im Gegensatz zu einer Etage höher. Ich werde nächstes Jahr berichten, wie ich es da empfinden werde. Aber es ist einfach eine Liga, die interessante Teams hat, die auch große Namen hat, die viele Zuschauer anzieht. Ich fühle mich da gut aufgehoben. Jetzt bin ich zwar mal einen Moment weg mit meinem Team, aber ich denke, wir werden wiederkommen. Deshalb hat die 2. Liga schon durchaus mehr als nur ein Augenmerk oder eine Randnotiz verdient. Das ist so mein Präsumé.
Ja, da muss ich aus einer berichterstattenden Rolle von jemandem, der sonst eben sich viel zu viel mit der 1. Liga abgibt, das muss ich genauso bestätigen. Oder darf das genauso bestätigen. Mir hat es total gutgetan, wieder regelmäßiger in die 2. Liga der Männer zu schauen. Es war ja vorher kein Unwillen oder irgendwie so. Es war einfach zeitlich nicht möglich. Aber die Dynamiken dieser Liga sind so, wie man es sich halt wünschen würde. Dadurch, dass die besten Teams immer weggehen und die schlechtesten, deswegen ist man so eng beieinander. Das ist ja sehr, sehr leicht erklärbar. Und da muss man jetzt gar nicht mit so Claims kommen, wie die beste 2. Liga aller Zeiten und so ein Kram. Das ist mir völlig egal. Ich finde, da tun auch namhafte Absteiger natürlich etwas mit der Liga. Aber so der große Effekt ist es dann doch nicht. Zumindest war es das letzte Mal so, als mit Werder und Schalke zwei große runtergegangen sind. Die sind dann direkt wieder hochgegangen. Da war ich dann vom Ergebnis her eher etwas ernüchtert. Wer weiß, wie das jetzt diesmal wird. Wir gucken es uns an. Aber ich habe noch vergessen, dass wir noch eine allerletzte Frage haben. Denn ich glaube, Tim war es. Oder? Tim, du hast uns doch vorhin begrüßt mit, jeder von euch muss einen Lieblingsspieler nennen, der nicht vom eigenen Verein kommt. Und weil du diese fiese Frage gestellt hast, gehe ich davon aus, du bist der Einzige, der quasi bewaffnet in diese Frage reinkommt. Deswegen darfst du anfangen. Und dann können die anderen beiden nämlich noch kurz überlegen.
Ja, aber über Tim Kleinwies haben wir ja schon gesprochen, ne?
Das heißt, du bringst diese Frage mit und hast dann die Kreativantwort, den Torschützenkönig zu nehmen und beantwortest sie in drei Sekunden. Das war dein ganzer Plan. Du bist doch auch Podcaster, Tim.
Ja, ich überlege jetzt noch in der Zwischenzeit, während ich den anderen beiden die Antwort weggenommen habe.
Ich bin natürlich auch bei Kleindienst, aber in Kombination mit BESTE. Dass dieses 3 zu 2 in der 99. Minute tatsächlich auch noch eine Kombi aus den beiden ist. BESTE gibt rein, Kleindienst steht da, wo er stehen muss und verwertet eiskalt. Die beiden sind für mich schon die beiden, die natürlich den Stempel auf diese Saison aufgedrückt haben. Auch wenn die Ligien zahlreiche Spieler haben, die es verdient hätten, hier Erwähnung zu finden. Aber ich glaube, die beiden, gerade was einfach die Wucht und die vielleicht auch manchmal Standardstärke, aber einfach auch Heidenheim, was die auf den Rasen bringen, da waren die zwei schon ein starker Faktor. Und deshalb sind bei mir ist dieses Tandem eher so, was ich nennen würde, einen eigenen Spieler, darf ich ja nicht nennen.
Ich werde auch noch zwei Namen in den Ring, von zwei Vereinen, die wir gar nicht besprochen haben, und da wird es noch ein bisschen rund kriegen hier. Marvin Wanicek vom KSC hat mir sehr gut gefallen in den Spielen. Und Fabian Reese. Auch ein bisschen Befangenheit, weil ich länger mit ihm telefoniert habe, war ja früher mal in Fürth. Da haben wir so ein bisschen als Chancen-Tot verschrieben. Das hat er sehr angenehm kritisch reflektiert. Ein super Typ, hat mir damals dann vorgeschwerbt, dass er jetzt ja die Bundesliga wechselt zu Hertha. Er bleibt der zweite Liga erhalten. Also er spielt ja nächstes Jahr auch hier. Ich gehe mal davon aus, dass sich da in den Verträgen nichts geändert hat. Da kann sich Hertha freuen. Die Entwicklung, die er genommen hat von einem Stürmer, der nicht so viele Tore gemacht hat, der oftmals Tore gute Chancen vergeben hat, zu einem richtig guten Schienenspieler, der ja links und rechts gespielt hat. Das muss man auch noch sagen. Der hat auf beiden Seiten der Kette immer wieder gespielt. Die beiden haben mir sehr gut gefallen. Aber Wadizek war fast noch mehr als Riesel. Das sind so Spieler, die fallen gar nicht so sehr auf. Auch Karlsruhe ist bis unterm Radar gelaufen natürlich immer mal wieder. Aber der hat da eine wahnsinnig prägende Rolle gehabt. Ich habe mir im Stadion gedacht, warum spielt er beim KSC und nicht in der Bundesliga? Vielleicht wird er da irgendwann auch mal spielen.
Da würde ich vielleicht noch einen letzten Namen dropen, nämlich Paul Nebel auf KSC, also ausgeliehen von Mainz. Er könnte so ein One-to-Watch-Spieler sein, also noch sehr jung, gerade mal 20. Er hat auch schon in der 2. Liga während der Laie gezeigt, was er kann und dass er jetzt noch mal in Karlsruhe bleibt, in einem Umfeld, wo auch junge Spieler wachsen können. Es gibt ja auch einen defensiven Mittelfeldspieler, relativ jung. Den Namen kann ich euch wahrscheinlich… Trimbreithaut. Genau, der ja auch schon mit anderen Vereinen ins Spiel gebracht wird. Da kann Karlsruhe gerne auch mal ein bisschen Aufmerksamkeit verdienen, weil vorhin klang es an, Nürnberg schafft es nicht, junge Leute zu integrieren oder den guten Unterbau irgendwie gewinnbringend nach oben, sich bemerkbar zu machen. Karlsruhe ist immer ein Club, der junge Spieler schafft, herauszubringen. Also in Darmstadt mit Nebel, mit Melem oder auch mit Baader, zwei, die aus einem KSC-Unterbau kommen. Und ja, da gibt es immer wieder Breithaupt und Konsorten. Davon auch ruhig erwähnen an der Stelle.
Überhaupt ist ja der KSC ein Verein, auf dem man schon… Also der fliegt immer ein bisschen unter dem Radar, aber auch die Kraft dieses Vereins ist spielbar. Mit dem neuen Stadion jetzt natürlich haben wir auch was geschaffen. Ich finde, das ist ein Verein, da wird es mich nicht überraschen, wenn sie nächstes Jahr dann oben mitspielen. Auch mit Christian Eichner, ein sehr sympathischer Trainer, der auch an seiner Idee festhält, er junge Spieler entwickeln kann. Ein spannendes Team mit in einem Umfeld, wo auch regelmäßig über 20.000 Zuschauer, wenn Sie mich nicht alles täuscht, jetzt da sind. Also das kann schon auch gut werden nächste Saison. Also das sind Vereine, da bin ich sehr viel positiver gestimmt als bei anderen in dieser Liga. Auch Heustern Kiel haben wir jetzt, haben wir vorhin gesagt, dass Max, ich glaube, da wird sich dann bald schon mal in der neuen Saison dann auch mal kurz was anbieten. Also sehr spannende Transfers jetzt im Sommer. Und in anderem ja Sima Kalla von, weiß nicht, wie er ausgesprochen wird, aber aus Osnabrück. Also wahnsinnig gut, auch viele junge, spannende Transfers, kann ich dir auch sagen. Also letztes Jahr haben auch viele gesagt, Fötter hat wahnsinnig tolle, junge Transfers. Da ist das Spiel, da wie Sidney Räbecke, die 18 Minuten in einer Saison gespielt haben. Das kann auch nach hinten losgehen, aber trotzdem klingt bei diesen beiden Vereinen, bin ich schon mal gespannt auf nächste Saison. Und dann denkt man auch so, die Saison ist vorbei, aber eigentlich schon wieder so eine Vorfreude da auf solche Mannschaften eben. Oder jetzt Magdeburg hat auch schon ganz gute Transfers getätigt.
Das ist schön. Ich freue mich auch. Ich werfe jetzt auch noch einen Namen rein, weil er noch nicht genannt wurde. Und zwar Terence Boyd vom 1. FCK Sais Laudon. Und der Grund dafür ist aber, dass ich da zu arrogant auf ihn geblickt habe. Ich habe die Schlussphase der Drittligasaison in der letzten Saison mitverfolgt und dann auch die Relegation. Und ich wusste ja schon, was Terence Boyd für den FCK bedeutet und so weiter. Und dann habe ich den gesehen und dann hat er da auch getroffen. Ich dachte mir, nie im Leben reicht das für die 2. Liga. Was ist denn das? Und der wurde dann nämlich auch so hochgejubelt von den Kommentatoren, die ihn ja natürlich auch die ganze Saison gesehen hatten. Ich dachte mir so, es tut mir leid. Also das soll ja ein ganz toller Typ sein, aber ich sehe es einfach nicht, wie der in der 2. Liga wirklich Tore machen sollen. Und vom Beginn an war alles, was er getan hat, ein ausgestreckter Mittelfinger gegenüber meiner Kompetenz, die ganz offensichtlich nicht vorhanden ist, 13 Tore gemacht. Ich meine klar, hinten raus die Rückrunde beim Lautern haben wir vorhin thematisiert, aber da lag ich richtig daneben, habe total bewiesen, dass ich keinen Blick für Spiele habe. Ich könnte vielleicht gerade mal Scout beim FC Bayern, aber mehr würde ich mir nicht zutrauen.
Ich glaube, mit Boyd ging es dir nicht alleine so. Also er war auch im Vorfeld des Ligenspiels bei einem Partner-Podcast zu Gast, also sprich einem anderen 98er-Podcast und da hat er selber gesagt, er war ja auch mal bei den Ligien noch zu ersten Liga-Zeiten in dieser 2. Saison, als eigentlich die Mannschaft nicht wirklich wettbewerbsfähig war und dann war er auch noch in der 2. Liga da, aber da hat er als Typ Spuren hinterlassen, aber nicht zählbar auf dem Spielfels, in dem Maße, wie es einem Stürmer eigentlich zugeschrieben wird. Und dann hat er gesagt, in Kaiserslautern hat er erst die Ruhe gefunden. Also er hat sich davor zu viel Druck gemacht und dann in Kaiserslautern ist er erfahrener, ist älter geworden, ist jetzt zweifelslos nicht mehr jung. Aber hat dann doch jetzt durch einen Abstecher in die USA und über Halle, danach Kaiserslautern, sprich, er hat einfach noch mehr Erfahrung gesammelt. Er hat eine Ruhe gefunden, die ihm hilft auf dem Spielfeld und offenkundig ja, wie du jetzt anmerkst, auch zählbar hilft. Insofern war es für ihn selber vielleicht auch gar nicht absehbar. Funktioniert das in der zweiten Liga, aber er hat es bewiesen. Das ist natürlich auch schön, wenn es beim Spieler funktioniert, der was zu sagen hat, der auch gegenüber Rassismus offen Farbe bekennt, wenn man das so sagen darf, ist er selber auch angefeindet und betroffen. Aber er ist auf jeden Fall ein Charakterkopf. Und jetzt auch erfolgreich in der zweiten Liga unterwegs gewesen.
Das stimmt.
Das bindet doch das hier ganz wunderbar ab. Ich danke euch dreien sehr, sehr herzlich, dass ihr euch ausführlich Zeit genommen habt und dass wir auch in dieser Konstellation sprechen konnten. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Tim Ecksteen vom Millerton. So bist du auch bei Twitter zu finden. Danke dir, lieber Tim, dass du mal wieder mit dabei bist. Danke an Michael Fischer, den Ed Flachpass Unterstrich. Ihr hört natürlich alle den 4. Flachpass, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Danke dir, Michael, dass du mit dabei warst.
Ich sage auch danke und komme gerne wieder in der nächsten Saison, wenn ich darf.
Ja, aber ihr müsst alle drei. Ich werde euch so auf den Nerv gehen. Matthias, halt dann in der ersten Liga. Das war jetzt schon mal hier Schlusskonferenz-Vorgeschmack für dich. Lieber Matthias Kneifl, Ed Kickschuhblock auf Twitter. Danke dir, dass du mal wieder mit dabei warst. Mir auch. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, das war unser Rückblick auf die 2. Bundesliga der Männer in der Saison 2022-23. Wenn euch noch ein Rückblick zur ersten Bundesliga der Männer interessiert, dann habt ihr da den Rasenfunk Royale. Wenn euch ein Rückblick auf die 1. Bundesliga der Frauen interessiert, gibt es auch eine Schlusskonferenz. Und wenn euch noch ein Rückblick auf die europäischen Männer-Top-League interessiert, dann checkt mal am Montagnachmittag, den 12. Juni, eure Podcatcher. Da wird es dann etwas Neues geben. Da warten wir natürlich noch auf das Champions League-Finale und das Europe Conference League-Finale, das gerade läuft und so weiter und so fort. Und danach ist aber Schluss. Das sage ich jetzt gleich. Kommt mir jetzt bitte nicht mit, wann machst du dann die dritte Liga? Ja, vielleicht wann anders. Vielleicht in der nächsten Saison. Na ja, lieben Dank für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk finanziell. rasenfunk.de/supportersknapp, da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht. Bleibt gesund, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Das war die Rasenfunk Schlusskonferenz.